Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Ist dir die Hitze gut überstanden?
Ja, denn ich habe ja zu Hause eine Klimaanlage.
Ja, das ist sehr vorteilhaft. Unsereiner, die armen Kirchenmäuse, haben natürlich keine, sondern nur ein Dachgeschoss. Und ich habe die Tage im Freibad verbracht. Und es war zu warm. Ich weiß nicht genau die Nachrichtenlage. Ich hätte gedacht, es kommt ein bisschen mehr Stress auf, aber ich habe auch nicht mehr so den Zugang. Ich weiß, also ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht, wo ich nachgucken müsste, um zu erfahren, was RTL aktuell oder ob es das überhaupt noch gibt und so.
Wie die jetzt noch darüber reden. Und auch das Regionalfernsehen hat schon relativ viel über die Hitze berichtet. Es sind ja Leute zusammengebrochen auf der Straße. Auch was das für wirtschaftliche Auswirkungen hat. Denn wenn man das mal durchrechnet, ist es nicht nur in Spanien, sondern auch in Deutschland natürlich inzwischen so, dass diese Hitze Einbußen beim BIP bedeutet.
In Spanien minus 1,4, habe ich gedacht.
Ja, man kann es also auch aus einer wirtschaftlichen Perspektive sich ansehen. Naja, und das ist schon sehr drastisch. Und ich war noch auf der Fülcolón. Und ja, da war dann der Saal klimatisiert. Das hilft. Aber irgendwann muss man mal raus oder rein. Und dann merkt man es schon.
Also ich habe mir vorgenommen, es sind ja jetzt so zehn Tage, bis es mal wieder über 30 ist. Ich werde jetzt mit KI-Hilfe Hitzepläne. Also klar, man kann jetzt ausweichen in Orte, wo es Klimaanlage gibt und so. Aber freibergab, da gibt es noch so ein bisschen Optimierungspotenzial finde ich. Schon allein bei der Frage, wo stehe ich eigentlich mein Fahrrad hin? Wie finde ich raus, wo 15 Uhr der Schatten steht und so?
Das macht jetzt alles die KI bei dir bald.
Ja, also es gibt verschiedene Apps, zum Beispiel für Fotografie, wo du so Schattenverläufe schon mal voraussägen kannst für den ganzen Tag. Und so. Und die kann man ja alle umnutzen jetzt. Und lauter solche Spiele rein.
Das klingt wahnsinnig kompliziert. Ich habe manchmal den Eindruck, dass ich höre ja auch viele Podcasts, in denen Leute von ihren KI-Erfahren berichten. Und ich denke manchmal so, mach doch die Tür einfach mal mit der Hand auf. Mitunter denke ich, ja, man kann natürlich 17 Apps da produzieren, um dies und das zu machen. Aber manchmal hilft ja auch, zum Beispiel, ich habe keine Wetter-App. Ich gucke auch manchmal einfach aus dem Fenster raus und sehe, es regnet.
Also Wetter-App ist auch noch so eine Sache. Denn wenn die Ankündigung ist, 19 Uhr wird es kühler und bis 24 Uhr noch 30 Grad. Interessiert mich genau, was in diesen fünf Stunden passiert. Ich will da nicht einfach so eine drei Stunden Vorhersage haben, sondern aber gut, später dann.
Aber was machst du, wie richtest du dein Leben dann darauf aus?
Ja, ich will zum Beispiel wissen, ob mit Temperaturabfall Wind einhergeht und wann dazu erwarten ist.
Und dann weißt du sonst, kannst du nicht aufs Rad steigen? Oder was machst du davon abhängig?
Aufs Rad würde ich sowieso nicht steigen. Ich bin ja dann im Überlebensmodus. Aber ich würde dann schon mal so ein bisschen, es ist jetzt dunkel, ungewöhnliche Zeit, um rauszugehen. Aber vielleicht doch einfach mal rausgehen. Schon allein, weil draußen ein bisschen mehr Wind weht oder so. Lauter solche Sachen. Ich werde dich auf dem Laufenden halten.
Ja.
Es ist ja gerade mal angefangen Juli. Jetzt ist ja wirklich verrückt.
Wir haben heute etwas vor. Wir sprechen heute über ein Buch eines Journalisten, der in allen Talkshows Dauergast ist. Der ist wahrscheinlich der bekannteste Politikjournalist zurzeit. Robin Alexander, er arbeitet für die Welt, hat ein Buch geschrieben, das heißt Letzte Chance, Der neue Kanzler und der Kampf um die Demokratie. Vorne auf dem Cover sind die Köpfe von Merz, Trump und Alice Weidel zu sehen. Wir sprechen gleich ausführlich über dieses Buch. Aber wir müssen glaube ich schon mal davor einige Sätze sagen. Denn wir haben ja hier sehr ausführlich im Podcast zum Beispiel die Berichterstattung reportiert zu den Attentaten, wie beispielsweise Reporter auf Weihnachtsmärkten herumstehen und sagen, ja, da waren Poller frei und da ist er dadurch gekommen. Und es läuft noch das Sanitätspersonal links und rechts vorbei. Und man sendet aber einfach weiter und macht schon eine spannende Story draus. Wir haben gesehen, wie wir nur Emotionalisierung bekommen, auch von den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, dass man da überhaupt nicht runterbremst. Und jetzt wird eigentlich an diese Emotionalisierung angeknüpft. Und ich habe so viele Fragen an dieses Buch, an dich, an den Politikstil, der damit einhergeht. Und vor allem auch an diese Art des Journalismus. Denn dieses Buch handelt natürlich implizit vom Journalismus, ohne das wirklich transparent zu machen. Denn wir sehen ja hier eigentlich den Journalismus als einen ganz wichtigen Akteur, der aber immer so unter den Teppich gekehrt wird. Ich finde, es ist ein ungeheuer aufschussreiches, grauenhaftes Buch.
Also ja, und es ist also alles, was du sagst, plus finde ich halt ein brutaler Eingriff in den Lauf der Dinge. Denn einfach nur zu sagen, der Journalismus wird da nicht mitreflektiert, ist ja das eine. Ich finde aber auch, es gibt verschiedene Strategien, wie Leute Sachbücher schreiben. Ich zum Beispiel sage mir gerade, ich schreibe gar nicht, weil diese KI-Welle soll jetzt erstmal über die Verlage hinwegrollen, wie auch immer. Also da verbrennen sich ja alle die Finger. Und da bin ich lieber Zaungast und stehe daneben und leide ein bisschen mit. Hier allerdings haben wir es mit einem Autor zu tun, der sich einfach denkt, das, was die KI am allerbesten kann, nämlich einen Deep Research anfertigen, etwas chronologisch zusammenzufassen, eine Rekombination aus 100 Zeitungstexten in einen roten Faden, das macht er. Mit dem wahrscheinlich erschlagenen Totschlagargument, dass der Subtext dieses Buches immer ist, man kann eigentlich das alles nur beurteilen, wenn man wirklich jedes Detail kennt. Und ich kenne jedes Detail. Ich habe ein Buch darüber geschrieben.
Und ich habe Zugang zu jeder Chatgruppe, jeder spielt eine Information.
Wir wurden Dokumente zugesteckt, ohne Schwerzung.
Für die Leute, die jetzt Robin Alexander nicht so kennen, Robin Alexander ist der, der immer informiert ist über alles. Er pflegt also sehr gute Kontakte zu offenbar allen Parteien, vor allem aber CDU, SPD und grüne FDP. Von ihnen bekommt er offenbar immer direkte Informationen zugespielt. Auch alle Dinge, die sonst nicht an die Öffentlichkeit so schnell gelangen, gelangen erst einmal zu Robin Alexander. Er ist quasi so ein Intermediär im politischen Feld geworden, der dort alle Informationen sammelt, deshalb immer sehr exklusiv sein kann. Dadurch natürlich ein Detailwissen hat, was sonst keiner haben kann.
Das würde ich mal bestreiten.
Beziehungsweise er hat bestimmte Details, die er gesteckt bekommt. Und andere bekommen andere Details gesteckt. Und man sieht auch in dem Buch, dass einmal jemand ja auch sehr viele Details plötzlich hat. Und das ist ihm gar nicht so recht. Das ist nämlich Robert Pausch von der Zeit, als es darum geht, dass die FDP dieses verrückte Paper da vorlegt. Dieses, was ist das, Doomsday und so weiter.
Genau, D-Day.
Der D-Day, wie sie da aussteigen wollen. Also wir werden darüber jetzt nachher noch ausführlich reden. Aber vielleicht sollten wir erstmal, weil das immer so unser Thema war, über diese Emotionalisierung sprechen.
Ich will noch mal kurz bei dem Storytelling an sich bleiben. Also du hast hier ein Buch, das im Grunde von einem Autor kommt, und der sagt, ich habe ja auch damals bei Hard Aber Fair im Nachhinein so angesprochen, wie du schon mit deinem Podcast zufrieden bist. Und er so, ja, ich hätte gerne mehr Zeit und so. Und ich fragte, was hören Sie denn für Podcasts? Ich habe ja gar keine Zeit zum Podcast hören und so, ja. Und wir kennen alle diesen Habitus, der dann so kommt mit so irgendwelche Podcasts, da schreiben wir zu Büchern 140 Seiten. Was kann man da schon machen? Es müssen 450 sein. So diese 450 kommen aber ohne Tiefgang. Also es wird einfach nur, du hast jetzt diese Pausch-Sache angesprochen, also in der Zeit große Investigationen, wie die FDP die Ampel zerstörte. Und da sieht man ja, also wo sozusagen publizistisches Gegenfeuer, wo er weiß, das haben die Leute jetzt im Hinterkopf, da muss ich kurz explizit werden. Und dann findet so eine Relativierung statt. Hey, es hat doch jede Partei gemacht und die FDP hat sich nur besonders dumm angestellt und so, ja. Also wir könnten sozusagen jetzt in Salon, das Buch ist 450 Seiten, also 4 Stunden 50 darüber reden, wie er das chronologisch gestaltet. Aber ich will jetzt gleich auf eine andere Ebene helfen, zumindest von meiner Seite. Denn ich halte diese Strategie, dieses Merkelsche, meine Sitzung dauert am längsten. Mein Buch ist noch nicht zu Ende erzählt, da seid ihr schon alle müde. Aber ich hab's nicht nur geschrieben, ich hab's auch eingelesen, Wort für Wort und so. Also diese Arbeitswut, die da drinsteckt, dieses Erschlagen, dieses Überrumpeln, das ist eine ganz fiese und sehr perfide Strategie. Und damit kommt man auch biografisch sehr viel weiter, weil das ist im Grunde, wir kennen das schon von Markus Feldenkirchen und so, diese Einladung. Lieber Wahlkämpfer, ich glaube, du wirst Erfolg haben, weil in Deutschland gibt es ja nur zwei Parteien, wer soll sonst Erfolg haben? Guck mal, ich habe schon zwei solche Bücher geschrieben, lass mich doch mal näher ran. Und dann bist du in so einem Stefan Lambi. Also ich mache natürlich den Film über die Chronik, wo noch mal die Tagesschauungen zusammengefasst werden und so. Aber ich bin dann auch dabei, wenn sie in den Fahrstuhl steigen und lauter so. Und da kommt so ein Spin rum, aber ganz unscheinbar. Man sieht ihn kaum, aber er ist total wirkmächtig. Wo hier so die Normalitäten sind, wo die Gefahren lauern und so. Das wird dann einfach so eingebaut in den Text. Das müssen wir heute so ein bisschen rauskratzen. Und bevor du in deine Kritikrichtung gehst, würde ich hier gern ganz paradigmatisch, existenziell einmal gegen anargumentieren. Und in zwei Punkten. Das eine ist die Perfidie. Ich war bei Hart aber fair. Am 11.11.2024. Das war eine sehr aufgeregte Zeit, denn es waren gerade fünf Tage oder so und die Ampel war Geschichte. Vier. Und ich traf dort auf Robin Alexander. Ich habe versucht, dort Argumente zu machen. Schuldenbremse, Schuldenbremse, Schuldenbremse. Hat natürlich nicht ganz gefruchtet. Wir hören hier mal hinein in einen Clip. Es geht um eine folgende Auseinandersetzung. Du hast ja die Immunsanität eben schon angesprochen. Die wird natürlich gleich tragendes Ding spielen. Robin Alexander doziert so über diese Frage. Also der Scholz war ja ganz schön gut vorbereitet. Fünf Minuten nachdem er den Vizekanzler entlassen hat und hat plötzlich so ein Statement gehabt, das er Wort für Wort abgelesen hat, der war verdächtig gut vorbereitet auf so eine Situation, wo er uns doch vorgaukelte, aus der Emotion heraus das Land zu schützen und die Ampel zu kippen. Und dagegen argumentiere ich mal an. Und jetzt vergleichen wir mal seine Argumentation, die ihm so wichtig ist, dass er mir sogar ins Wort fällt mit dem, was er heute Morgen bei TableMedia gesagt hat, zu im Grunde genau demselben Sachverhalt. Also hier Geschichtsstunde, hart aber fair, aus dem Herbst.
Scholz hat es dann aber durchgesetzt, hat gesagt, er entlässt ihn jetzt. Hat der Kanzler da Führungsstärke gezeigt?
Kann man diskutieren. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob dieser Art Fokus auf diesen Human Interest, es sind immer gute Zeiten, schlechte Zeiten, wie auch immer. Und wir können auch nicht dem Kanzler unterstellen, professionell vorgegangen zu sein. Also ein Statement für eine Eventualität, von denen Herr Gubicki meint, das hat sich doch monatelang angebahnt, sagen alle, er hat da Text vorbereitet. Ja, er hat Text vorbereitet.
Ja, nur dann kann man nicht sagen, er war emotional. Also entweder hat er vorbereitet oder hat aus der Emotion agiert. Aber es kann nur eins stimmen.
Er hat ihn vorbereitet und dann aus der Emotion heraus vorgetragen. Der Fokus ist aber, der Text war vorbereitet, weil er ja Deutschland eine Aufgabe stellt. Es ging darum, Schaden vom Land abzuwenden. Und dieser Schaden wurde auch benannt, die Schuldenbremse. Ich weiß nicht genau, das ist jetzt fünf Tage her, wie diese Botschaft verloren gehen konnte, wie diese Frage nicht mehr gestellt werden kann. Stattdessen müssen wir jetzt, wie emotional war er denn? Ungewohnt emotional? Okay, war es wirklich sehr ungewohnt emotional? Nein, ich habe ihn im Hinterzimmer schon mal so und so erlebt. Das sind alles Fragen. Die haben überhaupt nichts in dieser Situation verloren.
Gar nichts.
Sehr gut.
So, Robin Alexander sagt also, man kann nicht beides sein. Der Scholz kann auf gar keinen Fall emotional sein.
Und vorbereitet.
Und gleichzeitig vorbereitet. Auf eine Eventualität, bei der alle seit Monaten schreiben, morgen ist es soweit. Ja, gut übermorgen.
Also Leute, die zum Beispiel Grabreden halten, die sind darauf vorbereitet. Aber die können trotzdem in dem Moment emotional sein. Und das übermant einen manchmal selbst in Momenten, in denen man genau weiß, ja, lass dich gleich nicht übermannen. Das ist so ein eigenartiges Gefühl, werd jetzt nicht zu sentimental in diesem Moment bei der Preisverleihung zum Beispiel oder sonst was. Und dann sehen wir, dass selbst Leute, die im Business immer die Profis sind, plötzlich sehr emotional werden. Und er will aber jetzt hier ja die ganze Zeit darüber reden, wie emotional er ist. Und du versuchst ein inhaltliches Argument zu bringen, die Schuldenbremse. Aber die spielt jetzt keine Rolle, weil wir ja von Emotionen getrieben sind. Aber man muss sagen, nee, er ist von Emotionen getrieben.
Und ich würde ja sogar so weit gehen zu sagen, und das ist dann Vorbereitung auch auf Clips gleich, aber auch so unsere Erfahrung jetzt mit Bühnrealität. Gerade die Vorbereitung ist vielleicht ein besonders gelingender Umgang, und zwar auch aus Authentizitätsgründen mit Emotionen. Denn sich einfach nur krass, ich bin überwältigt von einer Emotion, ich haue mich weg, sondern nein, gerade wenn man es gestaltet, hat es ja sozusagen ausbreitenden, infizierenden Charakter auf eine Trauer gemeinte, noch mal, ah ja, stimmt, das sind die Emotionen, um die es jetzt geht. Und dann gehört zur Trauer vielleicht auch Freude auf Erfahrung, wie auch immer. Das kann man dann plötzlich alles so einbauen. So, wer hat es jetzt gehört? Nee, der Sachstand Schuldenbremse und so weiter, das muss hier ausgeblendet werden. Scholz war emotional und er hat uns aber belogen, weil er war vorbereitet. Jetzt hören wir denselben Sachverhalt, Schuldenbremse, aber eben nicht Scholz, sondern Merz, Sietzelensky im Oval Office, der ganze Kram, der hier so thematisiert wird. Und heute Morgen argumentiert Robin Alexander so im Gespräch mit Michael Brücker.
Und da sagen die Leute, wah, ein riesiger Wahlbetrug und so weiter. Man kann auch sagen, vorausschauende Politik. Ja, also ich meine, ich würde das so sagen. Du bist da sehr sanft mit ihm, in diesem Satz. Nein, ich bin nicht sanft. Ich versuche präzise zu sein und den Menschen gerecht zu werden.
Sehr gut.
Also schau, ist Friedrich Merz im Innersten erschüttert dadurch, dass JD Vans in München sagt, das Problem sind nicht die Russen, die Chinesen, sondern euer Verhältnis zur Meinungsfreiheit. Er ist erschüttert. Ist Friedrich Merz erschüttert darüber, dass Zelensky so gedemütigt wurde im Oveloffice? Er ist erschüttert. Zweite Frage. Nutzt er diese Erschütterung politisch und begründet etwas, was er tun muss? Ja, auch dies. Beides kann parallel wahr sein.
Ach so.
Hört, hört.
Jetzt hört es sich doch.
Tja. Also das ist diese Perfidie, die da einfach sich 450 Seiten lang durchzieht. Und deswegen muss die wundervoll zu drüber werden.
Und er ist natürlich sehr intelligent, dass man das nicht so leicht merkt. Man hat es hier mit einem intelligenten Autor zu tun, der sehr gut Dinge lancieren kann. Und da muss man aber erkennen, welche Absichten sind wieder hinter. Und hier wird auch ein Heiligenbildchen gemalt für Früh-März. Das werden wir nachher sehr ausführlich uns ansehen.
So, und deswegen wechseln wir kurz das Genre und gehen in die Las Vegas Zauber-Show. Es geht um Penn Gillette, der ist dort sehr berühmt. Er hat seine eigene Show im Rio gehabt, ein unglaublich riesiges Hotel und so weiter mit großem Festsaal unten. Und er hat heute einen Podcast. Also er macht immer noch diese Penn und Teller Show mit seinem Kumpel, der arbeitet auch im Podcast. Und wir hören jetzt mal eine Minute 30, spontan. Und ich sage vorher, ist so ein bisschen knapp neben der Spur. Aber danach, die zwei Clips, auf die kommt es mir an. Und die müssen sozusagen in diesem Gespräch kurz aufgehangen werden. Also hier, Penn kriegt spontan eine Frage. So, es geht hier um die Frage, können wir uns eigentlich damit abfinden, dass alles, woran wir uns erinnern, gar nicht so korrekt ist? Also wenn ich jetzt 450 Seiten Buch schreibe, eine Erinnerung darlege, was hat es mit der eigentlich auf? Und er versucht jetzt erst mal spontan so zu antworten. Die zwei Clips gleich kommen über eine Stunde später in diesem Gespräch. Da ist er dann sozusagen bei Fassung.
Nicht, dass wir uns erinnern, ist nicht so korrekt. Weil es keine Geschichte gibt. Nichts passiert wirklich im ganzen Weltall. Alles ist Modell in unserer Hand. Richtig.
Und also, sind Sie unkomfortabel mit dem, oder sind Sie komfortabel mit dem? Wenn ich es fand, als ich darüber gelernt habe, wurde ich mehr komfortabel. Denn als ich die Menschen als narrative-seekenden Individuen verstehe, die immer, die Split-Brain-Experiments aus den 1970ern, die Leute in die Aktion nehmen, und dann passiert es.
Hinschneidung, es gibt keine Freiheit und es gibt keine Welt da draußen. Das ist das, was wir hier reden wollen.
Ich denke, du hast schon mal gesprochen, wie du in der Vergangenheit deinen Diary überprüft hast.
Ja, ich habe. Und warum? Weil ich mag... Okay, lass uns das hier in Termen, die du verstehen kannst. Du Kommunist. Du Kommunist. Ein Teil meiner falschen Narrativen ist es, andere falschen Narrativen zu korrigieren.
So, er hat also eine Frage gestellt, an der er erstmal scheitert. Ja, also es gibt keine richtige Realität. Alles passiert nur im Kopf, aber wir können die ja trotzdem verarbeiten, um wissentlich falsche, aber vielleicht mit dem Willen, es doch irgendwie richtig zu machen, andere zu überzeugen davon, dass sie es ein bisschen falscher gemacht haben oder wir irgendwie so. So, und jetzt eine Stunde später in dem Gespräch kommt er zurück zu dieser Frage und möchte sie jetzt beantworten. Das sind so kleine Clips für die Ewigkeit, ja? Hier erster Aufschlag. So, es geht um die Frage. Und er hat nicht nur Zauber-Shows gemacht in Las Vegas, sondern auch Bücher geschrieben und er schwenkt gerade oben von Journalismus hier, da die Wahrheit auf Fiction. Welchen Mehrwert hat eigentlich mal Roman, Billy Drissig, am Schreibtisch zu sitzen und nicht die ganze Zeit so kronistenpflichtig rumzureihen?
Wenn ich Fiction schreibe, ist das bemerkenswert, denn in meinem neuesten Buch, Bellamy Juggler, bezeichne ich alle Geschichten, die ich glaube, wirklich mir passieren. Und das seltsame ist, weil es Fiction ist, glaube ich, dass ich mehr genauer zu der Geschichte, die in meinem Gehirn ist. Was du tun willst, denke ich, ist, dass du eine Geschichte in deinem Gehirn hast, die du weißt, ist nicht wahr. Und um jemanden zu machen, der das Weltwerk mit dir teilt, willst du genug Punkte haben, um mit deinem Narrativ zu begleiten, damit es ein Teil davon gibt. Und der einzige Weg, das Teil davon zu haben, ist, zu begleiten, dass es ein gewisses Weltwerk gibt, mit dem wir Dinge herausfinden und teilen können.
Ja, also, ja, Realität, schön und gut. Und irgendwelche Journalisten, die auf irgendwelchen Republikakonferenzen sitzen, um irgendwann nochmal in Objektivität und so weiter. Wir hatten ja auch kürzlich in Hamburg eine Kontroverse zu dieser Frage, wo das Publikum auch so ein bisschen, was sagt denn der Schriftsteller und so? Genau, was ist mit der Wahrheit und so? Nein, es geht hier nicht um Realität und Wahrheit, es geht um Resonanz und Widerstände.
Ja, beziehungsweise um Erinnerung, Konstruktion, Erzählung, Ereignis.
Genau.
Also es gibt Ereignisse und die sind wahr. Wie sie aber dann zu Erzählungen werden, beziehungsweise in der Erinnerung zu Erzählungen werden, ist das was anderes. Und wir haben ja hier Ereignisse, so suggeriert uns Robin Alexander, die zu einer Politik führen, dass aber da eine Erzählung draus gemacht wird aus den Ereignissen. Und aus der Erzählung wird eine Politik dann gemacht. Das wird hier nicht reflektiert. Und ich werde ja heute noch ein Buch vorstellen, eine Poetik-Vorlesung von Barbi Marković. Und diese Schriftstellerin spielt sehr mit der Frage Wahrheit und was darf man sich aneignen, was nicht, was ist mit der Realität. Und sie zitiert Proust. Und sie macht aber dann gleich eine Fußnote Proust aus dem Gedächtnis zitiert. Also wir wissen gar nicht, ob das wirklich ein Proust-Satz ist. Und Proust soll gesagt haben, laut Barbi Marković, unsere Wahrheit verändert sich für uns so sehr, dass andere sich in ihr schwer zurechtfinden können.
Genau. Und dieser Die Anderen, darauf hat er auch gerade abgestellt. Es geht nicht darum, eine Realität so aufzuschreiben, dass die anderen endlich einsehen, das ist die Realität. Sondern ein Angebot für Anschlussfähigkeit zu machen, dem gefolgt wird. Und wir sehen das ja heute in Amerika. Heut Nacht wurde dieses Big Beautiful Bill. Das ist so groß, über 1000 Seiten lang. Keiner weiß, was es real in der materiellen Welt wirklich bedeutet. Man muss jetzt einfach mit Narrativen hier versuchen, resonant und widerständig mit so Sachverhalten umzugehen. In der Hoffnung darauf, dass Geschichten derjenigen, die dann sozusagen die Betroffenen sind, irgendwie in Einklang zu bringen sind mit dem, was im Senat und im Kongress da gerade passiert. Und wenn das nicht klappt, und wir müssen das jetzt auch alle ein bisschen abwarten und halt gucken, wer beobachtet wie. Wir sitzen hier in Deutschland, wir werden das die nächsten Monate trotzdem ausführlich diskutieren. Wie geht denn das eigentlich? Und dafür gibt es ein wichtiges Kriterium. Wenn also Realität ausfällt, wenn Listen to the Science einfach nicht funktioniert, weil wir so einen Raffinessebetrieb über den Nebel der Realität legen und dann sagen, ok, hier erkenne ich so ein bisschen was. Es gibt ein anderes Kriterium, dass der Penn hier jetzt herausstellt, dass das maßgebliche ist. Und wir hören zuerst das Kriterium, und dann mache ich mein Urteil schon mal über Robin Alexander. So, und jetzt können wir uns ja einfach die Frage stellen. Wir beide haben das Buch schon gelesen, Und die ganze Besprechung wird gleich eine Argumentation zu meinem Urteil jetzt sein. Ich glaube Robin Alexander kein Wort. Und ich vertraue ihm nicht, dass er das Gute im Herzen hat oder überhaupt nur ein bisschen mich auch im Blick hat. Das klingt ja zahl. Bei den Schreiben dieser Lektüre. Sondern ich habe, wie wir alle wissen, kürzlich auch ein, zum Teil politisches Sachbuch geschrieben, in dem ich auch zum Teil kronistisch da durchgehe. Nur während Robin Alexander einfach 450 Seiten über die letzte Ampel schreibt. Und ich mir denke, Momentchen mal, also wenn man schon irgendwie so anfangen, hier journalistisch und kronistenpflichtig anzufangen, dann können wir doch mal sagen, das steht eigentlich im Koalitionsvertrag. Und im Koalitionsvertrag steht drin, das wichtigste zivilpolitische, gesellschaftspolitische Vorhaben ist hier Kindergrundsicherung und solche Sachen. Null Thematisierung. Das, was die Leute am meisten interessiert, am meisten in ihrem Leben sich wirklich niederschlägt, finanziell einfach die größten Effekte hervorruft, findet in diesem Buch einfach gar nicht statt. Sondern er hat sich ganz selektiv auf seinen Scheiß, und da würde ich jetzt sagen, den halt der Kanzler der Neue so beschäftigt, ja und er wird dann umjubelt und 100 andere Journalisten und 200 weitere Politiker interessiert.
Also das ist eine Perspektive, die zwar aus dem Inneren kommt, aber auch nur für die Inneren eigentlich gedacht ist. Also wir dürfen jetzt so ein bisschen Mäuschen spielen, dürfen mal durchs Schlüsselloch blicken, dürfen erfahren, wer ein bisschen viel trinkt, wenn ein Koalitionsausschuss ist. Ja, solche Dinge bekommen wir auch noch mitgegeben. Aber das bleibt ja alles auf der Boulevard-Ebene. Und diese anderen Fragen, die man stellen könnte, die werden nicht beantwortet bzw. die werden überhaupt gar nicht aufgetan. Und stattdessen lässt man sich ganz ein auf ja, eine Erzählweise, die man ja selbst produziert hat. Also wir haben es hier mit einem Mann zu tun, der für Springer arbeitet. Der schreibt für die Welt, ist mit der Bild-Zeitung also nachverbunden. Und die Bild-Zeitung als Meinungsmache kommt gar nicht vor. Es ist einfach so, es gibt Ereignisse in der Welt. Zum Beispiel, dass ein Flüchtling mit dem Messer Kinder ermordet und dann ist das Ereignis einfach an sich das, was zum Beispiel dann den Kanzler oder künftigen Kanzlerkandidaten emotionalisiert. Wie darüber berichtet wurde, welche Rolle die Medien dabei spielen, welche Rolle Robin Alexander explizit selbst dabei spielt, das kommt in dem Sinne gar nicht vor. Und wir versuchen uns mal einen Eindruck zu vermitteln, wie das hier läuft. Und wenn Alexander sogar an einigen Punkten recht haben sollte, dann habe ich wirklich Angst. Also für mich ist das Buch, also sollte Robin Alexander wirklich richtig liegen, mit dieser Art der Beschreibung. Dann sollte man schon mal darüber nachdenken, wo man möglichst schnell hin kann.
Flüchtet. Wartet nicht auf Putin.
Wir hören jetzt mal in den Machtwechsel-Podcast, den haben sie live aufgeführt. Alexander mit Dagmar Rosenfeld. Es geht um die Buchpräsentation. Rosenfeld leitet mal ein.
Wir werden beginnen mit dem Kapitel Blutwart. Und ich möchte das einordnen, damit alle wissen, wo wir uns befinden. Wir befinden uns im Januar 2025. Und die Lage der CDU in den Umfragen ist nicht gut. Es geht für die CDU nach unten. Es erscheint die erste Umfrage bei Insa, die die CDU unter 30 Prozent sieht. Das Attentat auf den Weihnachtsmarkt in Magdeburg ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt gerade mal vier Wochen her. Und in der öffentlichen Debatte dominiert das Thema Asyl und Migration.
Also hier sehen wir schon...
Die öffentliche Debatte ist, wir in den Medien machen das.
Dieses Buch benutzt, also benutzt, ich würde so sagen, es benutzt uns Leser als Schwungmasse für die Reputation eines Journalisten, der gerne in der kommenden Regierung wieder ein bisschen mehr Zugang hätte als in der letzten. Das wäre jetzt zum Beispiel eine Unterstellung, die man machen kann. Und das hört man ja hier schon, Blutbad. Also Menschen sterben auf der Straße. Und das erste, was sie dazu rein assoziiert ist, die Umfrage der CDU sind nicht gut.
Ja, wir hören weiter.
Und dann kommt der 22. Januar in Aschaffenburg, attackiert ein 28-jähriger Mann im Park, eine Kindergartengruppe mit einem Messer. Er tötet ein Kind sowie einen Erwachsenen. Und wieder ist der Täter ein ausreisepflichtiger Asylbewerber.
Und jetzt?
So, warte, auch hier. Ein Mann sticht auf Kinder ein und deswegen Migrationspolitik. Weil wer hätte gedacht, dass man vielleicht erstmal an einen Notarzt denkt oder so was? Nein, sofort im Innenministerium Anruf.
Ja, es ist, also es wird die ganze Zeit nur, also erstmal bei dem Weihnachtsmarkt wissen wir ja, das war ja jemand, der 2006 nach Deutschland kam, der hier als Arzt gearbeitet hat, der also bestens integriert war, wenn man so möchte, sich dann radikalisiert hat übers Internet. Wir wissen nicht genau, was sonst noch in diesem Kopfe so vorgegangen ist. Er hat aber auch Posts von der AfD geteilt. Wir haben es nicht mit jemandem zu tun, der klassisch islamistisch unterwegs war, ganz im Gegenteil. Jetzt haben wir es hier mit einem offenbar durchgedrehten zu tun, der möglicherweise hätte gestoppt werden können, wenn man früher auf dies und das reagiert hätte. Also auf diesen Fall konkret. Und wahrscheinlich gibt es ganz viele Sachen, wo man jetzt in Deutschland sagen kann, da müsste man eigentlich reagieren. Da wurden doch Behörden gewarnt, warum lässt man den immer noch frei herumlaufen. Leute, die psychotisch sind und im höchsten Maße gewaltbereit. All das ist ja vollkommen richtig. Aber davon abzuleiten, weil wir brauchen da eine gesamte Migrationspolitik, bedeutet ja einfach, einen Generalverdacht auszusprechen. Interessant ist die Erzählung, die hier immer wieder zu lesen ist, wir gehen dann nachher am Salon noch mal genauer drauf ein, ist ja, Friedrich Merz ändert seine Migrationspolitik, seinen Wahlkampf. Er will jetzt plötzlich Wahlkampf machen zum Thema Migration.
Gegen alle Beraterleistungen, die er vorher erhält.
Ja, und vor allem würde ich auch sagen, es stimmt doch gar nicht, dass dann das große Umschwenken kommt. Ich habe dann mal per Plexity befragt, habe mir Artikel anzeigen lassen. Zum Beispiel gab es schon am 13. Dezember, also noch vor Weihnachtsmarkt und allem, ja, hat man den Parteitag gehabt. Und da steht in der süddeutschen CDU, CSU verlangen eine grundsätzliche Wende in der Migrationspolitik. Wir kontrollieren die deutschen Staatsgrenzen und setzen konsequente Zurückweisungen an der Grenzen durch. Heißt es im Entwurf. Ja, es geht darum, der Familiennachzug zu subsidiär Schutzberechtigten soll ausgesetzt werden. Also genau, was wir jetzt bekommen. Das ist ja gar nicht das Resultat von Magdeburg oder von Aschaffenburg, sondern das hat man doch im Dezember gesagt. Ich habe dann noch mal weiter geschaut. Im Oktober sagen Union-Spitzen auch dazu, Friedrich Merz warnen davor, es würden durch Migration No-Go-Arias entstehen für Deutsche. Und da müsse man, und die Ampel sei nicht bereit und imstande, etwas dagegen zu tun. Deswegen müsse man wohl Migration den Wahlkampf mit aufnehmen, obwohl man es eigentlich nicht wolle. Aber wir haben schon monatelang eine Dauer-Migrationsdebatte, die sich dann natürlich noch mal zuspitzt. Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass die CDU sagt jetzt, da hatten wir nie dran gedacht. Wir hören jetzt Robin Alexander.
Die Strategen in der Union können ihr Glück kaum fassen.
Also man muss sagen, jetzt geht es um dieses Blutbad. Man sieht jetzt auch, wie zynisch über all das dann doch gesprochen wird. Also Schulz hält eine Rede und alle denken, okay, von der CDU jetzt verkündet der eine große Migrationswende, dann nimmt er uns das Thema weg. Schulz machte aber eine vage formulierte Rede, die seine Betroffenheit ausdrückt, aber er kündigt jetzt nichts konkret an. Und jetzt wird daraus jetzt gemacht, ja, das ist dann toll, jetzt können wir da richtig rein. Und man sieht ja, okay, da stimmt ja irgendwas mit dieser Art der Emotionalisierung, nicht die, die uns gleich verkauft wird.
Wie schon nach dem Anschlag in Magdeburg lässt Olaf Scholz erneut eine riesige kommunikative Lücke, analysieren sie. Diese Lücke kann Friedrich Merz füllen. Ja, er muss sogar. Andernfalls wird es Alice Weidel mit ihren radikalen AfD-Parolen tun.
Die hat ja jetzt sonst geschwiegen, wie wir wissen. Ja, die hat sich ja ganz zurückgehalten deshalb.
Sieht der Kanzlerkandidat das auch so? Oder bleibt er bei seinem bisherigen vorsichtigen Kurs?
Habt ihr, hat irgendjemand bei Friedrich Merz in puncto Migration in den letzten, sagen wir, zwölf Monaten einen vorsichtigen Kurs erlebt? Also wovon reden wir denn hier?
Um 22 Uhr lädt Merz zu einer Videokonferenz.
So, bei dieser Videokonferenz ist dann auch wer anwesend?
Linnemann im Teil, Frey und Dobrindt, außerdem Joachim Herrmann, der bayerische Innenminister, der über den Ermittlungsstand der dortigen Behörden informieren soll, sowie Andrea Lindholz, stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende und eine der wenigen Frauen in Merz Berliner Führungsteam. Zugeschaltet ist Lindholz an diesem Abend, aber aus einem anderen Grund. Aschaffenburg ist ihr Wahlkreis. Sie war in der Stadt, als der Anschlag passierte. In ihrem Wahlkreisbüro hörte sie die Rotoren des Rettungshubschraubers und erlebte anschließend, welche Ängste die Stadtbevölkerung ausstand.
Also sie hörte einen Rettungshubschrauber. Das ist ihre Nähe zu dem Ereignis. Es ist ihr Landkreis. Und jetzt schildert sie ein bisschen die Situation in der Stadt.
Der Täter konnte zunächst fliehen. Es gab Gerüchte, dass mehrere Männer mit Messern unterwegs seien. Lindholz sprach mit Angehörigen der Opfer, mit Polizisten, die zum Tatort geeilt waren. In der Runde mit Friedrich Merz schildert Andrea Lindholz ihre Erlebnisse sehr detailliert und sehr eindringlich. Wie die Erzieherinnen versucht haben, den Bollerwagen mit den Kindern vom Täter wegzuziehen. Wie der Täter sie aber weiter verfolgt und dann mit einem Küchenmesser auf den kleinen zweijährigen Jungen eingestochen habe. Wie der Täter extra noch die Mütze und den Schal des Jungen abgenommen habe, um ihn in den Hals stechen zu können. Insgesamt siebenmal. Wie eine 59-jährige Erzieherin beim Versuch, sich vor das Kind zu wehren und so weiter.
Also was wir jetzt hier präsentiert bekommen, ist diese Rede, die ja absolut verständlich ist. Lindholz schildert das dann da und natürlich ist man dabei emotional. Jetzt müssen wir aber natürlich aus der politischen Perspektive drauf blicken und sagen, ja, ich kann das mir jetzt ganz im Detail nochmal anhören, aber ich habe auch ein Vorstellungsvermögen, wie grauenhaft so was ist, wenn auf Kinder eingestochen wird und so weiter. Ja, das ist ja völlig klar. Die Frage ist jetzt nur, wohin führt mich diese Erzählung? Also wenn ich jetzt das gehört habe, sage ich dann dazu Migrationspolitik. Also ist das meine Antwort. Und wir springen mal zu dem nächsten Clip. Merz reagiert.
Merz reagiert sehr emotional auf ihre Schilderungen. Mehrere Teilnehmer der Videorunde werden hinterher berichten, dass Friedrich Merz tief bewegt, ja regelrecht erschüttert gewesen sei. Zeitweise stockt ihm die Stimme. Das Kinderziel der Attacke Waren setzt ihm besonders zu. Seine Bestürzung darüber äußert er wieder und wieder. Merz erinnert in seinen Worten auch an Magdeburg, an das viele Blut, das er dort auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt gesehen hat.
Wir erinnern uns nochmal gerade Magdeburg, war nicht die Frage von, da ist jetzt ein Flüchtling vor zwei Jahren gekommen, und den hat man da im Heim vergessen so. Aber er verknüpft das schon beides, ja.
Die herumliegende Puppe, das alles könne nicht so weitergehen, sagt Merz.
So, das ist jetzt also der Schritt, der bedeutet, okay, ich habe jetzt meine Erinnerungen an einen Blutband, ich habe noch mal Erinnerungen gehört an einen Blutband, und die führen mich jetzt zu einer Migrationspolitik. Wir könnten ja auch jetzt sagen, ich will nicht diese Attentate relativieren, aber es gibt ja auch andere schreckliche Taten, die zum Beispiel mit häuslicher Gewalt zu tun haben, die von Deutschen ausgeübt werden und so weiter, und die kann ich mindestens genauso emotional erzählen. Und davon kann ich Dinge ableiten, wie wir brauchen 1.000 Frauenhäuser mehr, wir brauchen dies und das, wir haben diese ganzen Armutsberichte jetzt bekommen, die einen fassungslos machen. Auch da kann ich aus einer Emotionalisierung heraus große Politik ableiten. Passiert hier aber nicht, passiert nur bei diesem Thema. Und ich finde wirklich interessant, wie jetzt hier damit umgegangen wird, denn wir haben es ja jetzt mit dem künftigen Kanzler zu tun, der aus der Emotion heraus und mit seinen Strategen Linnemann und Spahn im Hintergrund jetzt so agiert.
Asylbewerber als tickende Zeitbomben. Das hatte Merz also schon gehört, bevor Andrea Lindholz ihre Erlebnisse in Aschaffenburg so emotional schilderte.
Denn er hatte zuvor schon mit dem Chef der Bundespolizei gesprochen.
Seine Gedanken und Gefühle fasst Merz an diesem Abend so zusammen. Es reicht. Joachim Herrmann, der bayerische Innenminister, bestärkt ihn in dieser Einschätzung, die Innenminister aller Bundesländer.
Also wenn man jetzt das ja mal ernst nehmen würde, es reicht. Also er will, dass solche Taten nicht mehr passieren. Und dann müsste man sich ja genau fragen, was wäre zu tun. Also das radikalste Programm ist ja dann, dass der AfD zu sagen, Remigration, wenn keiner mehr da ist, kann keiner mehr was tun.
Aber dann wird halt nichts mehr getan.
Dann wird auch nichts mehr sonst. So, dann ist dann ist so. Und er fängt jetzt an mit irgendeinem Punkteplan.
Da auch die Sozialdemokraten unter ihnen seien überzeugt davon, dass es so nicht weitergehen könne. Anschließend tragen Dobrindt, Frei und Linnemann vor, worüber sie am Nachmittag mit Spahn beraten haben, ein Aufschlag für eine neue, viel härtere Migrationspolitik.
Die wird dann umgesetzt und wir werden nachher dann darüber reden, diese Zusammenarbeit mit der AfD und alles, was dann da so kommt. Und da merken wir, da wird im Blindflug regiert, entschieden und sonst was. Aus einer hohen Emotionalisierung heraus. Also sollte Robin Alexander auch nur ein bisschen damit Recht haben, was er da beschreibt. Und ja, er ist ja tief drin in den Sachen und die Fakten, die hier in dem Buch stehen, die werden schon an sich stimmen. Wir beklagen die Auswahl, die Perspektive und so weiter. Da muss ich ja sagen, rette sich wer kann, wenn da mal irgendwie eine Bedrohung für die NATO sich möglicherweise einstellen könnte oder irgendwas noch mal emotionalisierend ist für Friedrich Merz, was Putin getan hat oder so, dass man einfach sagt, so wir ziehen ins Manöver, ist uns jetzt alles egal, ich habe Emotionen, ich habe kleine Kinder gesehen. Also das ist doch unglaublich, wenn das stimmen sollte, dass das in dieser Weise ist, dann muss man sich ja wirklich fürchten vor der Politik.
Also ich habe ja schon immer gesagt, keine Angst vor Verschöungstheorien. Weshalb ich jetzt mal von der ganz großen anderen Richtung, ich frage mich, wann, und wir haben jetzt schon in Amerika die erste Meldung ein Quartal minus 0,5 Prozent Wirtschaftswachstum, also Wirtschaftsschrumpfung sozusagen, obwohl ja noch dieses Ganze, wir machen die Lager voll wegen Zollanddrogen mit Rheinfelden. Also wir sind eigentlich bei minus 3, 4 Prozent. So, das zweite Quartal wird gerade ausgerechnet. Heute haben wir Big Beautiful Bill. Also gigantische Diss-Funktionalitäten bei der Reichtumsverteilung. Ich frage mich, wer soll überhaupt noch in Amerika, was arbeiten? So, Bildungssystem wird zerschlagen, Ausländer werden rausgeschickt. Wie soll das funktionieren? Und irgendwie frage ich mich die ganze Zeit, wann kommt der erste Text? Und die Argumentation muss gar nicht aufwendig sein, um wahnsinnig überzeugend zu sein, der einfach zeigt, wir haben ein Dokument gefunden. MAGA war eine Idee von KI 2015. So, mit Amtsempführung. Das ist unser Projekt.
Ich glaube ja immer an die interne Blödheit.
Die kommt ja doch dazu. Die wurde ja ausgebeutet. In Amerika erleben wir gerade extrem impulskontrollgestörte Politik. Reiche Leute sagen, sie werden gern reicher. Zack, erledigt. Ärmere Leute können sich nicht wehren. Aussortiert. So. Ausländer, sichtbar auf der Straße, wegsortieren. Also es wird alles genau auf den ersten Blick so. Was ist mein erster Gedanke, den ich habe? Das mache ich. Und ich habe letztens in Deutschland vom Gehörsaal einen wahnsinnig interessanten Vortrag gehört, den ich jetzt natürlich auch nur aus dem Geiste kurz zusammenfasse, wo darüber gesprochen wurde, wie im Gehirn so kleine Hämmer Gedanken in die Länge ziehen. Also einen Impuls sozusagen. Nee, das wird jetzt noch nicht zu Ende rationalisiert. Hier kommt jetzt so ein Hämmer rein. Und diese Hämmer, also dieses Verzögern, werden dann auch noch mal ganz clever gehemmt, sodass überhaupt eine Idee von wir sind keine Hunde, die man innerhalb von drei Sekunden das Leckerli geben muss, damit sie noch verbinden können. Ah ja, weil ich jetzt gerade stehen geblieben bin, kriege ich das Leckerli. Sondern nee, wir kriegen so ein Bildungssystem gespannt. Wir machen dir heute ein Versprechen, bauen das dann aus mit so einer slothardäugischen Philosophie, der Vorfreude auf dich selbst, nennen es Bildung und in fünf Jahren kriegst du einen Abschluss, der dir die nächsten 50 Jahre mehr Einkommen beschert. So, das sind zivilisatorische Errungenschaften. In dieser Politik, die wir hier gerade dokumentiert bekommen, wird uns einfach erklärt, es ist ganz normal, dass unser Kanzler einfach so ein Dreisekundenhund ist. Wenn wir das in anderen Politikfeldern hätten, Familienpolitik, wenn wir die Familienpolitik so runterdampfen würden, wie die Migrationspolitik gerade abläuft, dann würde das bedeuten, das wäre feuerfrei. Männer würden über die Straße gehen, sagen, die Schnixe finde ich geil, da ist ein Gebüsch. Das wäre die Familienpolitik von Friedrich Merz. So, Punkt. Und das auf 450 Seiten auszubreiten, mit so einem Nimbus des, also wenn ihr nicht wirklich jeden Satz davon gelesen habt und alle Details kennt, die ich euch hier schildere, dann dürft ihr nicht mitreden.
Und dieses Prinzip wird ja, das Prinzip wird ja jetzt nicht nur darauf angewandt, sondern wir sehen das ja dann auch, wenn es um NATO, Außenpolitik und so weiter geht. Wir ahnen schon, es gibt dann ein Video, das Friedrich Merz sieht und das soll angeblich alles bei ihm umwerfen. Und dieses Video ist natürlich Selensky im Oval Office. Das wirft alles um und wie gesagt, wir gehen das jetzt gleich durch. Ich würde sagen, also man muss wirklich, ich habe schon mal geguckt, wie das, ich donne mal, kundig mit der Schweiz. Die sind ja geruhsamer. Also der Schweiz, sagt man manchmal, ist ein bisschen langsam, aber es ist geruhsamer.
Genau, wenn man in der Schweiz fragt, wer regiert hier gerade, nenn mir einen Namen. Niemand weiß welche, niemand.
Die Schweizer schon. Aber die sagen ja, da müssen wir noch mal darüber nachdenken. Und das, glaube ich, ist genau die richtige Haltung. Und mir wird auch, also ich bin ja nicht jemand, der ein Scholz-Fan ist oder so, aber mir ist über die Lektüre dieses Buches Scholz sehr sympathisch geworden. Auch wenn der Autor das überhaupt nicht beabsichtigt, war für mich jetzt nochmal so klar, dass Scholz sich genau aus diesem paffloffschen Reizreaktionsschema hinaus manövrieren wollte. Das gelang ihm am Ende nicht. Aber dass er zumindest diesen Versuch nochmal unternommen hat, aus dieser effektgetriebenen medialen Blase auszusteigen und auch aus der politischen Blase, die so effektgetrieben ist, und zu sagen, nee, ich mach das jetzt doch nochmal anders, finde ich bemerkenswert. Ich glaube, das wird man irgendwann später nochmal so resümieren können. Man kann es aber auch dann zwischen den Zeilen bei Robin Alexander lesen. Wir werden im Salon auch einen Clip von Friedrich Merz spielen, in Bezug auf die AfD. Nämlich, er hat sich da beim Parteitag ja mal dazu geäußert, warum er mit der AfD nicht zusammenarbeiten will. Und weil dieses Buch ja Letzte Chance heißt, so als sei jetzt Friedrich Merz die Letzte Chance für die Mitte und die AfD zu verhindern und sowas, würde ich mal gerne fragen, ob die Brandmauer nicht schon eingerissen ist, und zwar in einer anderen Weise, als wir jetzt darüber nachdenken. Ja, es gab diese Zusammenarbeit und die Migrationspolitik, da sind die ja fast deckungsgleich bei vielen Fragen. Aber ich würde es auch nochmal anders mit einem Clip zeigen wollen. Wir gehen also da ganz tief rein. Ich habe auch, ich kündige das hier schon an, kritische Anmerkungen nochmal zur Linkspartei. Da erfahren wir nämlich bei Robin Alexander nochmal ein sehr wichtiges Detail. Also ich finde manche Details wirklich sehr gut, die er hier zutage fördert oder die ich sehe aufschlussreich. Man muss ja nicht die große Erzählung von Robin Alexander unterstützen, aber die Sachen, die er da manchmal anbietet, sind sehr gut. Und sonst habe ich mal schöne Sachen mitgebracht. Also wirklich interessante Sachen. Ich habe schon angesprochen, diese Poetik-Vorlesung, die heißt Stehlen, Schimpfen, Spielen, als Countdown gestaltet. Jeder wird es kennen, wenn man einen Abgabetermin hat und will eigentlich nicht und kann nicht und so. Und die Autorin hat dasselbe Problem. Wir lernen sehr viel über das Schreiben, allgemein und über die Welt. Juan S. Guse hat…
Den kenne ich. Der war bei der FAZ als Hospitant zu meiner Zeit.
Ach, siehst du. Und der ist ja nicht nur ein Romanschriftsteller, sondern auch einer, der sich hineinwagt in etwas, was man ja Großreportage nennen kann, aber es hat auch wieder was Romanhaftes. Das Buch heißt 1000 Mal so viel Geld wie jetzt. Und er hat sich mit Männern getroffen, die durch Krypto reich geworden sind. Es sind aber nicht die Männer, die man so kennt in Dubai oder auf Superjachten, sondern er spricht mit den Sleepern, mit denen, die immer noch in der Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung leben, aber einfach unfassbar viel Geld plötzlich haben. Ganz interessant ist auch auf so einer Krypto-Konferenz, der Regisseur Dominik Graf hat ein Buch geschrieben über Schauspielerei im Film.
Bist du auch dein Vorwortgeber für dein Film-Analyse-Buch?
Genau, das ist der Vorwortgeber für mein Film-Analyse-Buch. In der Tat hat Nina Scholz über die indischen Studenten geschrieben, die in Berlin Lieferfahrten machen mit dem Fahrrad. Und in welcher Situation die eigentlich sind und was die so blechen müssen, ist es wirklich wieder der ganze Wahnsinn. Da könnte man emotional werden, da könnte man wirklich sagen, jetzt muss hier sich was ändern, jetzt reicht es. Aber das tut es natürlich nicht. Und ich werde noch ein Quartett vorstellen, Streichgott, das ist ja meine Lieblingsformation, Mendelssohn und Dvořák.
Sehr gut. Ich bin heute sehr eng fokussiert auf KI-Themen. Kommentare herzlich willkommen. Sam Altman hat über The Gentle Singularity geschrieben, also die begrusam daherkommende Singularität. Wir wollen jetzt einfach mal dokumentieren, wie hier die Wortwahl ist. Denn vielleicht, wenn es anders kommt, könnten wir ihn noch mal dran erinnern, wie wir von ihm belogen wurden. Die New York Times da heute ist ja gerade eine sehr interessante Zeit. Also dieses Big Beautiful Bill ist jetzt da. Das heißt, Elon Musk ist ausreichend sauer, will jetzt diese Make-up-Party gründen. Und in wenigen Tagen endet ja auch dieser Zollaufschub von Trump. Also das ist ja jetzt auch so eine Pokersituation. Jetzt muss Karten gezeigt werden. Und in den New York Times hat Frank Bruni, der dort ohnehin viel Meinungsredaktion macht, mit Christen Soltis Anderson und Nate Silver gesprochen. Nate Silver kennen wir. Der macht ja viel mit Zahlen und die Anderson auch, aber halt für die republikanische Meinungsforschung. Also ein Streitgespräch zur Frage, ist Trump jetzt eigentlich unter Wasser? Und wie sehen die jetzt anstehenden Wahlkämpfe, begonnen auch jetzt mit New York im November und so aus? Und dann die beiden Texte, Your Brain on ChatGPT. Also diese MIT-Forschung zur Frage, was läuft jetzt in unserem Gehirn wirklich ab, wenn wir GPT nutzen, in einem ganz spezifischen Anwendungsfall, den ich wahnsinnig interessant finde, denn es ist einer der hauptsächlichen meiner und grundsätzlich, wie es gerade benutzt wird. Und dann Apples Illusion of Thinking, was die jetzt in ihrer Forschung, welche Fragestellung die hatten, welche Probleme die sehen. Und wir können nur spekulieren, in welchem Rahmen Apple selbst hier ein Interesse hat, die Technik so ein bisschen Wind aus der Segel zu nehmen und so. Aber ja, ganz interessant. Das müssen wir, also ich dokumentiere halt im Grunde, was hier gerade Sprech ist.
Sehr gut. Wir sprechen also darüber gleich im Salon. Beginnen mit Letzte Chance, der neue Kanzler und der Kampf um die Demokratie von Robin Alexander und fragen uns, ob Friedrich Merz wirklich die letzte Chance ist oder eher schon die Brücke hin zur AfD. Wie gesagt, wir werden dann einen Clip hören und auch über den Journalismus, die Medien noch mal diskutieren, auch noch mal vielleicht an manche Dinge anknüpfen, die wir schon in Bezug auf Harald Wälzer und Richard David Precht uns deutlich gemacht haben. Das ist wirklich aufschlussreich, noch mal in dieses Buch reinzugehen, denn so ein Buch, das uns so ärgert, ist natürlich ideal eigentlich als Grundlage. Wer das alles hören will, kann das ganz einfach tun, nämlich kann man den Salon abonnieren. Das geht über Steady, über Apple und Patreon. Man geht einfach auf die Neue Zwanziger Seite, neuezwanziger.de. Dort ist ein goldener Button, da kommt man zu Steady. Das ist auch das von uns Präferierte. Da ist wirklich der Zugang zu allem, was wir jemals aufgenommen haben. Bei den anderen fehlen ja so die Anfangsmonate ein bisschen. Da kann man jedenfalls ein Abo abschließen mit drei Euro im Monat ist man dabei und kann dann auch Zugang haben zu allen alten Folgen, auch zu den Live-Salons. Man kann auch dort dann, wenn man möchte, den Salon verschenken. Und außerdem, wer schon bei Patreon ist, kann natürlich auch darüber das bequem hören. Manche wollen aber auch den Apple Cosmos aus verständlichen Gründen nicht verlassen, weil es einfach einfach ist. Da kostet es dann ein bisschen mehr, weil Apple eine größere Gebühr abverlangt. Aber auch da mit einem Klick ist man dabei und kann dann Zugang zum Salon haben.
Genau. Die Versorgung ist auch dort gesichert.
Ich will noch gerade auf den Termin im August hinweisen. Am 23. August sind wir in Bornheim, hier in Frankfurt, also direkt und werden dort unseren Sommersalon veranstalten. Karten bekommt man einfach über den Link. Da kann man sich im Saalplan etwas buchen. Man kann von allen Plätzen gut die Bühne sehen. Es ist also nicht so, dass man da irgendwie dann verdeckt ist und nur die Hälfte mitbekommt oder so. Der Saal ist klimatisiert und wir sind dann auch früh da. Und man kann uns auch davor und danach natürlich ansprechen. Und ich will noch darauf hinweisen, dass ich am 7.7. in Trier bin, um über Politik und Oper zu sprechen. Am 10.7. spreche ich in Köln über den Diskurs um die Kriegstüchtigkeit. Und am 11.7. bin ich in Ludwigshafen, um über die kleinen Holzdiebe und den Kapitalismus zu sprechen.
Sehr gut. Und heute bist du in der Oper.
Ja.
Ich kann heute leider nicht, aber ich habe sie deswegen schon gesehen.
Ja, Alchina von Händel.
Alchina. Es ist spektakulär. Also ich will jetzt grundsätzlich sagen, diese Oper, wenn die im Spielplan auftaucht, hier in Frankfurt, muss man sie sehen.
Oder sonst wo, denn es ist wirklich eine der besten Hände der Oper.
Ja, da hört man sie dann zumindest und kriegt sie wahrscheinlich auch bestens präsentiert. Aber hier in Frankfurt, Setting, 10 von 10 Sterne und natürlich Monika, abwechselnd in Hotpens und ausladenden Kleidern. Hinter mir saß ein älterer Herr, der meinte, er hätte jetzt schon sieben Alchinas gesehen. Und so albern wie heute war es ja noch nie.
Und meinte er das positiv oder negativ?
Ja, ich hab dann auch drüber nachgedacht, weil ich in diesem Moment erst dachte, ach so, die meinen das albern. Aber es traf so sehr meinen Geschmack, dass ich das erst gar nicht. Und dann hab ich gedacht, ach ja, okay, es ist albern gemeint, okay, gut. Also es ist wirklich ganz hervorragend. Ist auch eine, bei der ich jetzt sage, wenn die dann im Spielplein wieder auftaucht, sind meine Töchter fällig. Das muss man gesehen und gehört haben. Also da bin ich ein bisschen neidisch, dass sie nur noch heute und Sonntag nochmal gespielt wird.
Aber auch sonst kann man als Nina oder andere Händelopern natürlich überall erleben. Jetzt nicht laufend, aber sie werden doch viel gespielt. Das Barock Revival dauert ja Gott sei Dank an und immer werden diese Opern gegeben. Insofern ist da Frankfurt nicht der einzige Ort dafür.
Außerdem, ich wünsche mir Hinweise, denn ich war bei meiner ersten Städelausstellungseröffnung. Werner Tüpke wurde ausgestellt, Zeichnung gemacht. Ein wohl sehr zurückhaltender Künstler, der viel gezeichnet, aber dann auch mit Farbe gearbeitet hat. Und es war eine Privatsammlung von Eduard Boucan, der auf der Bühne mit war, um die Einführung zu machen. Man hat sich dagegen entschieden, einen Vortrag zu halten bei 36 Grad, oder ob das mit dem Wetter zu tun hat, weiß ich nicht. Es fand wohl für die Leute dort ungewöhnlich ein Dialog statt. Für mich, okay, das war die erste Veranstaltung. Und er hat ja damals unter Joachim Fest im Vöhtor geschrieben. Und war dann gleichzeitig noch so dieser Kunst zugewandt, dass er da selber diese Sammlung aufgebaut hat und so. Und es war ein so überraschender Einblick, kann man gar nicht eintauchen, in dieses alte Vöhtor-Leben, als die Welt noch richtig funktioniert hat. Und noch Platz war, nach vier Seiten Politik und drei davon langweilig, sich dem Vöhtor hinzugeben und nicht alle die ganze Zeit hier, ist es jetzt die letzte Chance und so. Also das war sehr gut. Wenn sowas häufiger stattfindet, würde ich da gern häufiger hingehen. Und es scheint ja wohl häufiger stattzufinden.
Also du möchtest jetzt die Kranken des Vöhtor verbunden mit der Kunst erleben.
Ja, ich möchte grundsätzlich sehen, was in diesen Museen los ist. Und ich habe festgestellt, in so einer Ausstellung geht man mit ganz anderen Augen, wenn man vorher einfach eine Stunde... Also in der Oper blenden wir die Einführungsveranstaltungen ein bisschen aus, weil die Oper ist das Erlebnis. Das ist natürlich bei Ausstellungen so ein bisschen anders.
Man kann es so oder so machen. Also es kommt drauf an. Ich habe natürlich auch schon schreckliche Ausstellungseröffnungen erlebt oder sehr gute Operneinführungen. Aber ich würde dann sagen, du musst dann auch manchmal Frankfurt verlassen. Du musst dann aufweichen, denn Deutschland hat ja ganz wunderbare Museen. Auch die kleineren Städte, ob das in Brühl das Max-Ernst-Museum ist oder das Burda-Museum in Baden-Baden, was auch immer.
Wer ich auch bereite, gibt es da gerne.
In Schwerbisch-Hall ist der Wirt, hat ja da seine große Sammlung auch. Das ist interessant. Es gibt viele Orte. Jetzt gehen wir aber erstmal in den Salon, werden also jetzt über viel Politik diskutieren und ob wir wirklich an dem Punkt sind, wo wir sagen, ja Friedrich Merz ist unsere letzte Chance. Er rettet uns vielleicht sogar. Skepsis ist angesagt und wir müssen ja mit dem Journalismus hart ins Gericht gehen. Das jetzt alles gleich im Salon. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr den Salon abonniert.
Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Warum sind auf diesem Bild die Gesichter, die da drauf sind?
Auf dem Cover sind Weide, Trump und Merz, aber da könnten auch die Köpfe der Ampel sein.
Das habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Wir wissen ja, wie so Titel, Verlage machen, Vorschläge, wie auch immer. Die erste Idee war Stresstest. Die aktuelle ist letzte Chance. Ich kann einfach nur sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die Verbindung zwischen Titel und Buch ist.
Was er immer wieder versucht, weil er glaube ich selbst merkt, dass der Titel nicht eingelöst wird vom Text und das Cover schon gar nicht eingelöst. Dass der Text das schon gar nicht eingelöst, was das Cover heißt. Versucht er immer wieder, nachdem er 50 Seiten beschrieben hat, wo es wieder geknazt hat bei der Ampel, zu sagen und daraus kann Friedrich Merz lernen, dies und das ist wichtig, Vertrauen ist wichtig oder in kleinen Ausschüssen zu tagen, ist wichtig. Er sollte nicht noch einmal den Fehler von Scholz begehen. So als könne man jetzt hier so eine Gebrauchsanweisung finden, die aber nur aus der Negation heraus funktioniert. Dann kann man sagen, ja, gut damals haben drei Parteien regiert, das macht das ohnehin schon mal komplizierter. Dann gibt es so ein Proporz bei den Grünen, dass die immer zu zweit auflaufen und dann verdoppeln sich irgendwelche Sitzungen da durch, weil die anderen sagen, dann würden die aber auch zu zweit und so Dinge. Ja, gut, dann kann ich sagen, ja, das sollte man auf jeden Fall nicht mehr machen. Aber ob das jetzt das Entscheidende ist, mit dem Friedrich Merz verhindern kann, dass die AfD regiert, das ist alles so ein bisschen hingebogen. Ich würde sagen, dies ist ein Buch, das folgendermaßen entstanden ist. Es war absehbar, dass die Ampel nicht zu ihrem regulären Ende kommt, sondern frühzeitig sich verabschiedet. Und dann wird Robin Alexander angefangen haben, seine Notizen zu sammeln, zu korrektieren, zu schreiben, dann auch schon entsprechende Abschnitte blockweise. Und so konnte man dann dieses Buch ja auch relativ schnell produzieren. Denn wir sitzen jetzt hier, wir sind Anfang Juli ausgestattet mit einem 380 Seiten langen, eng beschriebenen Buch. Das da heißt Der neue Kanzler im Untertitel und der Kampf um die Demokratie. Aber natürlich erfahren wir von dem aktuellen Friedrich Merz relativ wenig, sondern wir bekommen noch diesen merkwürdigen zweiten Wahlgang mit, wie es dann Friedrich Merz doch noch schafft. Wir bekommen mit, dass er die Schuldenbremse dann direkt lockern will, als er noch gar nicht zum Kanzler gewählt wurde. Aber es ist nicht ein Buch, das hinausblickt jetzt in die nächsten Jahre, die da kommen werden, sondern es ist vor allem ein Buch, das nochmal resümiert, was war alles bei der Ampel, was sie dann zum Scheitern gebracht hat. Und daraus wird immer mal wieder abgeleitet die ein oder andere Lektion, die Friedrich Merz angeblich daraus lernen kann, wo ich sagen würde, naja, kann man eigentlich nicht, denn das ist ja das Besondere eigentlich an diesen Zeiten, dass man so wenig extrapolieren kann.
Genau, also die ganze Anlage des Buches ist der früheste Termin, der, glaube ich, genannt wird, ist 2021. Die Grünen versuchen doch noch mit Laschet und so die Ampel zu verhindern. Und dann sitzt aber Söder da und sagt, nee, wenn ihr über die Schuldenbremse reden wollt, dann nicht. Also machen sie halt Ampel. Ja, also es beginnt sozusagen oder sagen wir mal so, diese Szene kommt relativ spät, aber die ganze Chronologie, die hier aufgezogen wird, beginnt gleich mit so, ah ja, da sind sie eigentlich schon gescheitert und die CDU ist standfest geblieben und so weiter und so fort. Und das letzte Ereignis, was dann beschrieben wird, ist eben März im Bundestag. Also März soll gewählt werden im Bundestag und es gelingt nicht beim ersten Anlauf. Und da habe ich so gedacht, ja, das ist eigentlich wahnsinnig interessant. Dieses Buch endet jetzt gezwungenermaßen zu einem Zeitpunkt, in dem es dann halt publiziert werden muss, was finde ich zu der interessanten Beobachtung führt, dass jetzt gerade, in der Robin Alexander uns sein Buch verkaufen möchte, ja ein SPD-Parteitag abläuft, bei dem einfach klar geworden ist, dass Lars Klingbeil auf 65 Prozent oder so kommt. Und ich mir sage, kommt Leute, 1 plus 1 ist 2. Diese verlorenen Stimmen von Friedrich Merz im Bundestag sind natürlich Lars Klingbeil zuzuschieben. Und wenn man das journalistisch, also im Sinne von die SPD-ler haben die Stimme verweigert, sind uns zufrieden. Genau. Was ja dann bedeutet, dadurch, dass wir den Fakt, wie Klingbeil dasteht, jetzt haben, ist eigentlich die ganze Geschichte dieser aktuellen Regierung schon erklärt. Weil, wenn sich das in den Interaktionen niederschlägt, dass ja Klingbeil März im Stich gelassen hat, sozusagen, dann ist da auch andere Stimmung.
Ja, beziehungsweise Klingbeil einfach nicht geliebt ist von seinen eigenen Leuten und die dann möglicherweise anfangen, das auch zu torpedieren.
Also wenn man im Stil der Robin Alexanders darüber schreiben würde, wäre völlig klar, in vier Jahren oder in drei Jahren, wenn die Koalition auch wieder vorher bricht, weil und so weiter, die SPD dann irgendwie bei sieben Prozent sagt, nee, Notbremse und so. Wird einfach genau so eine Chronistenarbeit abgeliefert, die mit diesem beim SPD-Parteitag haben wir es verstanden. Und genau diesen Moment hat jetzt er gerade verpasst, in dieses Buch reinzuschreiben. Also finde ich auch so ein bisschen lustig.
Ja, es wird ja immer nach so Schlüsselmomenten gesucht. Und damit beginnt ja das Buch dann auch gleich. Friedrich Merz will eigentlich mal nach Hause fahren ins Sauerland, will ein bisschen Ruhe haben. Er bekommt aber schon, wenn er ins Auto steigt, eine Nachricht, schau dir da unbedingt mal ein Video an. Und es ist natürlich das berühmte Video im Oval Office. Zelensky ist zu Gast, wird da gedemütigt von Trump und JD Vance. Und jetzt wird geschildert.
Das ist nur, um jetzt ungemütlich ins Detail zu gehen und so. Aber es ist Wladimir Zelensky, der Präsident des von Ostern überfallenen Landes. Merz schätzt ihn sehr.
Zweimal hat er ihn in Kiew besucht.
Genau. Also es ist so dieser Textverlauf, oder der neue Kanzler soll endlich den Taurus liefern. Macht das auch? Das wird ja dann gleich erklärt und so.
Ja.
Aber jetzt sieht Zelensky müde aus, müde und hilflos, bestürzt, muss Merz mit ansehen, wie der US-Präsident den Ukrainer demütigt. Und dann im Verlauf nennt er aber gar nicht JD Vance sozusagen, sondern der Satz beginnt dann so, also, so könnte man dann auf Literatizität oder wie das auch immer heißt.
Literatizität.
Auch ein zweiter Mann hackt verbal auf Zelensky ein. Haben sie jemals Danke gesagt? Und dann erst wird JD Vance beim Namen genannt und so, ja, als wäre das so, auch ein zweiter Mann spielt in diesem, ich will in diesem Buch über die Person reden.
Ja, das ist, so schreibt man ein Krimi. Das ist der Wunsch, Spannung Friedrich Merz, Gespannter und man muss ja so einen Krimi erzeugen, um jetzt zu sagen, das ist der Moment, in dem Friedrich Merz wieder aus der Emotion heraus, könnte man sagen, ja, aus einer doppelten Emotion, seine eigene und die Emotion im Overload ist, klar wird, vielleicht geht die NATO zu Bruch. Wir brauchen sehr viel mehr Geld für die Aufrüstung. Wir müssen die Schuldenbremse reformieren. Wir sitzen ja hier seit Jahr und Tag und sagen, ja, die CDU wartet nun darauf, das zu machen. Du hast immer gesagt, ja, an Tag eins, wenn Friedrich Merz Kanzler ist, wird er das machen. Okay, war da noch ein bisschen früher noch, eh er Kanzler ist, an Tag Null hat er das gemacht. Aber jetzt wird uns hier verkauft, dass die Schuldenbremse eigentlich feststand. Nur jetzt plötzlich dieses Ereignis ändert das. Also was man hier schon macht, ist Friedrich Merz zu entschuldigen. Der hat gar nicht irgendwie die Leute an der Nase herumgeführt. Die haben das nicht deshalb nicht als Thema gemacht in ihrem Wahlprogramm oder so, weil Friedrich Merz wusste, dass er damit jetzt keine Erfolge einziehen kann, sondern jetzt erst durch dieses Ereignis sind die auf die Idee gekommen, Mensch, ich ruf mal Udo Di Fabio an. Der soll mal gucken, wie könnte man dann sehen, dass man noch mit dem alten Bundestag was machen kann. Also es wird so getan, als hätte sonst die Schuldenbremse festgestanden. Dabei haben wir schon die ganze Zeit, ja und das schildert ja auch Robin Alexander dann später mal, CDU-Ministerpräsidenten, die sagen, bitte geht man diese Schuldenbremse an, wir können ja hier gar nichts mehr machen.
Genau.
Wir haben ja die ganze Zeit Stimmen dahin. Und ich will das hier am Anfang sein, damit ich das ja nicht vergesse. Ich habe das eben schon, ein Teaser ist mir das nicht direkt gekommen. Es wird immer wieder gesagt, Friedrich Merz wollte einen Wahlkampf machen, der auf Wirtschaftsthemen ausgerichtet ist. Ich habe ja dieses Wahlprogramm gelesen. Dieses Wahlprogramm hat wirtschaftlich fast nichts anzubieten gehabt. Es war ein bisschen Steuererleichterung, bei dem man aber vage geblieben ist, was dann jetzt so genau. Man hat, man hat irgendwas gesagt, Bürokratie, Bürokratie, Bürokratie abschaffen. Aber da war ja nicht das große industriepolitische Projekt. Oder ich würde es mir noch gefallen lassen, wenn da wirklich gestanden hätte, der Spitzensteuersatz wird halbiert und weiß ich nicht was alles. Wenn das ja da drin gestanden hätte, dann könnte man darüber streiten, ob das sinnvoll ist. Nein, das ist nicht. Aber dann würde ich sagen, okay, das war wirklich ein Wirtschaftswahlprogramm. Aber das Wirtschaftswahlprogramm war da nicht zu finden. Und folglich ist auch im Koalitionsvertrag zum Thema Steuern und so fast nichts zu finden. Und ja, jetzt bekommen die Leute, die irgendwie das höchste 3% sind, die bekommen jetzt nochmal 10.000 oder 15.000 Euro im Jahr mehr. Ja gut, das wird die jetzt auch nicht dazu bewegen, dass jetzt Rieseninvestitionen in Gang kommen. Wirtschaftspolitisch war die CDU von Anfang an total blank und hat das auch gar nicht als Karte ausspielen können. Deswegen hat man ja nur anzubieten gehabt Asylbewerber, die irgendwelche Sachen bekommen, die eigentlich nur Deutschen zustehen, Bürgergeldempfänger, die zu faul sind zu arbeiten und das ganze Geld verprassen. Das waren die Angebote, die man hatte. Man hatte nicht für die Industrie, für den Mittelstand, auch nicht für die, die zum obersten Szenen Einkommens-DC gehören, hatte man auch nichts anzubieten. Jetzt zu erzählen, dass das eigentlich ein Wirtschaftswahlkampf geworden wäre. Dann aber die Flüchtlinge kamen mit den Morden und deswegen wurde es Migration. Eigentlich wäre die Schuldenbremse nicht angetastet worden, aber dann war sie Lenski im Oval Office. Man muss doch verstehen, dass das nicht wahr sein kann.
Also wir haben hier ein Buch mit Null Tiefe. Wir müssen jede reinbauen. Im Grunde ist das ein Buch, das die ganze Zeit im Duktus des illustrativen Einführungskapitels, aber auf Seite 380 halt immer noch. So, weshalb ich jetzt mal dran erinnern möchte. Wir haben zum Beispiel über Thomas Mann gesprochen und kurz diese Idee aufgeworfen, manche Leute leben in einer Welt und nutzen dann die Literatur als Eskapismus oder sie leben eigentlich in ihrer Literaturwelt und nutzen dann die Realität nur als, ah, schöne Anekdote, baue ich in meine Literaturwelt ein. Und so ist das hier auch so ein bisschen. Und zwar auf allen Ebenen. Trump operiert so, der lebt eigentlich in seiner eigenen Welt und dann sollte die Realität mal schön passen, ansonsten wird er wütend und dann muss Mark Rutte wieder irgendwelche Nachrichten schreiben. Robin Alexander aber auch, das ist einfach so ein Narrativ. Und wenn dann Realität passiert, blendet er sie einfach aus, weil sie nicht so in den roten Faden passt. Und das ist zum Beispiel dieser eine Satz. Also diese riesige Szene, personal interest-mäßig aufgeladen, human interest, wir haben hier zwei Leute, die gegeneinander und so weiter. Alle sehen das, auch Politiker sagen dann später, wir brauchen eine Billion, wie auch immer. Aber so in Halbsätzen einfach nur, kommt dann mal Realpolitik vor. Bla, bla, bla. Ein fertig ausgehandeltes Rohstoffabkommen wird nicht unterschrieben. Ja, ich hab, also meine Argumentation damals war ja, das war der Aufhänger. Ja. Trump wollte dieses Rohstoffabkommen, wo einfach nur drin steht. Ja, dann haben wir da unsere Amerikaner, die machen irgendwas, dann wird sich schon keiner trauen, da anzugreifen. So, und das ging einfach nicht auf. Und eigentlich, ich wiederhole nochmal, war ja meine These, Selenski hatte eigentlich Trump vorgeführt und nicht umgedreht. Denn das war in Sachen Unterstützung, weltweite Mobilisierung. Deutschland ist plötzlich eine Billion und so, war das wohl sehr viel lohnenswerter für Selenski als für Trump?
Ja, beziehungsweise kannst du es auch anders sehen und sagen, nee, es war ja lohnenswert für Trump. Denn jetzt sind ja plötzlich alle NATO-Partner aufgeschreckt. Er hat nicht einfach nur gedroht, gesagt, jetzt investiert man zwei Prozent, sondern plötzlich haben die das ja gemacht, weil sie sagten, okay, mit dem ist nicht zu spaßen. Ich muss da auch in fünf Wochen sitzen. Also wir haben ja da diese Strategie und man muss auch, also man hätte sich ja auch die Mühe machen können, mal diese, wir haben ja mal im Teaser darüber gesprochen, man hätte sich ja mal Mühe machen können, diese 40 Minuten sich wirklich mal analytisch anzusehen. Und dann gibt es ja einfach Stellen, in denen sich Zelensky sehr unglücklich verhält. Also hier wird das ja einfach so getan, als wäre jetzt irgendwie Trump nur wild geworden. Aber wenn natürlich Zelensky im Oval Office sitzt und sagt, ja, also noch spüren sie das hier nicht, also sie Amerikaner, aber die Bedrohung ist da, sie spüren das noch nicht. Und dann sagt natürlich Trump zurecht, sagt uns nicht, was wir spüren sollen, weil er natürlich jetzt nicht will, dass ein fremder Präsident dem amerikanischen Volk Angst macht vor was, was auch einfach nicht geht.
Also ich meine, Gefühle werden von Trump diktiert.
Ja und man kann auch nicht hingehen, man kann auch nicht als deutscher Bundeskanzler zu den Franzosen gehen und denen sagen, also noch spüren, das nicht, aber klopft mir. Ihr solltet hier eigentlich Angst haben und Macron steht daneben. Das geht auch einfach nicht. Und es geht aber gar nicht auf diese Ebene, sondern es soll nur dabei bleiben, Friedrich Merz, Emotionen, jetzt muss gehandelt werden, Schuldenbremse muss weg, nur die Frage oder Schuldenbremse muss reformiert werden, wir brauchen Spielraum für die Bundeswehr. Die Frage ist, wie macht man es dann? Und dann findet er Wege dafür. Und Merz?
Ja, also du hast ja eben gemeint, in Bezug auf meine These, da hat eigentlich Zelensky Trump vorgeführt, weil die Mobilisierung gerade in Europa ist als Jahr ausgelöst. Es kann sich auch für Trump auszahlen, wenn die Europäer so blöd sind, ihr Verteidigungshaushalt nach Amerika zu überweisen, um dann Technik zu kaufen, die dort einfach ausgeschaltet werden kann oder sowas. Aber das sehen wir dann erst in den nächsten zehn Jahren, diese Budgets. Aber für die Ukraine ist es auf jeden Fall gut, wie sich Europa gerade grundsätzlich mobilisiert. Davon werden die ja gerade jetzt, wo die Waffenlieferungen ernsthaft versagt werden. Und die Fernsehshow von Trump führt natürlich dazu, dass Merz jetzt davor sitzt und dann denkt, unter diesen Umständen muss Deutschland selbst wehrhaft werden. Dann denkt dann Robin Alexander für Merz, für uns. Das sind die Gedankengänge. Aber die Demütigung von Zelensky habe alles geändert, so sagt er. Also in so kleinen Hinweisen ist schon, das ist ein gesponnenes Narrativ, aber so sagt er. Man hätte genauso gut eine Alternative aufziehen können, dass man in den Buch jetzt einfach in die Analyseebene wechselt und sich fragt, warum hat Merz jetzt gesagt, Deutschland muss jetzt aufrüsten, warum gibt es jetzt nicht die große Initiative zum europäischen Militär oder sowas. Aber diese Analysebene findet da alles gar nicht statt. Mit Trumps Attacken ist für Friedrich Merz tatsächlich eine Welt zusammengebrochen. Man liest so diese Kapitel und denkt sich, wow, der ist echt alarmiert, der hat Angst vor Trump. Merz schläft nachts schlecht, weil er weiß, der hält heute in Amerika eine Rede und morgen früh ist die Nachrichtenlage aus der NATO ausgetreten. Putin hat das Baltikum überfallen und so. Und zwei Monate später sitzen wir alle da und fragen uns, wie tief will der Merz sich bücken, um auf dem Foto mit Trump cool auszusehen? Also es hat irgendwie gar keine Konsequenz. Robin Alexander erklärt uns hier über emotionale Sachverhalte auf, bei denen wir doch im Fernsehen abend sehen, dass sie ja doch keine Konsequenz haben.
Ja, ich würde auch einfach dem widersprechen wollen, dass das so realistisch ist. Also hier wird ja immer wieder gesagt, es gab wohl eine Rede, eine Trumps Kongressrede, da hätte eigentlich drin gestanden, dass sie aus der NATO austreten und dann sei das aber nicht gekommen. Und ich frage mich, was spricht dann eigentlich dafür? Also die NATO ist ein Bündnis für die Amerikaner. Das ist nicht irgendwie so eine kleine Sozialhilfe für Europäer. Also, dass er da so in dieser Form austritt, dass das als Drohkulisse verwendet wird, damit alle aufrüsten. Was sie ja dann tun, dass mittlerweile ein Überbietungswettbewerb da ist, 5 Prozent, 7 Prozent, dass das natürlich von ihm genutzt wird, ist vollkommen klar. Aber die Amerikaner würden ja nicht einfach alles abziehen. Was würde das auch bedeuten für andere Konfliktregionen? Also das ist ja jetzt nicht einfach so, dass sie sagen, wir überlassen Europa, Europa und damit ist gut, sondern das hat ja eine direkte Auswirkung auf Amerika. Also das einfach so zu tun, als wäre jetzt Trump schon ganz kurz davor gewesen und das hat auch März gewusst und deswegen müssen wir aufrüsten, ist ja ganz verrückt. Ich würde eher so weit gehen und sagen, also wenn das wirklich die Option gewesen wäre, also ist das wirklich so realistisch, dass jetzt Trump sagt, jetzt ist Schluss, wir ziehen hier alles ab, nichts mehr ist da, NATO gibt es nicht mehr, löst sich alles auf. Ja, dann müsste man ja in einer ganz anderen Weise vorgehen. Also dann würde ja selbst diese Lockerung, die man da vorgenommen hat, dieser Spielraum von einer Billion oder was, überhaupt nicht ausreichen. Ja, also ich meine, also es wird wirklich so getan, als sei das jetzt einfach so mal ganz kurz dran vorbei geschrabt und März hat aber nur diese äußeren Faktoren, die so kurzzeitig dann aufeinander kamen, zum Anlass genommen, die Schuldenbremse zu reformieren.
Ich bin ja ein großer Befürworter von einer Politik, ich habe es ja schon beschrieben, die im Sinne Mark Rotes Amerika Honig ums Maul schmiert, semantisch, aber strukturell ganz hart dagegen arbeitet. Und so könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass Emmanuel Macron durchaus da in seinem Palast sitzt und eigentlich darauf hofft, dass das große Gewitter mal kommt und dann Trump einfach sagt, ich mache es jetzt ohne Europa, weil dann kann man das auch alles mal, dann muss er halt selber klarkommen, so, dann ist einfach die Aufgabenstellung klar. Und es wird aber hier nicht verhandelt und wenn nur so angedeutet. Also die Schöpfungshöhe politisch ist gerade so, dass man irgendwas mit der Schuldenbremse macht.
Aber ich frage mich jetzt nochmal ganz konkret, warum sollte das Verhältnis zu den Amerikanern schlechter sein gerade? Als unter Joe Biden. Also ich frage jetzt wirklich, also alle sagen jetzt ja, was der mit den Universitäten macht oder so.
Die Zölle, das macht schon einen echten Unterschied.
Gut, aber die Zölle bekomme ich ja auch nicht weg, indem ich jetzt aus der NATO aussteige oder selbst mich eigenständig mache. Das wird ja eher noch schlimmer. Also man ist ja so sehr daran gebunden an diese transatlantische Partnerschaft, dass doch jetzt nicht ernsthaft Macron oder Merz oder sonst irgendjemand sich wünschen könnte, dass das zerbricht. Genauso wie sich die Amerikaner das nicht wünschen. Es geht jetzt darum, auch ja mit Blick auf China, da macht die EU ja die Blockbildung vollkommen mit, natürlich wieder als Verbund stark zu sein und bedeutet also, dass man sich so gegenseitig unter Druck setzt. Wer rüstet am meisten aus? Aber ich sehe wirklich keinerlei Loslösungen, die auf der Ebene. Ich sehe auch keine Begründung darin. Also jetzt von mir aus ja, aber ich sehe doch jetzt nicht, dass bei der CDU zum Beispiel eine Loslösung ist. Macron ist ein klassisches Beispiel für eine transatlantische Karriere. Und wenn man sieht, wer war zum Beispiel bei der Inauguration von Trump, natürlich die Familie Arnaud, das teuerste Unternehmen Frankreichs.
Ja, wir sind ja hier noch. Klar, Robin Alexander geht jetzt eh nicht so in die Wirtschaftspolitik, aber wir haben immer eine Zweigleisigkeit. Also Verteidigungspolitik, Wirtschaftspolitik. In Europa ja auch. Also die Briten können aus dem Binnenmarkt aussteigen, sind wirtschaftlich wirklich abgekoppelt und stehen auf sich selber. Und Armutswellen gehen durch dieses Land. In der Verteidigungspolitik sind sie natürlich voll NATO-Mitglied, europäische Verteidigungspolitik, erste Annäherung direkt über Verteidigungspolitik und so weiter. So ist auch das Verhältnis mit Amerika. Die wirtschaftlichen Einschnitte durch die Zölle, die ja bisher erst mal nur angedroht sind und die Börsen auch so ahja, nee, hat's ausgesetzt, pausiert, direkt wieder hoch. Es glaubt ja keiner so richtig dran. Aber da sind ja nur noch wenige Tage, fünf, sechs Tage. Heute ist der 4. Juli. Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob es heute oder morgen oder so ist, dass die Zoll-Dinger dann einfach greifen. So und dann liegen die Karten einfach auf den Tisch. Das allerdings ist entkoppelt von diesem ganzen NATO-Spektakel. Wenn wir jetzt aber sagen würden, nur mal so illustrativ, die Verteidigungspolitik würden wir gerade genauso machen wie die Wirtschaftspolitik zwischen Amerika und Europa, dann wäre NATO schon Geschichte. Also so hart greift diese Zollpolitik da gerade rein. Und von daher würde ich sagen, ja, wir können halt nicht alles zuspitzen auf die eine Person und ihr Verhalten in Interaktion, sondern wenn wir die ganze Vielschichtigkeit mit dazu nehmen, was uns Robin Alexander ja verwehrt, durch seinen ständigen Fokus wie in so einem Drehbuch auf Personen, sehen wir das alles nicht. Aber diese politischen Verwerfungen sind real und echt da und die haben auch Konsequenzen. Ich kenne das selber aus meiner Familie, dass Leute eigentlich so Pläne hatten, Renteneintritt, aber die Firma hat schon geregelt mit der Rentenkasse, ich kann ja länger arbeiten und so weiter. Und dann heißt plötzlich, ne, Trumps Zölle, jetzt ist erstmal jeder Plan vom Tisch. Also das geht wirklich richtig tief und hat schon Wirkung.
Ja, das glaube ich, dass das Wirkung hat, nur sehe ich jetzt nicht, wo gerade irgendwo geplant wird, eine Alternative zur NATO zu errichten. Denn das würde ja bedeuten, dass man zum Beispiel andere Partnerschaften, andere Bündnisse pflegen sollte. Die Hälfte der Welt, mit denen machen wir eh nichts, weil wir die als Antisemiten ansehen. Mit China sagen wir, das ist autoritär, da müssen wir eine Blockbildung machen, dass die nicht mehr über uns investieren können und so weiter. Also da macht man schon die ganze Zeit eine massive Zollpolitik. Gut, mit Russland kann man ja ganz offenkundig sowieso nicht. Wie bleibt dann jetzt noch?
Also was will man da machen? Darauf kann ich dir eine ganz sozio-logisch eiskalte Antwort geben. Robin Alexander macht uns ja ein Denkangebot, das wir gerne annehmen, weil wir glauben, das stimmt irgendwie und wir haben es ja auch schon als Gefahr markiert. Nämlich, dass Trump, dass sich März überrumpeln lässt von entweder emotionalen Ereignissen, die er mittelbar erlebt oder die ihm geschildert werden. Und dann ist für ihn plötzlich alles anders, jetzt reicht es, jetzt muss Zäsur organisiert werden. So, in Sachen wirtschaftliche Verflechtung zu Amerika ist völlig egal, was deutsche Politiker dazu machen. Also du suchst jetzt zu Recht politische Planung, wer organisiert denn hier was. Aber Amerikaner treffen gerade politische Entscheidungen hinsichtlich, wenn Container mit Waren darüber kommt, kostet das Geld. Europäische Unternehmen leiden darunter. Es ist völlig unerheblich, ob in Berlin noch irgendeine Ausschusssitzung zu irgendeinem Thema stattfindet, weil wir ja die ganze Zeit schon thematisieren, einen Amerikaner kriegst du gerade eh nicht. Die wissen gar nicht, wo sie anrufen sollten und was auch immer. Also nur weil wir keine politische Planung sehen, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass hier sich Sachen aufstauen, bei denen dann irgendwann und sei es der nächste Wahlkämpfer sagt, ey sorry, Markaten auf den Tisch. Also so geht das nicht. Was macht ihr hier eigentlich? Darüber würde ich gerne was lesen. Also über dieses Nicht-Primat der Politik, aber in einem Buch, das uns 400 Seiten lang, nicht nur vom Primat der Politik, sondern der Primat der Politik heißt Friedrich Merz. Und mit der Primat meine ich jetzt auch den doppelten Wurzel.
Das Primat, ja.
Genau. Da kommen wir natürlich hier nicht rein in dieses Thema.
Wir haben ja schon das letzte Mal über Geoökonomie gesprochen. Also ich sehe, ja gut, das ist natürlich eine theoretische Ebene, dieses Buch überhaupt nicht hier von Robin Alexander aufweisen kann, an keiner einzigen Stelle. Nein, was ich aber nicht glaube, ist, dass diese Entflechtung da gerade, diese Entkopplung, dass man Europa und Amerika sich entkoppeln sieht, in dieser geopolitischen Strategie, die sehe ich überhaupt nicht.
Semantisch. Und finde die auch nicht statt. Und ich habe ja sogar dafür geworben, dass wir sie semantisch sie nochmal besonders betonen.
Ja, ja, ich sehe es aber.
RUTTE soll seine Nachrichten schreiben.
Ja, aber RUTTE schreibt ja nicht nur Nachrichten, sondern es ist ja eine Aufrüstung von der zum Beispiel die US-Industrie, die Waffenindustrie sehr stark profitiert.
Das sagst du jetzt so, weil es historisch immer so war und wir dann eine Sehgewohnheit haben. Große Formatstarre im transatlantischen Verhältnis. Aber ob das wirklich so kommt, das müssen wir noch abwarten.
Zweiter Punkt Israel. Israel ist nun nicht nur mit Deutschland aus geschichtlichen Gründen besonders eng verbunden und natürlich dann Staatsräson, U-Boot, Lieferung und so etwas, sondern gleichermaßen ja mit den USA. Ja, da gibt es jetzt auch immer mal wieder Ärger zwischen Netanyahu und Trump. Aber das ist ja auch ein Dreieck, das verbindet. Also ich würde nur sehr große Skepsis anmelden, wenn es darum geht, dass man sich irgendwie von Trump gerade löst. Gerade, also die Politik, die Deutschland und die EU gerade macht, ist genau die, die Trump möchte. Genau. Und das ist nicht nur Semantik, sondern das ist ja auch Geld, wird wohin bewegt und gewonnen.
Ja, also diese 5% sind für 2035 oder so dann.
Wir werden sehen. Jedenfalls verkündet ja dann Merz, whatever it takes. Ja, denn er hält ja den Austritt aus der NATO für möglich. Und deswegen müssen man jetzt das alles neu nochmal durchdenken. Und dann ist er also bereit, das mit der Schuldenbremse zu machen. Allerdings, so schildert dann Robin Alexander, gestaltet sich das erstmal schwierig, weil Friedrich Merz ja sein Problem damit hat, mit den Grünen überhaupt ins Gespräch zu kommen. Da gibt es dann diese berühmte Mailbox-Anekdote.
Dieser Wortlaut hier mit, wir können jetzt, wir haben ja gerade Penn gehört, bei der Frage, was will der Autor uns mitteilen, auch im Sinne von welche Aufrichtigkeitskommunikation schwingt denn im Text mit, die uns zeigen sollen? Erstens, ich schreibe hier die Wahrheit. Zweitens, ich schreibe über das, was wichtig ist und wie auch immer. Der Wortlaut hier ist, kein Zweifel. Merz ist aufrichtig empört über den Erklar im Oval Office. Aber diese Empörung weiß er auch zu nutzen. Offenbar gibt es Menschen in Deutschland, die dieses Buch lesen und dann Robin Alexander in die Falle gehen sollen mit, Merz ist aufrichtig empört. Ah, er meint es ernst. Sein Herz ist rein. Und dann, aber diese Empörung weiß er auch zu nutzen. Ah, er hat Kompetenzen, die ich nicht habe. Ja, irgendwie so. Also das scheint so die Unterstellung des Publikums, für das Publikum zu sein, dass hier Traktion drin ist, in dem Fortlauf, während wir einfach nur denken, ne, der ist nicht empört, der ist überrumpelt. Und diese Überrumpelung weiß er auch zu nutzen. Wie denn? Also wir haben noch kein Beispiel dafür gesehen. So, ja, also dieses, man findet überhaupt keinen Zugang zu diesem Buch, weil man es von vornherein schon ablehnt, so wie ich. Und dann ist es wirklich einfach eine Schrottliteratur, die uns so ein Gedankenbeutel aufbaut. Sascha Loba hat das mal so Erlebnisschrott, was wäre das jetzt? Erlebnis-Schrott-Blocken, ja, so ungefähr. Und das ist ja hier auch, es ist so ein, ich war dabei, ich schreibe es euch auf, aber Traktion so richtig hat es nicht.
Ja, es liegt, glaube ich, daran, dass Politik so gedacht wird nur, also man hat ja mal irgendwann in der Geschichte sich gedacht in dem Fach, wir können nicht immer nur große Männer machen Geschichte erzählen, sondern wir müssen nochmal andere Perspektiven darauf einnehmen. Und hier ist aber nur große oder kleinere Männer oder Frauen machen Politik. Und jetzt gibt es einzelne große Ereignisse, die sind immer so ein Umschwung. Und das ist aber, glaube ich, einfach eine dramaturgische Entscheidung, die plötzlich Friedrich Merz in die Schuhe geschoben wird, im Sinne von, jetzt ändert sich für ihn alles. Nein, das ist eine Art, so ein Buch zu erzählen. Das ist jetzt mal der, der muss ja einen großen Bogen spannen. Also er kommt aus einem Business, in dem er tagtäglich einen Podcast aufnimmt und nochmal sagt, ja, da hat sich Klingbeil zu weit vorgewagt, da hätte aber Ricarda Lang das und das machen müssen. Also das ist ja immer so von heute auf morgen. Und der Podcast von gestern ist schon überholt. Du hast es uns ja eben vorgespielt. Ja, einmal bewertet er das so, Emotionen und Vorbereitung geht nicht zusammen. Irgendwann später sagt er, Vorbereitung und Emotionen gehen sehr gut zusammen. Das widerspricht sich nicht. So und das ist der alltägliche Modus, in dem solches journalistisches Arbeiten stattfindet. Bei einem Buch braucht man einen größeren Bogen, braucht man Cliffhanger, braucht man entsprechende Pointen, braucht man so kleine Spannungspunkte, auf die es zuläuft. Und dann hat er jetzt diesen Knall im Oval Office. Und daran lehnt er jetzt so eine Erzählung an, die dann wieder von was Nächstem eingeholt wird. Und dann geht es wieder zurück. Wie war das denn damals bei der Ampel? Und da gab es doch auch schon mal so einen großen Knatsch. Und der hat dann da und dort hin zu gefügt. Ich glaube, dass diese Art der Berichterstattung deshalb auch so beliebt ist, weil man dann diese Politiker wie Romanfiguren rezipieren kann. Und zwar im Unterhaltungsroman. Wer macht jetzt was als nächstes? Wie hat Habeck reagiert? Aber jetzt heißt es dann, macht er erst einmal Smalltalk. Lästert mit den grünen Frauen über die AfDs, geht dann um Dobrindt, der jetzt plötzlich da so mit den Grünen sich ein bisschen, ja, sagen wir, auf ein gutes Gleis stellen muss, damit die Grünen einwilligen bei dieser Schuldenbremsreform. Und sagt, als diese sich noch einmal über den harten Wahlkampf gegen Habeck beschweren, ach, ich kriege es doch auch ständig auf die Fresse von euch. Dobrindt schlägt vor, die Verhandlungen in die parlamentarische Gesellschaft zu verlegen. Da dürfen Journalisten nicht rein. Und die Küche öffnet notfalls die ganze Nacht. Gelingt doch noch ein Kompromiss. Ausgerechnet der Grüne, der die Ökopartei stets in die Mitte positionieren wollte, argumentiert weiter dagegen. Also Habeck soll März doch in der kommenden Legislaturperiode sein Glück versuchen und mit der Linken eine Mehrheit verhandeln. Rät der noch immer gekränkte Habeck? Doch jetzt widerspricht ihm eine grüne Stimme aus der Vergangenheit, die noch mehr Gewicht hat. Joschka Fischer, der frühere Außenminister und Oberrealo, lässt sich im Heute-Journal interviewen. Jetzt würde ich aber eine Ehrenrettung mal vornehmen für Robin Alexander.
Hättest du das gut geschrieben?
Ja, das hat so einen Sound. Man kann das so unterlesen. Das ist nicht meine Art von Literatur, sage ich mal. Auch wenn es fiktiv wäre, ist das nicht meine Art. Warum will ich jetzt eine kleine Ehrenrettung vornehmen? Ich kann das natürlich, wie ich das eben auch deutlich machte, sagen, ja, das sind so literarische Strategien, um Spannend zu erzählen. Und ich habe mich aber immer wieder bei dem Gedanken ertappt. Und ich habe es eben schon angedeutet, als wir diese Clips zum emotionalen März gespielt haben bei Aschaffenburg und so, mich gefragt, ist es vielleicht doch so, dass der Modus der Politiker so ist, wie Robin Alexander den beschreibt. Sind die vielleicht, machen die sich vielleicht zu Akteuren in einem Trivialroman?
Dazu habe ich eine sehr gute Antwort, denn ich habe als Verlegenheitsliteratur für den Fall, dass ich wusste noch nicht genau, ob ich heute so zwei Texte zusammenbinde oder wie auch immer. Es gibt in der New York Times einen Text von Tyler Pager. Zwischen den Gipfeln von Trump, also zwischen, er reist früher vom G7-Gipfel ab und Macron schreibt noch so, er bereitet den Frieden in Iran vor und Trump dann so, nee, mache ich nicht. Ich mache was anderes. Und wir wissen heute, er hat das Ding. Und dann passiert das ja, bevor er auf dem NATO-Gipfel auftaucht. So, und der Pager argumentiert einfach, das, was wir von Trump sehen, und zwar in irgendwelchen Social Media Posts ab vor 6 Uhr bis Mitternacht, in Eingesprächen und so weiter, ist einfach das Ding. Und wenn wir jetzt sagen, das ist aber verwirrend, wir kommen gar nicht weiter, wir brauchen hier eine Deutung, dann heißt das einfach nur, es gibt nichts zu deuten, weil Trump weiß es selber grad nicht. Wenn Trump da steht und sagt, ich lasse mir zwei Wochen Zeit, und einen Tag später heißt es aber, die Flugzeuge waren schon in der Luft, dann war für Trump selber noch dieses, sie können jederzeit Nein sagen, wir fliegen nur schon mal los für den Fall und so weiter, weil Zeitpläne, aber sie können jedenfalls, also sie können immer Nein sagen, dann fliegen die einfach wieder zurück und so weiter. Und bis die sagen, also wenn wir abwerfen, dann jetzt, wir müssten zurück zum Tanken fliegen und so, sagen sie jetzt Ja oder Nein, und dann sagt Trump Ja. Und in dem Moment weiß die Weltöffentlichkeit, okay, ist das passiert? Und früher hat es keiner gewusst, auch nicht Trump. So, und das gilt hier auch.
Genau.
Das ist einfach, diese Leute, also im Endeffekt ist ja der ganze T-Note dieses Buches immer wieder, Merz war überrascht, er war wirklich schockiert, es gab wieder ein Ereignis, das ihm offensichtlich Klarheit verschaffte am nächsten Tag, er war wieder überrascht und so weiter. Man könnte ja auch das Gegenprogramm aufschreiben. Erst hatten sie keinen Plan, dann hatten sie ihn nicht eingehalten, dann haben sie wieder versucht, einen Plan zu machen, haben wieder nicht gemacht, dann kam wieder eine Erzählung, die sie hinweggerissen hat. Und so stehen die einfach auf einer Theaterbühne. Wir wissen natürlich, da gibt es einen Regisseur, der hat denen geschrieben, was sie machen sollen. Aber für uns, das unbedarfte Publikum, passiert das alles gerade sozusagen aus der Situation hinaus. Und in der Realität gibt es halt keinen Regisseur. Also die stehen selber genauso da und versuchen aus der Situation heraus. Also davon bin ich mittlerweile sehr überzeugt.
Ja, okay, aber dann müssen wir ja in gewisser Weise Ablöte tun. Es ist ja dann doch so, wie Robin Alexander schon mit seinem Buch von 2017 suggeriert, dass sie es nämlich die Getriebenen, wir haben es mit Getriebenen zu tun.
Das wäre ein sehr guter Titel, hier auch wieder gewesen.
Ja, und das ist ja dann auch ein interessanter Punkt. Also wenn wir jetzt mal über die Kritik an Robin Alexanders Stil oder Art darüber nachzudenken hinausgehen, dann müssen wir ja eigentlich feststellen, dass wir von Leuten regiert werden, die absolut im Reizreaktionsschema die ganze Zeit unterwegs sind und auch immer wissen, dass sie eine Zeit lang Spiele spielen können. Also natürlich kann Habeck erstmal sagen, ohne mich Schuldenreform, Bremse und so, das ihr früher mal machen können. Aber er weiß natürlich genauso wie alle anderen es wissen, okay, wenn es jetzt dann drauf ankommt, werde ich natürlich auch meinen Kurs wieder darauf einstellen.
Ja, aber jetzt will ich Klammer und Klammer machen.
Das ist ja das Interessante hier.
Denn deine Frage zielt ja gerade auf, du hast von Dobrindts Sachen vorgelesen, wie er sich den Grünen gegenüber verhält und so. Da gilt, so wie ich es eben meinte, ja, das ist so ein bisschen, während wir eben schon meinten, wir wünschen uns so fast Schulz zurück, weil der versucht hat, sich dagegen aufzulehnen, also einen Plan durchzuziehen. Ja. Nein, ich liefere keine Waffen oder wie auch immer. Und das haben wir hier eben auch. Merz steht auf einer Bühne und sagt, spätestens seit den Äußerungen von US-Präsident Donald Trump in der letzten Woche ist für mich klar, dass den Amerikanern, jedenfalls diesem Teil der Amerikaner, dieser Regierung das Schicksal Europas weitgehend gleichgültig ist. Diese Linie kann man durchziehen. Also erst mal den Standpunkt kann man haben. Das hat ja Merkel damals nach dem ersten Besuch auch gehabt, dass sie dann in so einem Festzelt plötzlich so meinte, oh, das wird jetzt kritisch mit den Amerikanern. Und die kann man dann auch durchhalten. Also diesen Standpunkt kann man durchhalten. Nur wenn Robin Alexander uns sowas hier schreibt. Und dann sehen wir zum Erscheinen des Buches diese Kniefälle von März erst im Oval Office, dann beim G7-Gipfel, dann beim NATO-Gipfel. Und jedes Mal stehen einfach alle hypernormalisierend daneben und sagen, zum Glück kein E-Klar, es ist mir egal, wie tief er sich gebückt hat. Dann habe ich damit ein Problem. Und wenn ein Journalist sich die Aufgabe stellt, diese Hypernormalisierung mir reinzutricksen, mit so einer elendlangen Erzählung, dass der rote Faden nun mal alternativlos und so weiter. Da ist meine Kritik.
Genau. Das Buch suggeriert einen roten Faden und es ist aber keiner da.
Genau.
Also und getrieben ist nicht nur der einzelnen Politiker, sondern sind es die Journalisten auch. Und das wird auch hier ja nicht thematisiert. Also dass die Journalisten die ganze Zeit Taurus wollten. Aber nicht die Bevölkerung mehrheitlich Taurus wollte. Das wird nicht thematisiert. Also diese Unterscheidung, die prächt und weltsam machen zwischen öffentlicher und veröffentlichter Meinung, die wird hier überhaupt gar nicht zu Kenntnis genommen, weil die öffentliche Meinung überhaupt nicht zählt. Es sei denn, man muss noch mal in irgendeiner Umfrage abfragen, ob man morgen gewählt wird. Ja, dann kann man noch mal die Öffentlichkeit befragen.
Das hat ja mehr als jetzt erlebt. Jetzt wo er Kanzler ist, ist Taurus plötzlich so, wir sind strategisch, machen wir diese ganz große Ambiguität.
Macht er erst für die Journalisten und die Journalisten akzeptieren das jetzt auch und sagen, ach toll, strategische Ambiguität.
Das wird ja nicht nur akzeptiert, sondern übernommen.
Ach, das hat er wohl auch von Pistorius, der hat das ja ihm auch schon geraten. Pistorius hat immer so gesagt, ja wir dürfen uns nicht in die Karten schauen, das ist ein Pistorius, spricht von strategischer Unberechenbarkeit. Putin soll auch gar nicht wissen, wie viel Deutschland aufrüstet und so. Und plötzlich wird das als sowas ganz Geniales dargestellt. Aber das ist einfach nur eine Entscheidung, dass man sagt, gut, ich stelle das jetzt als genial dar. Er geht ja dann auf, wir springen gerade mal ein bisschen, ich glaube, es ist ganz sinnvoll. Er geht ja zum Beispiel dann immer wieder darauf ein, dass Scholz mit der Angst spielt der Bevölkerung vor einem Atomkrieg. Und das ist so absurd, weil diese Angst ja real ist. Und er beschreibt dann auch, dass tatsächlich beiden große Angst hatte, als tatsächlich die Erfolge der Ukraine im Krieg, im Herbst groß waren, des ersten Kriegsjahres, dass Putin quasi sich immer mehr an die Wand gedrückt fühlt, entscheidet jetzt strategisch, Nuklearwaffen einzusetzen. Dass da also die Angst nicht einfach nur bei Scholz im Kopf und in der angstdeutschen Bevölkerung war, sondern auch bei Joe Biden und sagt aber dann immer wieder, ja, da hat er auf die Umfragen geschieht oder sonst was. Und niemand kann mir ja in irgendeiner Weise auch in Robin Alexander mit all seinen Details nicht ausschließen, dass Putin doch auf Atomwaffen zurückgreift. Und er geht selbst immer wieder darauf ein, auf das, was dann Christian Trosten mal das Präventionsparadox so genannt hat. Also das ist nicht sein Begriff, aber das hat er ja immer wieder betont.
Und dieser Frank Sauer nicht verstanden hat mit seinem Atomwaffenwert nicht eingesetzt, also ist es ein Nichtereignis.
Ja, also er geht immer wieder auf dieses Präventionsparadox ein, in Bezug auf andere Dinge, aber nicht in Bezug auf die Sache, dass Scholz sagt, ich muss diesen Atomkrieg verhindern, das darf auf keinen Fall sein. Und da dann draus zu schließen, dass Scholz da nicht richtig reagiert hat oder nicht richtig bei der Sache war, zu sehr zögerte, ist einfach falsch.
Und das finde ich jetzt so witzig auch, amüsant, wenn man nämlich, und es ist ja eine sehr große, ich habe einen roten Faden, ich habe alles reportiert, jetzt fasse ich es für euch nochmal zusammen, das ist mein Angebot, ich bin Robin Alexander, euer oberster Erzähler und dann sagst du, so werden wir das Buch besprechen, ja wir springen jetzt mal so ein bisschen und ich denke mir so, ja, das muss man gar nicht so entschuldigt sagen, weil was macht denn Robin Alexander hier? Es geht total sprunghaft, einfach wird so ein Narrativ durchgeprügelt, hier zum Beispiel, linker und rechter Rand, für ihn ist grundsätzlich im Plural politische Ränder. Es gibt nicht den rechten und den linken, es gibt politische Ränder, warum? Na weil die Mitte doch eine Zweidrittelmehrheit braucht, um Deutschland zu organisieren, weil Grundgesetz, Verfassung und so weiter.
Und die Mitte ist immer gut.
Genau. Die Mitte ist immer gut. Diese Zweidrittelmehrheit sollte man am besten haben. Jetzt ist sie aber weg. Und anstatt jetzt einfach, was machen denn die Linken da? Ach ja, die machen so Angebote an und so weiter und so fort. Wird jetzt einfach erinnert an die Spätphase der Weimarer Republik. So steht es dann im Text. Denn die Nationalsozialisten und die Kommunisten haben im Reichstag über 50 Prozent und verhindern damit, dass Sozialdemokraten, Liberale und Vorläufer der Christdemokratie vernünftig Politik machen. Und es wird uns einfach untergejubelt als, so ist das heute. Das ist unsere Erklärungsfolie.
Friedrich Merz ist ja Vernünftige, die anderen sind die Unvernünftigen.
Das droht ja schon wieder großer Krieg, weil die Kommunisten irgendwie da und so weiter die 50 Prozent mehr hätten und mitorganisieren. Das erinnert an, also ich finde, wenn sich niemand mehr lebendig daran erinnern kann, darf man diesen Satz so nicht schreiben. Weil niemand erinnert sich daran. Diese historische Aufarbeitung und Erinnerung ist Arbeit, die muss man dann auch entsprechend thematisieren. Aber nein, man erinnert sich so dran, blende dann so ein bisschen aus, ja, also die Kommunisten und die Nationalsozialisten haben die damals so zusammen die Mitte zerschlagen oder wie waren das? Ich glaube, es war ein bisschen anders. Ich habe das gar nicht im Hinterkopf so, ja. Also da wird die Erinnerung so ein bisschen schwammig gehalten. Und so ist einfach, ja und dann Schuldenbremse. Nächstes Kapitel ist jetzt Schuldenbremse, weil da brauchen wir ja die Zweidrittelmehrheit. Wird einfach assoziativ so die Weimarer Republik jetzt drangebaut. Und dann Zeitungswissen, Kehrtwende bei der Schuldenbremse, denn es gibt ein Dokument, ihr Enzylikum, Moritz Schulerring, Michael Hüther, Clemens Füß schließen sich zusammen. Da hätte ich mir ja gewünscht, dass da einfach ein Text mal drinsteht. Ja warum auch nicht. Also wenn es so offenbar ist, dass wirklich jede Schule vom Einsturz bedroht ist, klar schließen sich dann mal die Ökonomen zusammen und machen so einen gemeinsamen Vorschlag. Springt da irgendwer über seinen Schatten? Nee, ich glaube nicht. Denn sobald einer sagt, hier ist ein 600 Milliarden Investitionsdefizit und sagen ja wohl alle bei Verstand, stimmt. Und dann wird politisch diskutiert.
Ja, aber also kein Wort auch da. Das ist ja das, was du so stark machen wolltest bei Hart aber fair. Kein Wort zu der ausgestreckten Hand von Scholz. Nachdem, an dem Tag, an dem er Lindner entlässt, hält er diese Rede, redet er erst darüber, wie Lindner so drauf ist und sagt dann, aber wir können jetzt gemeinsam, und er sagt eigentlich da der Union, wir könnten jetzt mal die Dinge hier klären. Wir haben jetzt den Austeritätspolitiker nicht mehr drin. Wir könnten jetzt vernünftig gemeinsam was machen. Das könnte man ja mal würdigen, dass aber Merz hier die ganze Zeit nur auf Kalkül fährt und sagt, ne, also eher geht das Land den Bach runter, dass ich mit der SPD jetzt noch mal was zusammen mache. Ich meine, sie haben mal ein Treffen gehabt, das wird ja auch da reportiert.
Ja, und das, hier kommt halt jetzt diese journalistische Perfidie durch, die ich gar nicht anders klassifizieren kann. Ich habe in der Kinderwüste auch zweimal aus dieser Rede von Scholz, wie er die sprengt, zitiert, weil es einfach so wichtig ist. Was macht Robin Alexander daraus? Scholz hat ja irgendwas gesagt, keine Ahnung, Brotlaut ist egal, so. Also selbst der dann ja wirklich hoch dramatische, wie er da immer wieder mit dem gleichen Satz beginnt, zu oft, zu oft, zu oft hat Lindner und so weiter und so fort, findet hier gar nicht statt, nicht von Bedeutung. Stattdessen März plante mit den Ministerpräsidenten eine Lockerung der Schuldenbremse, weil die sind ja immer noch an diesem 0,0% und so, aber Kai Wegner plaudert aus. Also lässt März den Plan fallen, denn er hatte zwar einen schön großen Plan, aber es ist doch voll blöd, wenn das Verhandlungsergebnis, das er erreichen möchte, vorerst schon in der Zeitung steht, da macht es doch gar keinen Sinn mit Scholz zu reden. Und ich denke mir so, nee.
Das soll jetzt die Begründung für alles sein.
Was ist das für ein absurder Scheiß? Wenn du willst, dass die Länder die Schuldenbremse ein bisschen gelockert kriegen, dann sag das öffentlich und sage, darüber müssen wir halt mal Mehrheiten herstellen. Und nicht, oh nee, jetzt ist das schon bekannt.
Und dann kann man die Details...
Dass ich hier abdrücke von meinem superharten Kurs und das ist ja blöd. Ich will ja jetzt nicht als...
Aber das wird alles entschuldigt. Also das ist wirklich eine Hagiografie für Friedrich Merz.
Vielmehr habe er dem Bundeskanzler ein Angebot machen wollen, prinzipiell über die Schuldenbremse zu reden. Aber wir sind so dankbar, Friedrich Merz, dass du das wolltest. Und dann ist dir Kai Wegner. Du saßt plötzlich in der Falle der öffentlichen…
Konnte er nicht mehr umhinden.
Da ist wirklich dann die Frage, wie ist denn die Bild damit umgegangen, dass plötzlich Kai Wegner so sagt, der Schuldenbremse ist vielleicht nicht ganz so cool. Und wenn man da natürlich gleich reingeht mit, jetzt bröckelt Merz Nimbus. Der harte Typ hat wahrscheinlich seine eigenen Leute nicht im Griff. Aber solche Reflexionen finden gar nicht statt, wie das journalistisch begleitet wurde.
Kommen wir zu dem schon angesprochenen Blutbad.
Ja, wir haben auch noch den Wahlabend hier. Merz ist einfach immer erschüttert. Ja, immer erschüttert. Die Lage des Bundeshaushalts ganz erschüttert.
Kassensturz.
Briefing von Cookies, genau diesen Kassensturz. Ganz erschüttert. Und dann immer dieses, erzählte er Teilnehmern anschließend und so weiter. Ganz erschüttert.
Und wir kennen ja alle genau diesen Ton. Das darf doch nicht wahr sein. Da sage ich ihnen aber ganz ehrlich, das ist ja immer dieser Merz-Ton. Also dieses erschütternd erpöhrt sein, das ist bei Friedrich Merz ja immer drin. Also das hätte ich mir nicht träumen lassen.
So, aber dieses Briefing, das da stattfindet, ist halt auch für Spanien ganz entscheidend, weil da kann er plötzlich zeigen, er hat voll die Expertise, weshalb uns Robin Alexander nochmal erklären muss, ich meine, wir wissen alle, wer hier in Spanien ist.
Er sagt ja, dass Spanien es schaffe, sich unentbehrlich zu machen, wegen seiner Expertise.
Merz riskiert freilich viel, indem er einen so ambitionierten Mann wie Span in dieser Schlüsselposition duldet, also dann später Fraktionsvorsitzender, aber für die CDU wäre es langfristig vielleicht noch riskanter, unabhängige Köpfe nicht in die Führung einzubinden. Also wenn ich solche Normalisierung von Jens Spahn, er ist wirklich unentbehrlich und so weiter.
Unentbehrlich, unabhängiger Köpfe.
Ich möchte dir die Gegenerzählung. Jens Spahn ist das Beste, was die CDU aufzubieten hat, der Einzige mit Regierungserfahrung. Ansonsten blank. Ja, diese Geschichte möchte ich hören.
Ja und er ist mit allen vernetzt und weiß sehr viel über sehr viele.
Fährt dazu nur eine Puppe, keine Partei.
Damit ist das dann zu sagen, ja. Also ich meine, da könnte man auch ein tolles Enthüllungsbuch schreiben, da könnte man auch mal in Chatverläufe und sowas gehen. Das wird natürlich bei Springer nicht gemacht.
Vor dem Blutbad, lasst uns noch, also Trump verlässt vielleicht die NATO und so. Er kann nicht da ordentlich schlafen, das bringt ihn durch die Nacht. Und dann kommt ja davor schon dieser kleine März fremdelt mit den Grünen. Was bedeutet, er ignoriert sie einfach. Wo ich mir denke, Robin Alexander, du hast uns doch gerade noch mal erklärt, wie hat Helmut Kohl das gemacht, wie hat Merkel das gemacht. Merkel hat ja irgendwie, ah Esken ist jetzt SPD-Chefin, ich lade sie erstmal zum Tee. Und dann sitzen die beiden Frauen da und reden über Männer in der Politik oder was auch immer. Alle wissen, die verstehen sich nicht, was auch immer. Und uns wird dann aber einfach gesagt, ja, das war halt die gute Schule der anderen März, ist halt so anders, ist aber auch kein Problem, der hat die einfach ignoriert. Ich denke mir so, wie der die einfach ignoriert. Klar macht da jede Fraktion ihren eigenen Kram und so, aber wie kann man uns das einfach verkaufen, dass er da so ein bisschen, ja, muss man halt verstehen so. Der hat keine Lust auf Leute, die ihm seine heilige Zweidrittelmehrheit organisieren sollen. Also es ist wirklich, und so geht es im Grunde die ganze Zeit. Okay, das Blutbad, lasst uns mal hier einsteigen, wo er eigentlich noch dieses Briefing bekommt.
Von der Allensbach-Chefin.
Ja, und von, also der Michael, Matthias Jung hat ja vorher immer Merkel beraten und so. Und er war immer, also der ist ja dann auch berühmt geworden durch dieses, es fand wieder eine Bundestagswahl statt. Und Matthias Jung hat der Merkel-CDU erklärt, dass die größte Wählerwanderung von CDU-Wählerschaft in den Tod stattfindet. Und nicht etwa zu anderen Parteien und so. Also diese kleinen Voranden. Genau, und dann hat er ja da so seine eigene Renate Köcher.
Die ist beim Allensbach-Institut. Früher hat sich ja schon Kohl von Leneumann beraten lassen. Also setzt man auf Allensbach und die hat herausgefunden und ich glaube, sie hat recht, dass wann immer die CDU das Thema Migration ganz groß macht, das dazu führt, dass die Leute zur AfD gehen. Denn wir haben auch immer gesagt, wenn man sagt, das ist unser größtes Problem, dann wählt man das Original. Warum auch nicht? Also jetzt aus der Logik heraus muss man ja sagen, ja dann klar, dann wähle ich ja jetzt nicht Merz.
Merz-Teno ist die ganze Zeit, ja eigentlich hat die AfD ja recht. Ja. Klar, dann das Original.
Dann sagt man, okay. So und deshalb rät sie, Wirtschaftswahlkampf zu machen und das nicht als so ein großes Thema zu machen. Und dann kommt es aber erst zu Magdeburg. Und jetzt, um in dieser Erzählung von Robin Alexander zu bleiben, Merz hält sich daran, was die Allensbach-Chefin sagt. Ich würde sagen, nee, wirtschaftspolitisch hatte die CDU nichts anzubieten gehabt, musste also schon die ganze Zeit auf diese Migrationsthema rumreiten.
Blöd, wenn da so ein Buch drin steht.
Ja und medial wurde das ja auch genauso unterstützt, dass das stattfindet. Also ich finde auch hier ja interessant, wir haben es hier mit einem Journalisten für Springer zu tun, der hätte auch sagen können, na ja, wir haben ja das Thema so groß gesetzt, haben jeden Tag in Welt und Bild darüber berichtet, haben einen Chefredakteur Ulf Poschert, der jeden Tag live im Fernsehen sitzt und sagt, dass man draußen seine Kinder nicht mehr auf die Straße schicken kann.
Was soll ich mehr zu machen?
Das würde man sich nicht mehr trauen. Das produziert natürlich auch ganz viel und dann kommen noch die Anschläge dazu. Aber wir haben ja schon die ganze Zeit eine solche Politik, die auch einen Scholz dann schon früher dazu getrieben hatte, im Spiegel zu sagen, wir müssen im großen Stil abschieben und so. Also hier wird immer noch so getan, als hätte jetzt Friedrich Merz diesen Wirtschaftswahlkampf eigentlich machen wollen.
Genau, also ihre Empfehlung ist ja ganz präzise. Also, wenn sich die Parteien der Mitte über Grenzschließung, Zurückweisung und Abschiebung stritten, würde stets die Umfrage der AfD steigen. So weit, so gut. Weißt Köcker nach, Köcher nach. Dann, wenn sich das Thema illegale Migration gar nicht vermeiden ließe, sollten sich Unionspolitiker dabei auf die sicherheitspolitischen Aspekte konzentrieren. Auf diesem Feld gäbe es für die Union noch eine Kompetenzvermutung, wie Demoskopen das nennen. Also, uns wird ja auch immer vorgeworfen, dass wir bei Migration so feuerfrei, grenzooffen wie auch immer. Das ist ja gar nicht so. Nur, es gibt halt keine Maßstäbe, auf die sich alle mal geeinigt haben. Und zwar nirgendwo. Das sehen wir ja vor allem jetzt gerade in Amerika, wo man einfach die einfängt, mit denen man am einfachsten habhaft wird, weil man sie auf der Arbeitsstelle findet. Und dann später gibt es einen Diskurs zum Thema, ja, das hat jetzt sicherheitspolitisch gar keine Bewandtnis. Das ist zwar Migrationspolitik, aber mit Sicherheitspolitik hat das nichts zu tun. Nur, Sicherheitspolitik ist halt anstrengend und die kann man auch nicht so in der Öffentlichkeit austragen.
Die ist kleinteilig und ist quasi eins zu eins.
Genau. Und dass dann einfach Robin Alexander später im Text sagt, naja, dass Aschaffenburg in Bayern liegt, dass in Bayern Söder zuständig ist und dass der Typ auch behördlich bekannt war. Also Behördenversagen macht sich jetzt nicht so gut in öffentlichen Darstellungen. Deswegen wird es einfach ausgespart. Stattdessen Vorschlaghammer. Obwohl die Köcher das sagen. Nein, wenn du Vorschlaghammer machst, ist das gut für die AfD. Du musst jetzt zeigen, dass du eine sicherheitspolitische Kompetenz hast. Aber findet ja gar nicht statt. Und das wird auch von Robin Alexander gar nicht thematisiert. Sondern das ist einfach, ist halt so. März war halt mal wieder überrascht und emotional ergriffen.
Ja, wir sehen das ja auch bei diesen Grenzkontrollen. Ich habe es ja geschildert da, als ich von Luxemburg kam. Ja, auf dieser Hauptstraße stehen die dann. Und da sind natürlich nur irgendwelche Luxemburger, die in Trier arbeiten oder umgekehrt. Oder ich, der ein Konzert besucht. Und wenn ich jetzt illegaler Migrant wäre, der versuchen würde, nach Deutschland reinzukommen, über die luxemburgische Grenze, würde ich ja vermutlich nicht mit dem Auto über die Autobahn fahren, oder?
Bei uns vor dem Vereinshaus steht seit zwei Tagen ein Auto mit eingeschlagenem Fenster. Polizei wurde jetzt dreimal angerufen. Wir haben zu wenig Personal. Wir können gerade für solche Fälle niemanden schicken. Das sind doch die Themen.
Ja, also ich meine, das wäre genau so. Wir haben ja immer wieder durch Facebook-Aktivisten, vor allem kriege ich es dann auch mit, wenn es um häusliche Gewalt und Femizide und sowas geht. Und dann sehen wir auch, dass da ganz viel Behördenversagen auch mit einhergeht, weil es oft nicht die eine Tat ist, sondern dass davor schon ganz viel passiert ist. Ganz viele Hinweise, ganz viele Dinge, wo man sagen muss, man hätte die Frauen daraus befreien müssen früher, hätte denen ökonomische Möglichkeiten geboten. Das wäre aber jetzt so, wenn ich sage, wir haben Femizid. Ich habe mir überlegt, jetzt bekommen einfach alle Männer eine Fußfessel oder so. Würde man genau sagen, ja, tickst du noch ganz richtig. Du kannst auch das nicht jetzt daraus ableiten. So und genau das passiert jetzt aber hier. Und Friedrich Merz bekommt Magdeburg mit, läuft dann da herum, sieht Magdeburg auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt, wie da noch Blutspuren sind. Natürlich ist das auch eine emotionale Situation. Das will ich ja gar nicht leugnen. Dann kommt Aschaffenburg. Er bekommt das nochmal von der Lindholz geschildert, wie das Sohn etwa sich da verhalten hat. Und Merz sagt jetzt, es reicht. Diese Erzählung muss man jetzt erstmal gar nicht mitgehen. Interessant ist aber jetzt, dass sich natürlich die Antimikrationspolitik der CDU dann erheblich noch zuspitzt. Sie war vorher schon da, so meine These, spitzt sich dann aber so zu. Jetzt kommt wieder Jens Spahn mit ins Spiel, Linnemann und weitere. Die wollten nämlich immer noch viel stärker darauf gehen und schmieden jetzt diesen Plan. Ja, komm, der soll jetzt so einen Fünfte-Plan machen und so. Man ist nämlich eigentlich ziemlich planlos in der ganzen Gemengelage. Und dann geht das ja so weiter, dass Friedrich Merz aus diesen emotionalen Berichten heraus und daraus, dass Scholz diese kommunikative Lücke angeblich lässt, sagt, ich habe hier den Plan, das und das ist zu tun. Und wir wissen, sicherheitspolitisch ist da wenig Sinnvolles dabei. Manche Ministerpräsidenten aus den eigenen Reihen sagen auch, hör mal, wenn wir das so machen, das geht nicht. Also er will zum Beispiel innerhalb von Gefängnissen noch mal irgendwelche Einzäunungen vornehmen, wo dann illegale Asylbewerber oder so untergebracht werden. Und da sagen die auch, nee, so raten wir sehr von ab. Das geht nicht und das ist auch gesetzlich nicht möglich. Na ja, dann lässt er sich da immer wieder dazu hinreißen, da noch mal was zu modifizieren. Er verkündet aber öffentlich dann, mir ist völlig gleichgültig, wer diesen Weg mit mir geht.
Lass uns das mal Schritt für Schritt machen. Also Affenkantung. Genau, und es beginnt ja hier in Magdeburg. Also es ist dieser Terror in Magdeburg. Über die Weihnachtsfeiertage kommt Merz doch noch ins Grübeln. Ob er noch diesen alten, wir machen hier Sicherheitspolitik, die Köcher hat gesagt und so weiter, sonst laufen wir in die Falle der AfD. Die Bilder aus Magdeburg haben sich in ihm eingebrannt. Da würde ich ja sagen, komm, hier muss jetzt ein Buch darüber geschrieben werden, wie wir hier gerade abdriften. Wie wir es nicht geschafft haben, einen Kanzlerkandidaten in dem Fall aufzustellen, der es bewältigen kann. Der eine dritte Partei, die mitentscheidet, akzeptiert, statt einfach Impulskontrolle gestört, ich mache es fast in Selbstjustiz selbst. Und es läuft eben nicht wirklich auf Selbstjustiz hinaus am Ende. Also klingt das ein bisschen überhochtrabend, aber die Argumentation geht hier wie folgt. Also er denkt an die Attentate der vergangenen Jahre zurück. Immer kürzere Abfolgen, Mannheim. Der Polizist Rufen Lauer wird erstochen. Ein persönlicher Bekannter von Moritz Oppelt, dem örtlichen CDU-Bundestagsabgeordneten, März überredet ihn. Halt doch eine Rede im Bundestag. Die ist natürlich emotional. Wer hätte es gedacht, wie Robin Alexander zu berichten weiß? Er zitiert, also aus dem Bundestag. Es ist an der Zeit, dass wir in Berlin Verantwortung übernehmen, Verantwortung für die Zustände in unserem Land, insbesondere in unseren Großstädten, in die wir unsere Polizisten Tag für Tag schicken. Da würde ich sagen, bisher auf Track. Da bin ich total dafür. Aber wir schulden es ihnen, dass wir jetzt entschlossen handeln, dass wir unsere Migrationspolitik den tatsächlichen Aufnahmekapazitäten in unserem Land anpassen. Das hat doch gar nichts damit zu tun. Also es wird einfach so, er hätte jetzt auch genauso gut über die Milchmarkt reden können. Also einfach ist es so reingestreut.
Ja, das ist ja nur so statistisch. Weniger Leute, weniger statistische Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass diese was anstellen.
Genau. Merz redet dann selber im Parlament, nachdem Bad Oeynhausen war. Wohin entwickelt sich unser Land? Und wie lange hält unsere Gesellschaft die seit Jahren ungesteuerte Migration noch aus? Also da ist wieder eins plus eins ist gleich irgendetwas. Wenn nicht bald etwas geschehe, Zitat, zerstört das die Grundlage unseres gedeihlichen Zusammenlebens. Frag ich mich, was ist denn das gedeihliche an unserem Zusammenleben, wenn wir der sanktionsfreie in der Bundespressekonferenz hören und so, oder eben was in Familien so angeweiltlos ist. Frank-Walter Steinmeier mischt sich ein. Die Begrenzung der Migration ist die zentrale Aufgabe der nächsten Jahre. So und dann schwenkt Robin Alexander um auf den Chef der Bundespolizei, Roman, der schon 2015 Chef war, an der Grenze damals in der Flüchtlingskrise vergeblich sich dafür, so schreibt er, er hat sich vergeblich dafür eingesetzt, Klammer auf, was ja voll richtig ist, Zurückweisung. Auch wenn jemand Asyl sagt. Diese fünf Worte, auch im Falle eines Asylgesuches, musste er damals wieder streichen. Bei Merkel hat er den Schuss nicht gehört. Da läuft der Text die ganze Zeit. Wir hatten damals nicht nur Merkel, sondern auch Thomas de Maizière als Innenminister, also einen Juristen, der weiß, weder ich als Innenminister noch die Kanzlerin kann das hier entscheiden. Das ist vorgegeben Gesetze und Grundgesetz. Jetzt wird uns rein normalisiert, dass wir endlich einen Kanzler haben, in dem Fall noch ein Kanzlerkandidat, aber jetzt einen Kanzler zur Publikation des Buches, der endlich, ja was denn eigentlich, wie Trump sagt, ey, Verfassung, ich muss dann mal gucken, ob ich mich daran halte.
Ja, denn wir erfahren ja, später werden parteiinterne Kritiker der neuen harten Migrationspolitik behaupten, Merz sei in diesen Tagen gezielt emotionalisiert worden. Westfalen seien nun einmal sentimentale Eichen, zitierte eine Politiker eine Passage aus Heinrich Heines Wintermärchen. Jeder in der Union wisse, dass der Westfale Friedrich Merz hinter einer harten Schale einen besonders weichen Kern verberge. Das hätten sich die Befürworter einer schärferen Flüchtlingspolitik nach Aschaffenburg zu Nutze gemacht. Vor allem Alexander Dobrindt habe dafür gesorgt, dass Merz durch immer detailliertere Schilderungen der Bluttat, durch seine Parteifreunde Lindholz aufgewühlt bleibe. Und da denke ich mir, gut, wenn das jetzt so sein sollte, ja, dann Gnade uns Gott.
Ich will es mal...
Vor allen Dingen, ich kann ja auch mal ganz, also wenn ich sentimental werden will, muss ich mir nur den Bericht von Helena Steinhaus mal ansehen. Und wenn ich die ganze Zeit über das Wohl der Kinder rede. Also Kinder interessieren ja auch immer diese konservativen Politiker nur dann, wenn man sie vor Mord und Totschlag nachträglich beschützen will. Aber sonst interessieren die ja gar nicht.
Genau. Also Merz hat diese Köcher im Hintergrund, die ihm Zahlen, Daten faktenmäßig sagt, das wäre eine erfolgreiche Einflugsschneise für dich. Du willst ja 40 Prozent und die AfD halbieren. Wir haben heute gesehen, das hat nicht funktioniert. Warum nicht? Also frei Linnemann, Dobrindt, Spahn, du hast ja genannt, machen diese Viererrunde, die ihn da überzeugen möchte, dass die gescheiterte Migrationspolitik zu den immer neuen Attentaten führt, also dein direkter Zusammenhang ist. Und später im Textverlauf schreibt Robin Alexander darüber, dass Dobrindts Idee ist, die Richtlinienkompetenz des Bundeskanzlers medial zu verarbeiten, wie eine Executive Order des amerikanischen Präsidenten.
Das ist interessant.
Denn, das jetzt Zitat Robin Alexander, Dobrindt glaubt, diese Bilder mit Trump und den großen Stiften hätten auf die deutschen Zuschauer eine faszinierende Anziehungskraft. Und da würde ich auch wieder sagen wie du, wenn das so stimmt, dann Gnade uns Gott. Das geht nicht.
Also wenn ich, ich denke jetzt gerade so, wenn du das jetzt so als Soldat liest und dann denkst du so, okay, also wenn denen da eine Sicherung durchspringt, dann werde ich morgen irgendwo hingeschickt.
Dann war es das mit der freiheitlich-demokratischen Grundordnung. Da musstest du immer drauf eingeschoren und jeden Tag daran erinnern.
Ich meine, Alexander gibt sich Mühe, uns Friedrich Merz ein tolles Licht zurück, nee. Also ich würde sagen, das macht wirklich Angst.
Mit so ein bisschen eingeschaltetem Kopf denkt man hier so, nee, es ist nicht gesund, was hier abläuft. Na ja, genau. Und dann kommt Aschaffenburg, diese detaillierten Briefings, wie die Terrorablaufen. Ich finde es sehr bezeichnend, dass Robin Alexander bei der Entscheidung, was lese ich bei der ersten Podcast-Lesung aus meinem Buch vor, genau das, was März auch so beeindruckt hat, damit wir mal fühlen, wie März beeindruckt war, weil es uns auch beeindruckt.
Die sollen auch mal emotionalisiert werden, dass wir verstehen, ja genau, dann hätten wir auch gesagt, alle Grenzen dicht.
Ja. Und dann kommt eben dieser Fünf-Punkte-Plan, den du ja eben schon angeschnitten hast. Ich habe Folgendes vor, das ist mein Fünf-Punkte-Plan. Und ganz interessant ist ja, dass Robin Alexander selbst hier kurz schreibt, die Worte sind irgendwie angekommen und alle sind bestürzt. Und eigentlich war Merz, der sich entschieden hatte, diese Pressekonferenz im Reichstag zu halten, nur nicht nur in der CDU, schon, er hätte einfach dann gehen können nach der Ansage, aber er beantwortet plötzlich noch Fragen. Und Robin Alexander schreibt hier auch, da ist er mal besonders kritisch. Also er liefert gerade sein Statement und dann in diesem Hochgefühl macht er einen Fehler. Er bleibt stehen. März verharrt im Scheinwerferlicht der Kameras, denn er ist ja gerade ergriffen von seinen eigenen Worten und so. Und dann bekommt er so Fragen, ja wie weit würden sie es denn darauf anlegen? Und dann kommt sein, mir ist völlig gleichgültig, wer diesen Weg politisch mitgeht. Ich sage nur, ich gehe keinen anderen und wer ihnen mit mir gehen will, muss sich nach diesen fünf Punkten richten. Kompromisse sind zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht mehr möglich. Das ist eine spontane Worteußerung. Die CDUler hören das auch. Und es macht sich so jeder seinen eigenen Reim drauf.
Also spontan wird die Brandmauer eingerissen, weil er einfach noch ein bisschen da steht und sagt so ein, zwei Fragen.
Genau, aber dass die Brandmauer eingerissen wird, da passieren ja noch drei, vier Fehler.
Ja, ja, es geht ja noch weiter.
Sondern wir haben hier einen Start in eine Situation, von der Robin Alexander meint, ich cleverer Journalist mache das mal so, ich stelle Merz als den Überrumpelten vor, weil in der emotionalen Ergriffenheit steckt ja eine Wahrheit, nämlich die für uns alle gilt. Merz handelt hier auch für uns. Er opfert sich für uns. Er trifft die schweren Entscheidungen für uns. Und dann lässt er das, setzt er erstmal in diesen zentralen archimädischen Punkt, um uns Merz zu verdeutlichen und kann dann selber nicht, umhin kurz zu markieren, ja, da sind schon ein paar Fehler passiert. Das müssen wir jetzt aber aushalten. Es ist halt Realität oder so, ja. Also es tut mir fast ein bisschen selber leid, dass selbst der kluge Robin Alexander, der versucht, uns das hier zusammenzubinden, trotzdem einsieht, ja, ein bisschen blöd ist schon. Und ich komme ja auch nicht umhin, ich muss hier sagen, Merz hat auch einen Fehler gemacht.
Ja.
Und das ist doch irgendwie.
Und dann wird uns das, im Prinzip, wir müssen uns ja ein bisschen sputen, damit wir nochmal durch dieses Buch durchkommen. Dann wird uns dann nochmal genau dargestellt, wie das dann war. Die AfD hat entsprechend clevere Leute in ihren Reihen, die wissen, was sie jetzt zu tun haben, wenn es da Möglichkeiten gibt. Doch selbst ein Antrag von der CDU, willst du das jetzt nochmal ganz detailliert machen?
Also ich will nur mal ver…
Ich meine, das ist das Problem, dieses Buch erzählt einfach nochmal die letzten vier Jahre.
Für mich ist das ja so der Höhepunkt des Buches, weil… Okay, für mich nicht. Ja, ich will es nur… Wir nutzen jetzt die Möglichkeit, das mal zu illustrieren. Merz fühlt sich von den Reaktionen aus der CDU in seinem Kurs ermutigt. Also er fühlt eine Reaktion auf seine drei Minuten Ansage zum Fünf-Punkte-Plan. Ich glaube, das hat gesessen heute Morgen. Das musste auch sitzen. Wenn wir es gut machen, ist das das Momentum des Wahlkampfes, wo es für uns nach oben geht. Es kann natürlich auch kippen, wenn wir jetzt Fehler machen. Das sagt er ausdrücklich, wenn wir jetzt Fehler machen. Und was passiert? Die machen diesen Entschließungsantrag und übersehen, Thorsten Frei übersieht, dass es nicht zwei Lesungen gibt, sondern dass der direkt nach der ersten Lesung zur Abstimmung steht. Man kann ihn also nicht, nachdem man ihn thematisiert, im Bundestag noch mal rausnehmen, sondern nein, danach ist sofort offen für die AfD, einfach mitzumachen und nachher Mehrheit herzustellen. Das haben die einfach übersehen. Merz hat am Morgen noch gesagt, und ich finde es schon problematisch auf dem Ding, er wollte uns darstellen, wie emotional er ist, und dann kommt, also diese Robin Alexander-Thema von vorhin, kommt dieses, das ist unser Momentum, wir müssen es noch richtig nutzen, jetzt keine Fehler machen und drei Stunden später Fehler. Das ist doch grotesk.
Und bei der AfD sitzt noch mal bessere Strategien, die wissen nämlich, dass es schon so ein Gesetzentwurf der Union gibt, der schon mal im Bundestag da eingepackt wurde, und dann sagen sie, ja, dann bringen wir den jetzt wieder ein. Und dadurch muss die CDU ja dann auch darauf, sich wieder dazu wiederverhalten, muss den also dann selbst wieder einbringen, damit die AfD den nicht einbringen.
Also Merz sagt einfach wirklich, das wussten wir nicht, das haben wir gerade erst erfahren, dass auch andere Fraktionen unsere Anträge einbringen können. Und jetzt wissen wir nicht, ob wir der nein, das war ja unser Antrag. Also wir kriegen ja auch ein Dokument der Dummheit, das muss man echt sagen. Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm. Okay, was ist dir noch wichtig?
Würde ich gerne mal, weil jetzt ja hier die ganze Zeit diese These vertreten wird, Friedrich Merz ist der Mittelkanzler, der als unsere letzte Chance gilt, um die AfD abzuwehren mit Friedrich Merz. Das wird ja dann auch hier immer wieder zitiert, weil trotz dieser Abstimmung gibt es keine Zusammenarbeit. Aber hören wir uns jetzt mal einen Auszug an, der ist ein bisschen länger, aus einer Rede von Friedrich Merz beim Parteitag. Im Winter war das dann. Mich hat auf dieser Rede aufmerksam gemacht der Journalist Sebastian Friedrich. Und wir hören jetzt mal, wie bei Friedrich Merz da die Abgrenzung zur AfD erfolgt. Denn wir haben ja jetzt schon gesehen, okay, die AfD bringt schon CDU-Anträge ein und die CDU sagt, nee, das machen wir jetzt lieber. Aber dann könnt ihr auch mitstimmen. Wir hören mal rein.
Und ich kann den Wählerinnen und Wählern in Deutschland eines sehr klar und sehr deutlich versichern. Wir werden mit der Partei, die sich der Alternative für Deutschland nennt, nicht zusammenarbeiten. Vorher nicht, nachher nicht, niemals. Diese Partei steht für gegen alles. Diese Partei.
So, jetzt sehen wir hier die ganzen Wirtin, die sind ganz außer Sicht, stehen jetzt auf, applaudieren. Alle sind aus der Sicht, freuen sich. Ich denke ja immer, wenn man eine Selbstverständlichkeit ausdrückt, muss man ja nicht so sich feiern lassen. Also wenn ich jetzt hier sage, ich werde nicht die AfD wählen, dann springst du mir nicht um den Hals. Da wirst du sagen, ja klar, das würde uns auch so ein Grund machen.
Dann bin ich eigentlich ausgehakt, Wolfgang, verdächtig.
Aber hier großer Applaus.
Liebe Freunde, diese Partei steht.
Ja, viel mehr, 2025 sehen wir hier Plakate.
Diese Partei steht gegen alles, was unsere Partei und unser Land in den letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten in Deutschland aufgebaut hat.
So, die Partei steht gegen alles. Also die AfD. Aber gegen was steht die denn eigentlich? Und jetzt kommen interessante Punkte, die ja oft zählt.
Sie steht gegen die Westbindung.
Sie steht gegen die Westbindung. Sehen wir jetzt gerade bei der AfD was? Naja, nicht eine Ablösung von der Westbindung, sondern die sagen ja, grüß den auf und Trump ist jetzt toll. Endlich können wir mit den Amerikanern wieder zusammenarbeiten.
Gegen den Euro.
Gegen den Euro. Seit wann steht die? Das war mal. Wir wollen die D-Mark wieder haben oder so. Und ja, man findet in dem Wahlprogramm auch noch mal so, wir müssten da eigentlich raus. Aber niemand verfolgt in der AfD irgendein solches Szenario. Das ist völlig passé. Das ist 2017 vielleicht.
Sie steht gegen die NATO.
Sie steht gegen die NATO. Steht die AfD noch gegen die NATO? Ich glaube nein. Selbst Maximilian Krah, der hat Goscubiszek angemerkt, kritisch, ist jetzt da umgelenkt.
Deshalb wollen wir gerade in diesem Wahlkampf alles tun, um diese Partei wieder so klein wie möglich zu machen. Es gibt keine Zusammenarbeit. Es gibt keine Duldung. Es gibt keine Minderheitsregierung. Sie ist der wichtigste Gegner für uns in diesem Wahlkampf. Wir wollen sie wieder klein machen. Sie wollen wir zu einer Randerscheinung machen, da, wo sie hingehört, liebe Freundinnen und Freunde. Und da gibt es kein Wenn und kein Aber. Gar nichts gibt es da, mit uns zusammen zu machen. Gar nichts.
Ja, und da fragt man sich ja, es sei denn, die AfD will im Euro bleiben, in der NATO bleiben und die Westbindung nicht aufgeben.
Und hat was gegen Migranten. Da ist man natürlich, ja, das ist wie vorhin schon angemerkt.
Er könnte ja sagen, das ist eine menschenfeindliche Partei. Das ist eine Partei, die Antisemiten hat. Das ist eine Partei, die die Menschenwürde verletzt. Wir haben zwar auch immer wieder darauf hingewiesen, wir haben Sicherheitsprobleme in Bezug auf Migration. Aber wir sind nicht grundsätzlich gegen Fremde. Wir sind nicht gegen Migranten. Das könnte er alles sagen. Und deswegen sind das für uns rote Linien. Nee, er wählt drei Punkte aus. Und alle drei sind bei der AfD längst abgeräumt.
Na ja, Carsten Linnemann sagt auch hier in der Neuen Westfälischen, in seiner Heimatzeitung, dass Nazi-Bashing und das Brandmauer-Gerede müssen aufhören. Während gerade Zustrombegrenzungsgesetz und dieser Entschluss da. Es ist wirklich brutal. Ich habe dieses Zitat gefunden beim Zustrombegrenzungsgesetz. Also unser Experte Friedrich Merz, Verwaltungschef, Bundesregierung, sagt, das haben wir erst gestern herausgefunden, dass es auch möglich ist, von anderen Fraktionen das auf die Tagesordnung zu setzen. Also ihr eigenes Gesetz, mit dem sie dann die noch Ampel ärgern wollen.
Ja, springen wir ein bisschen durch die Kapitel. Es geht dann um Demokratie im Krieg, um die Zeitenwende. Man muss das jetzt für die, die das nicht gelesen haben, erklären. Das war es jetzt erst mal zu Merz. 90, 95 Seiten sind rum. Und jetzt erzählt uns Robin Alexander nochmal haaklein, was alles bei der Ampel so los war.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden, warum.
Ja, damit das Buch 380 Seiten hat.
Kann man nicht einen Satz mal kurz?
Man will das erste Merz Buch schreiben. Aber da Friedrich Merz ja erst jetzt im Amt ist und man aber gerne jetzt schon liefern will, bevor noch fünf andere so ein Buch schreiben, muss man einfach jetzt sagen, ich fülle das auf, mit weiß ich nicht was.
Also wir hatten schon Kontakt mit solchen Büchern. Bob Woodward ist ja da ganz berühmt für, dass neue Buch kommt. Und dann irgend so ein in diesem Sicherheitsrat wurde mal das und das gesagt. Und das steht dann auf Seite 280. Und vorher wird einfach nochmal Chronologie, irgendwas.
Alles erzählt. Also Scholz hält die Zeiten, Wende, Rede und... Ja, der kann natürlich so ganz anschaulich schreiben. Das ist wie man so ein Krimi liest, wird das dann noch da erzählt. Wird nochmal darauf hingewiesen, Scholz hat diesen Begriff Zeitenwende schon in seinem Buch 2019 verwendet. Es ist so, dass Scholz eigentlich der ist, der schon vorher aufrüsten wollte, aber wusste, okay, das geht in der SPD nicht und eigentlich auch nicht so in der Bevölkerung. Also was wir hier immer wieder lesen, und da finde ich dann das doch ziemlich erhellend, die Aufrüstung an sich war schon viel länger geplant. Und das war jetzt nicht alles durch Putin. Aber Putin hat quasi so einen Effekt gegeben wie Aschaffenburg. Jetzt müssen wir aber. Finde ich interessant, dass wir also diese Bildung schon schon länger haben. Auch schon eine Woche vor der Invasion im Kanzleramt hat man mal durchrechend, wie man eigentlich so eine Aufrüstung finanzieren kann. Es gibt dann ein Non-Paper von der FDP, die das auch schon mal durchspielt. Ein Non-Paper ist, da ist kein Autor angegeben. Das ist einfach so, wir schreiben es mal auf. Jeder kann mal drauf gucken. Wenn man es nicht wollen, dann verschwindet es im Tisch. Aber niemand ist gescheitert mit irgendeiner Vision.
Wenn man es auf Zustimmung stößt, kann man es dem Finanzminister zurückschicken. Und dann macht er auch seinen Briefkopf. Genau.
Ja. Und da heißt es dann schon, ich kaufe dieses Modell. Eigentlich, so war mal im Koalitionsvertrag angedacht, sollte jeder zusätzliche Euro für Aufrüstung auch zusätzlich ins Entwicklungsministerium fließen. Da könnte man sagen, Stichwort für feministische Außenpolitik. Aber das macht man dann nicht. Nämlich, als man dann große Aufrüstung sagt, also jetzt dann so das Entwicklungsministerium, dann nicht, dass am Ende noch Menschen geholfen wird damit. Dann sagt man, also das soll dann lieber ganz in die Aufrüstung werden. Merz ist dann auch ganz ergriffen davon, dass Scholz so beherzt dazugreift und ist dann auch dabei. Er steht ja dann auch auf, applaudiert. Also es wird alles nochmal klein erzählt. Und jetzt so ein schönes Detail von Robin Alexander hier nochmal aufgespießt. Merz ist bei dieser Zeitenwende- Rede ganz vom historischen Moment ergriffen. Also immer wieder Emotionen. Dieser 24. September 2022, sagt er, wird uns allen als ein Tag im Gedächtnis bleiben, von dem wir später einmal sagen werden, ich weiß noch genau, wo ich war, als ich die erste Nachricht vom Krieg in der Ukraine gehört und die ersten Bilder gesehen habe. Merz, meint selbstverständlich den 24. Februar 2022, er hat sich versprochen. Er dachte wohl an den 11. September 2001, als die USA in New York und Washington von Terroristen angegriffen worden waren. An diesem Tag vor über 20 Jahren war Merz ebenfalls Oppositionsführer und auch damals stützte er einen sozialdemokratischen Kanzler, Gerhard Schröder, der sich zur uneingeschränkten Solidarität mit den USA bekannt hatte. Das war ein Wendepunkt im Verhältnis der beiden Männer. Von da an lud Schröder Merz regelmäßig im Kanzleramt ein und besprach mit ihm, manchmal bei reichlich Rotwein, die Leitlinien seiner Politik. Zwischen dem Kanzler und dem Oppositionsführer war damals ein Vertrauensverhältnis entstanden. Das entsteht aber dann nicht zwischen Scholz und Merz auf Dauer.
Apropos Vertrauensverhältnis, also nicht nur, dass ihr Sprechfehler September Monate verwechseln und so, sondern im Textverlauf, da weiß man gar nicht, wie es dazu kommt, im Zurück im Sauerland berichtet Merz seiner Frau Charlotte von diesem außergewöhnlichen Tag der Zeitenwende Rede und sagt, ich habe heute zum zweiten Mal eine historische Rede eines Bundeskanzlers gehört und wieder hat sie ein Sozialdemokrat gehalten. Da frage ich mich so ein bisschen, also wenn der Ehemann Merz nach Hause im Sauerland mit seiner Frau redet, warum weiß Robin Alexander, wie das Zitat lautet, das dann hier im Buch steht. Hat er mit Charlotte geredet?
Oder Friedrich Merz hat gesagt, ich habe gestern noch zu meiner Frau gesagt, wie da hat ein sozialdemokratischer Kanzler irgendwie sowas. Aber es wird natürlich so eine wahnsinnige Nähe suggeriert, als wäre da so eine ganze Zeit im Tarnumhang ein Robin Alexander in jedem Raum mit dabei.
Auch wenn das bin hier, Juso-Chefin Jessica Rosenthal kündigt sofort an, gegen das Sondervermögen stimmen zu wollen. Sie ist Parlamentsneuling und macht einen Anfängerfehler.
Naja, das ist nochmal so Details, die mir nicht so klar waren. Zelensky bei Merkel. Es gibt diese Zitterattacken 2019. Zelensky trifft dann schon Habeck. Und Zelensky sagt dann, Habeck wäre doch toll als neuer Kanzler. Er sieht sich da so als Young Leader mit Habeck und Macron zusammen. Deswegen diese Habeck-Zelensky-Verbindung ist von da an immer gegeben. Die schreiben sich da gegenseitig SMS. Man versucht noch vor dem Krieg Russlands, versucht man tatsächlich noch mal von Seiten der Union und der Grünen statt Steinmeier eine andere Kandidatin hervorzuzaubern für das Amt des Bundespräsidenten. Ich habe wirklich gedacht, ich kann es nicht fassen. Also man wollte die Grünen damit locken, dass es eine Grüne und eine Frau ist. Man hat tatsächlich Marie-Louise Beck vorgeschlagen. Also die vom Zentrum für Liberale Modelle. Ich würde mal sagen, dann kann man auch gleich sagen, gibt es einen Applebaum? Also ich bin völlig fassungslos. Und da hat aber dann Habeck wohl so im letzten Moment gesagt, nee, mache ich lieber doch nicht, damit wir jetzt nicht da in der Ampel Krach bekommen. Habeck ist auch der, der am stärksten für Waffentlieferungen ist. Baerbock ist da erst zögerlich, war mir auch nicht so klar.
Na ja, Habeck hatte ja damals diese Reisedienste.
Jaja, und den emotionalisiert, so wird das ja auch da wieder geschrieben. Also es geht immer über diese Emotionen. Ich dachte auch, als ich das wieder so las und auch dann über die anderen Politiker, die alle in der Ukraine waren, schreibt er auch nochmal, wie emotional das war, ich dachte ja immer, okay, Politiker sind ja zynische Menschen, die machen diese Bilder in der Ukraine, gucken da und wissen, das ist eine gute Bildpolitik, die funktioniert. Und sie selbst aber sind dann nicht so sehr befangen davon. Wenn ich jetzt Robin Alexander ernst nehme und ich bin geneigt, das zu tun, dann glaube ich, dass das wirklich was bewirkt. Also dass man die wirklich nur mal so denen was zeigen muss und sagen muss, seht hier, da fallen Bomben ab. Und dann sagen die, okay, liefert den Taurus. Also ich habe mich dann noch gefragt, ob man es nutzen kann. Also müsste man vielleicht einfach die jetzt, ja, muss man die jetzt her schleifen. Also muss man jetzt in die nächste kaputte Schule einfach den nächsten zur Verfügung stehenden Minister herholen. Guck mal da, guck mal da. Oder wir gehen jetzt mal durchs Bahnhofshörtel, guck mal, was da los ist. Oder hier an der Supermarktkasse, guck mal, die können sich das gar nicht leisten.
Ich bin ja sehr dafür, Beförderung und Bewirtung mal rauszunehmen.
Offenbar funktioniert das so. Also ich dachte immer, okay, das ist so eine Bildpolitik und so funktioniert halt der Laden. Aber nee, die scheinen wirklich, wenn man denen sagt, da ist ein Krieg, dann können die sich das noch nicht so vorstellen. Wenn die den aber so zwei Meter entfernt sehen, dann sagen die, ach so, ja nee, dann müssen wir natürlich.
Man kann nicht drauf vertrauen, dass da menschlich spekuliert wird. Die brauchen Anschauungsmaterial.
Ja, Robin Alexander bleibt natürlich ganz auf dieser Linie, die da alle vertreten, von Melanie Ahmann bis sonst wohin. Zögerlichkeit zahlt sich nicht aus. Beschreibt aber die ganze Zeit, wie gut da Biden und Scholz zusammengearbeitet haben. Und dass für Scholz klar ist, ich will nicht einen Alleingang für Deutschland machen, weil das möglicherweise für die Russen bedeuten könnte, okay, dann nehmen wir jetzt Deutschland als Ziel. Aber wenn das immer im Verbund mit den USA geschieht, dann wäre also jeder Angriff der Russen immer ein Angriff auf das gesamte NATO-Gebilde und nicht nur auf den deutschen Sonderweg. Und das will Russland nicht riskieren. Und deswegen versucht sich Scholz immer so, ganz gleichzeitig abzustimmen mit Biden. Da würde ich sagen, das scheint mir strategisch sehr sinnvoll zu sein.
Auf jeden Fall.
Die letzten Jahre geben ihm doch auch insofern recht, dass eben nicht eine Katastrophe passiert ist. Und Alexander schreibt dann, Scholz schürt die Angst, auf die Putin setzt. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, der setzt auf Angst, aber der kann einem ja auch wirklich Angst machen, weil das eine Nuklear macht.
Also diese Spinnerei, die dieses Buch durchzieht, ist wirklich ärgerlich. Ich finde es zum Beispiel auch in diesem Kapitel 12 Stresstest. Das ganze Buch sollte ja eigentlich so heißen. Da hätte ich auch gedacht, okay, das passt dann irgendwie, weil Letzte Chance hat so einen programmatischen Einschlag, der ja nicht drinsteckt. Aber ein Stresstest ist ja schon so, okay, wir dokumentieren mal, wie der Stresstest war. Einer dieser Stresstests, also im Plural nennen müssen, einer dieser Stresstests ist ja Heizungsgesetz. Also es passiert dieser Krieg und Habeck denkt so, ja, wir haben ja eh den Plan gehabt, das Heizen unabhängig zu machen von Öl- und Gaslieferungen aus Russland. Also mache ich das mal mit Wärmepumpen, weil die eine andere Energieversorgung haben. Dass man das überstürzen kann, schön und gut, dass da schon Pläne bereit lagen, interessant. Nur, wo kamen die Pläne her? Und dieser Ton, in dem hier darüber geschrieben wird, dass der Zuständige für Klimaschutz in Gebäuden Patrick Greichen ist, während vorher Habeck das Angebot bekommen hatte, von Clara Geivitz, Heizen doch mit ins Bauministerium zu nehmen. Er dann aber ablehnt, weil er sagt, nee, also Heizen ist ein ganz fundamentales Thema für Klimapolitik, kommt also ins Klimaministerium. Robin Alexander einfach sagt, ein folgenschwerer Fehler. Wo ich mir denke, nee, also wer Federführung bei Themen hat, ist wirklich ganz hart erkämpft. Und wenn das im Koalitionsvertrag drin steht, dann ist das besiegelt. Und wenn dann später irgendwie so ein Anruf kommt, kannst du mir einfach das Heizungsthema geben. Nein, das ist kein folgenschwerer Fehler, sondern das ist einfach nur so.
Es sei denn, ich denke nur strategisch darüber und denke, ja, dann hätte sich Habeck einen schlanken Fuß machen können.
Ja klar. Also berühmtblickend kann man natürlich sagen, ja schön blöd, so. Aber wir können natürlich nicht einfach berühmtblickend zu urteilen.
Ja, aber das sind immer diese, lasst mich nochmal einmal, bevor wir da dann hinkommen, sagen, er sagt zum Beispiel, dass Joe Biden die Situation im Oktober 2022 so gefährlich einschätzt wie die Kuba-Krise. Also man ist vor einer nuklearen Katastrophe. Scholz sagt, ich versuche jetzt mal mit dem KI zu sprechen, dass der noch mal sagt, auch die Androhung mit Atomwaffen gehört sich nicht, um Putins Unterdruck zu setzen. Wir erfahren noch, dass Scholz Biden weichklopft, damit Biden Eparams Panzer liefert, damit Scholz nachziehen kann. Also Scholz drängt Biden. Er schreibt das alles und tut aber weiterhin so, als sei Scholz der Zögerliche und der, der da nicht genügend Verantwortung übernimmt. Ich kann es überhaupt nicht begreifen. Er hat doch die Fakten noch mal besser aufgeschrieben, als ich sie wusste. Also da ist doch und schreibt dann noch mal so, Loben für Friedrich Merz. Friedrich Merz, im Gegensatz zu Scholz, sein ganzes Leben lang ein überzeugter Transatlantiker, wird im Frühjahr 2025 radikal umsteuern. Also in Bezug auf die NATO. Und da denke ich mir, nee, macht er ja gar nicht. Ist ja gar nicht der Fall. Und sagt dann, Scholz produziere die öffentliche Meinung zum Taurus entscheidend mit. Ja klar, wenn der Kanzler was sagt, ist das auch öffentliche Meinung produziert. Aber die ganze Zeit wird ausgeblendet, die Meinungsmache, die in Bezug auf Taurus entsteht. Du hattest es ja damals im Aufwachen-Podcast in vielen, vielen Clips mit Tilo gezeigt, wie irre das war mit diesen Taurus-Lieferungen, wie sehr das da alles gefordert wird. Also er hat, also man hat den Eindruck...
Da hatte Tilo die Panzerlieferung, genau. Wie vehement das da zuging.
Also das gibt es doch alles gar nicht. Das heißt nicht, dass man das so auspländen kann. Er sagt dann ja später mit Bezug auf den Agrar-Diesel und den Bauern aufpländender, die Bewirtschafter des Volkszorns von der AfD und den Rechtsaußenmedien versuchen, die Anliegen der Bauern mit ihren eigenen Themen zu vermischen. Dann würde ich jetzt mal gerne wissen, welche Rechtsaußenmedien, Herr Alexander, meinen sie? Meinen sie den Springer-Verlag, der 100 Titelbilder gemacht hat, mit wie schlimm Habeck ist, mit dem Heizhammer und mit den armen Bauern. Und bald werden wir nichts mehr zu essen haben. Jetzt sind auch noch die armen Bauertran. Also hier tut jemand so, als könne er über alles drüber fliegen. Produziert ja diese Meinung die ganze Zeit mit. Also die öffentliche Meinung zum Taurus und zum Krieg und zur Zögerlichkeit von Scholz hat ja Robin Alexander ganz entscheidend mitgeprägt. Wir erinnern uns an diesen Auftritt. Er mit Melanie Ammann gegen Precht und Wälzer bei Markus Lanz. Sie lassen ja kein harte Kritik an sich rankommen.
Ja und so auch in diesem der Heizhammer. Also genau die Kritik. Wo ist die Bildzeitung? Wo ist die große Geschichte? Weil bei ihm ist das so. Also Habeck hat grundsätzlich diesen folgenden schweren Fehler gemacht, das Thema Heizen ins Klimaministerium einzubauen, wo ich mir denke, welche andere Alternative? Na ja, Wirtschaft und Klima. Und da ist ja wirklich die Frage, welche Alternative schwebt ihm hier vor, dass es super klug wäre, also dass er heute im Buch geschrieben hätte, Obert Habeck war der beste Wirtschafts- und Klimaminister aller Zeiten, denn er hat das Heizungsthema abgegeben. Das ist doch absurd.
Ein klarer Geilwitz, von der man ja weiß, dass die sich um alles kümmern.
Dass da gar nichts passiert, genau. So, also bleibt er bei diesem Heizungsthema und für Gebäude und Klimaschutz ist Patrick Greichen zuständig. Greichen muss uns, der wir ihn natürlich schon kennen, nochmal so richtig erklärt werden. Also wortlaut ein Unionspolitiker beschreibt, Greichen und Baake, dieses Duo, das eben aus Agoraenergiewende darüber wechselt, als den Sith Lord und sein Padawan. Muss natürlich all in.
Ja, also die scheint der schlimmste Mensch der Welt zu sein.
Und während die Agoraenergiewende ein Think Tank ist, okay, der halt eine notwendige Politik plant oder sagen wir mal ein Problem bewältigen möchte, nämlich Klimawandel, ist das hier einfach ein ganz böser Monopolist, der nochmal auch im amerikanischen Verhältnis, dort hat man ja, muss man wissen, wird man dann aufgeklärt, immer Pro und Contra, eine Liberale und eine Progressive, eine Liberale und eine GOP-Seite und je nachdem, wer gerade regiert, bedient sich da halt und so. Aber in Deutschland gibt es ja nur die Agoraenergiewende und die ist ja auch nur angeführt von so einem Sith Lord und die Wechseln hat einfach geschlossen und so. Und dann kommt am Ende so ein Halbsatz, an der Expertise hat niemand gezweifelt. Ich denke, wir können doch jetzt nicht die Expertise mal so an den Rand drängen und sagen, ja, aber der war da irgendwie familieverbunden, keine Ahnung. Der ist ja verheiratet mit der Frau von oder mit der Schwester von dem Keller oder so. Aus der Grünen Fraktion. Und das ist einfach schlimm. Das ist diese Perfidie hier, die halt so sagt...
Ja, wenn man mit den Maßstäben sich jetzt das Kabinett von Friedrich Merz ansieht, würde keiner da überleben.
Genau. Wo ist denn da die Expertise? Wo ist denn da der folgeschwere Fehler? Ja, also ich meine, das ist doch... Was soll das denn noch werden?
Die Wirtschaft und noch und nöcher.
Also eigentlich brauchen wir wirklich ein Gegenbuch, dass das mitdiskutiert wird, wie das passiert hat.
Also ich meine, die strategische Blödheit von Habeck, die lag natürlich darin, dass er meinte, das ist eigentlich ein ganz guter Zeitpunkt jetzt, wo eh schon alle darben. Wir machen mal noch mal ein neues Fass auf. Also das ist dann wirklich auch so eine grüne Abgehobenheit, wo man sagt, achso, es gibt auch noch Leute, die unter 8.000 Euro verdienen. Na ja, da hab ich gar nicht mehr nachgedacht. Da würde ich sagen, das ist der Fehler. Und da hätte man auch, und da ist wieder aber Lindner natürlich die Person, die stört, sagen müssen, wie Adam Tusk man im Vortrag formuliert hat, wenn 70 Prozent der Leute die Heizpumpen haben wollen, die Wärmepumpen haben wollen, dann schenkt sie ihnen, dann ist damit die Transformation gemacht. Und die anderen werden sich vielleicht noch mal überlegen, ob sie nicht auch gratis nehmen. Nur, dass man natürlich sofort in so eine merkwürdige Rechnung ging und wie wird wer daran beteiligt und gerade die, die noch mal sanieren müssen. Ja, dann verliert man natürlich alle. Und dann wird aber auch hier einfach die Bild-Zeitung komplett ausgeblendet, die diese Kampagne also nur gefahren ist die ganze Zeit.
Genau, bei der Frage, und das finde ich auch so krass, weil allein die Frage jetzt zu formulieren ist total schwierig, wer hat denn das Heizungsgesetz durchgestochen? Weil schon da würde ich sagen, das ist ja gar nicht die Frage. Wird von Ihnen natürlich hochgradig thematisiert, weil es ja immer noch entscheidend wird, wer hat es denn vor? Also es gibt eine, wir kriegen hier Aufklärung, Frühkoordination. Diese komischen Paper wandern hin und her, auch zum Kanzleramt, damit sich die Chefs schon mal einig sind, bevor es im parlamentarischen Prozess zerredet wird. Nur hat es hier einen Konstruktionsfehler, wie er sagt, einen entscheidenden Konstruktionsfehler. Es gibt ja Spiegelreferate im Kanzleramt, das heißt, dieses Papier haben ganz schön viele Leute in der Hand. Dann kommt es raus, Habeck beschwert sich abends in den Tagesthemen, dass er hier ganz übel mit ihm mitgespielt wurde und so weiter und so fort. Und ich denke mir so ein bisschen, wenn die Pointe dieses Textabschnitts bei Robin Alexander einfach ist, ob das jetzt die SPD war, um Habeck irgendwie ans Bein zu pinkeln, oder die FDP, weil die immer schon was gegen Habeck hatte, vielleicht war es einfach der gleichen Selbst. Also ja, es ist dann bis heute Rätsel in die Grünen, wer ihr wichtigstes Vorhaben durch Indiskretion in Misskredit gebracht hat. Zwei Drittel tippen auf Scholz und Schmitt, ein Drittel tippt auf FDP. Dabei spricht vieles dafür, dass die Antwort überraschend und profaner ist. Habecks wichtigster Mitarbeiter selbst war es, weil Greichen schon in seiner alten Übung als Lobbyist, einfach mal vor irgendwelchen Verbänden und so weiter, in halböffentlichen Veranstaltungen schon mal darüber sprach. Und da denke ich mir so, das Problem ist doch nicht hier, dass der Ablauf so war, wie er war. Und die Problematisierung, dass man noch mal thematisiert, wie der Ablauf war, sondern bis heute ist auch einfach die Frage, wie konnte es passieren, dass man denn dem deutschen Publikum quasi Magie hinstellt, was die Funktionalität und Wirkung angeht. Ganz Nordeuropa ist schon davon überzeugt. Alle schlagen sich vor den Kopf und fragen, was macht ihr in Deutschland? Ihr heizt mit Öl? Seid ihr bescheuert und so? Das ist doch das eigentliche Thema. Und stattdessen wird hier nochmal dieser Brei aufgerührt.
Ja, da könnte man jetzt wieder noch 17 Talkshows anknüpfen. Aber es führt zu nichts. Und endlich geht es ja dann auch weiter bei diesen ganzen Querelen dann zwischen Lindner, Scholz und Habeck. Und Lindner kommt hier meines Erachtens dauerhaft zu gut weg. Wir haben das eben schon mal erwähnt. Robert Pausch hatte ja diese sehr gute Recherche, wie die FDP wirklich systematisch versucht hat, das so zu torpedieren mit ihrem D-Day, dass das dann ja alles so aussieht, als sei quasi die FDP Opfer und jetzt aber auch Sieger zugleich. Die planen das einfach knallhart durch. Lindner ist überhaupt nicht mehr kooperativ, bleibt bei dieser komischen Austeritätspolitik hängen, wo man ja auch jetzt mal, wenn man so einen Text schreibt, eine Frage stellen könnte, ob das in irgendeiner Weise je Sinn ergeben hat. Gerade jetzt im Bezug darauf, dass Friedrich Merz einfach einen Tag nachdem er gewählt wurde, sagt, jetzt wird alles hier anders gemacht. Also da hätte man ja jetzt auch sehr viel Selbstkritik üben können, vielleicht an dieser Austeritätspolitik, an der konservative Journalisten immer festgegangen haben. Nichts davon, sondern es wird jetzt einfach dann nochmal so gesagt, naja, dieses Papier von der FDP war ja nur eines unter vielen und alle haben sich irgendwie vorbereitet. Da muss ich sagen, ja, natürlich bereiten sich alle auf irgendwelche Dinge vor, aber Robert Pausch hat ja schon nochmal hervorgehoben, was da eine Großstrategie gewesen ist. Das war ja nicht so ein, ich brauche mal ein Ausfallszenario, wenn das hier nicht klappt, sondern es war ja tatsächlich der aktive Versuch, diese Ampel zu Ende zu bringen.
Und Robert Alexander ganz beviel, er versucht es so. Er schreibt dann einfach so Sachverhalt und dann all das legt den Eindruck nahe, die FDP habe Verhandlungen um den Erhalt der Regierung zuletzt nur noch dem Schein nachgeführt. Ach, zum Beispiel, ja. Oder die FDP hat sich ohne Frage nach Kräften blamiert. Und dann das D-Day-Papier der Liberalen war nur eine von mehreren Planungen für das Ende der Regierung. Sie wurde nachweislich von allen drei Ampelparteien angestellt. Die FDP ging nicht besonders perfide, sondern besonders stümperhaft vor. Ach so, ja.
Jaja, genau, die sind da so.
Es ist einfach brutal.
Also ich glaube, er ist einfach neidisch darauf, dass ausnahmsweise Robert Pausch bessere Infos hatte.
Ja, er ist auch zu Recht neidisch drauf.
Ja, also das ist so. Wir hören dann so einzelne Details, von denen man vielleicht auch gar nicht wissen wollte, dass es so war. Scholz führt so ein Vorkabinett ein, wo man sich so ein bisschen austauschen kann.
Ja, das ist die kleine Politikstunde von Robert Alexander für uns.
Genau. Und da erfahren wir dann, dass Baerbock dieses Format nutzt, um immer längere Vorträge über die Weltordnung zu halten. Und sie beendet immer die Vorträge mit Tutti Completti Komplex. Und ich denke, Gott, wie grauenhaft muss es gewesen sein, da zu sitzen. Also ja, Respekt für die, die es durchhalten und das ohne Weißwein schaffen. Manche greifen, wie man immer wieder hört, nicht bei den Vorkabinettssitzungen, aber bei anderen zum Weißwein.
Ja, naja, hat ja die Poente noch, dass Scholz nicht immer anwesend war bei diesem Vorkabinett. Weil er zum Beispiel den Deutschen Schulpreis verleihen muss. Und das ist wieder so ein Punkt, wo ich denke, ihr Konservativen könnt nicht immer die ganze Zeit so über Areaschule, Kinder und so weiter. Der Deutsche Schulpreis, wenn da der Kanzler kommt, ist das eine wichtige Sache. Das ist nämlich unsere Zukunft, unser Nachwuchs.
Also das ist bestimmt wichtiger als eine Rede von Baerbock über die Weltlage.
Wir hatten das auch schon von der CDU, dass sie da im Bundestag steht und sagt, ach, sie da namentlich Linke, ihnen würde ich ja nicht mal die Leitung einer Kita anvertrauen. Und ich denke, die Leitung einer Kita ist für alle Anwesen im Raum gerade die verantwortungsvollste Aufgabe, die man nachkommen könnte. Ja, so ihr sitzt hier rum, werdet bewirtet und befördert und hört euch halt Tutti Frutti Vorträge an mit solchen Pointen.
Also ich habe es jetzt auch wieder gesehen, als ich im Museum war, im Kunsthistorischen in Wien, da waren sehr viele Schulgruppen, ich war vormittags da.
Jetzt gerade überall in Deutschland.
Was das für eine unglaubliche Arbeit ist, wenn du einfach 25 Viertklässler hast und sehr, sehr unterschiedliche Bedürfnisse und Mentalitäten unterwegs. Und da dachte ich immer, okay, ich schaffe es ja eigentlich, mich nur durch Wien zu navigieren, weil ich Ohle noch dabei hatte und jetzt das Smartphone. Und dass die das da schaffen mit 25 Kindern, denen würde ich gleich mal ein Ministerium erstmal geben. Die würden es auf jeden Fall ein bisschen besser machen, als das, was wir da so alles lesen. Interessant fand ich, dass Olaf Scholz doch nochmal versucht, so einen Ansätzen Ostpolitik zu machen. Also er ist ja sehr gegen diese Strafzölle für China. Kann sich dabei gar nicht durchsetzen. Er versucht dann nochmal Habeck zu ermuntern, zu sagen, wir brauchen da Verhandlungen. Baerbock will die Strafzölle, EU natürlich auch. Also es ist ganz merkwürdig. Über Habeck erfährt man auch vieles, was einen ja vielleicht bestätigt oder auch das nochmal ein schlechteres Licht rückt. Also er ist eigentlich froh, dass die Linken da aus der grünen Jugend rausgehen. Er spricht dann auch bald von einem Kamala Harris Moment, den er bei den Grünen sieht, weil er glaubt, er ist bei den bürgerlichen Wählern beliebt und er braucht unbedingt diese schwarz-grüne Koalition. Und das, was da von links kommt, das stört er. Und deswegen wird ja dann auch Ricarda Lang zum Beispiel rausgeworfen. Und dann sagt er am März zu Ricarda Lang wohl, also zitiert Robin Alexander, also sie sind doch gar nicht das rote Tuch für die Union. Das rote Tuch ist Habeck. Also finde ich auch sehr gut, dass das noch mal hier so aufgeschrieben wird. Also da sind dann schon manchmal diese Details, die Robin Alexander einfach hat, auch wenn er die FDP laufenden Schutz nimmt und er aber auch einmal dann schreibt, ja, ein lohnendes politisches Projekt hatte die FDP nie. Und das ist doch eigentlich ein guter Satz. Und dann kann man doch sagen, das andere waren irgendwelche Störfeuer. Aber es hat zu nichts geführt. Er glaubt dann, dass ja die Koalition, die nächste dann erfolgreich sein kann, wenn dann solche Fehler organisatorischer Art vermieden werden. Es heißt dann, deshalb muss die Wirkung der Reformen der neuen Bundesregierung unter Friedrich Merz diesmal schneller eintreten, damit sie noch vor der nächsten Wahl einer Regierung aus der Mitte zugeschrieben wird. Schwarz-Rot und Schwarz-Grün oder andere Konstellationen der politischen Mitte dürften bei der nächsten Bundestagswahl nur dann eine Chance haben, wenn die CDU-CSU die illegale Migration erfolgreich reduziert, die SPD den sozialen Ausgleich gewährleistet und beide den Klimaschutz nicht vergessen. Die klare Abgrenzung von Gestaltungs- sphären innerhalb einer Koalition kann dabei helfen. Und dann denke ich mir so, ja, aber wann ist denn das Migrationsthema gelöst? Also das ist ja kein lösbares Ding, in dem sie sagen, jetzt ist es zu.
Das sehen wir doch jetzt in Thüringen, Sachsen. Bundestagswahlzustimmung für die AfD bis 45 Prozent, flächendeckend. Da gibt es keine Ausländer. Also es gibt urbane Zentren mit Ausländern. Das schlägt sich statistisch nieder. In den Dörfern ist einfach Null. Und selbst Null reicht nicht. Sondern Null in Verbindung mit einer 10 Meter hohen Mauer und einer Selbstschussanlage. Vielleicht, aber dann ist es immer noch nicht.
Wenn wir irgendwann sagen, wir müssen vielleicht auch mal wieder sehen, wer ist eigentlich, sind die Italiener eigentlich? Sind die nicht auch Migranten? Also das kann ja immer weitergehen bei diesen Leuten. Und du hast ja keinen Messwert. Also beim BIP kann ich einfach sagen, plus 2 Prozent, super, läuft. Ich kann sagen, die Arbeitslosenzahl ist gesunken.
Na ja, man hat es ja versucht. Obergrenze 300.000. Kretschmer sagt heute 30.000.
Genau, jetzt sagen sie 30.000. Und Ähnliches kann man ja auch bei der Aufrüstung sagen. Auch interessant. Inga Solti, der von der Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung hatte so ein Gedankenexperiment, interessanterweise bei Facebook veröffentlicht. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum gerade da. Aber könnte man ein bisschen populärer vielleicht publizieren, wo er sich mit einem alten Bekannten unterhielt, so ehemals links friedensbewegt, Lehrer, jetzt aber wir müssen aufrüsten und so. Und er fragt sich dann, wann ist er eigentlich genug aufgerüstet? Also wann sind wir sicher gegenüber Putin? Also wie viel muss es eigentlich sein? Und sagen wir irgendwann dann auch, ah ja genau, bis jetzt ist gut. Jetzt brauchen wir nicht noch einen weiteren Panzer. Machen wir natürlich nicht. Und das sind beides so Themen, die man unendlich spielen kann. Er regt sich dann auf, Robin Alexander, dass Olaf Scholz von den Kommunikationseliten spricht und so, dass Scholz jetzt plötzlich in die Medienkritik übergeht. Dann würde ich sagen, ja, das hätte er eigentlich viel früher machen müssen, viel aggressiver und hätte sich gar nicht darauf einlassen wollen. So und jetzt noch meine Kritik an der Linkspartei.
Okay, ist das der abschließende, letzte Punkt?
Für mich das Abschließende, also wenn du noch was vorher loswerden willst.
Ja, lass uns ruhig mit den Linken dann groß aussteigen. Ich will zwei Sachen nochmal markieren. Das eine ist, dieses Buch heißt, wie es heißt, nämlich, wie heißt es nochmal? Letzte Chance. Das ist auch deswegen so unklar, warum es so heißt, dass ich danach fragen muss, weil es mir wirklich unklar blieb bis zum Letzten.
Warum es so heißt, ja.
Und einen Satz habe ich dann doch gefunden, der es uns darstellt, nämlich, lese vor, und das ist auch die tiefste Tiefe, die man hier in Sachen Schöpfungshöhe irgendwie konstruktiv rauskann. Wenn sich die Koalitionspartner von CDU, CSU und SPD gegenseitig nur blockieren, so wie es am Ende im Ampelbündnis lief, dann verspielt die neue Regierung die womöglich letzte Chance für die Demokratie in Deutschland. Damit werden wir alle eingelassen, ja, mit diesem Satz. Und der zweite Punkt.
Damit müsste das Buch beginnen, ne?
Würde ich auch sagen, damit kann man beginnen. Dann vielleicht zehn Seiten illustrativ, aber nicht 400. Und dann sollte eigentlich was kommen. So, der andere Punkt ist, Robin Alexander möchte uns gerne heldenhaft schützen vor ausländischen Einflussnamen. Ich lese mal vorhin. Das Land braucht in der Krise schnelle Veränderungen. Das müssen keine Disruptionen sein, wie sie die amerikanischen Tech-Milliardäre empfehlen. Die 2024 in der amerikanischen Präsidentschaftswahl Donald Trump unterstützten und vor der Bundestagswahl 2025 auf Alice Weidel und ihre AfD setzen. Sie irren! Gesellschaftliche Stabilität war und ist ein Standortvorteil für Deutschland. So, das stimmt. Stabilität ist immer ein Standortvorteil. Was sonst? Also wer sagt jetzt Kurs oder Chaos? Wer entscheidet sich für Chaos? Wer für Kurs? Und ich möchte hier mal anmerken, wir erleben doch gerade eine Welt, in der, nachdem Warren Buffett uns vor 100 Jahren schon aufgeklärt hat, dass hier gerade ein Bürgerkrieg arm gegen Reich und die Reichen gewinnen und so läuft. Indem die Reichen es jetzt auch nicht mehr verschleiern, sondern einfach zeigen, wir gewinnen hier. Und Elon Musk hat USAID gecancelt. Federstrich. Eine Person. Einer hat gesagt, mach mal. Der andere sagt, okay, mach ich. Und jetzt kommt Lancet und sagt, wir haben es mal durchgerechnet, in den nächsten fünf Jahren 14 Millionen Tote. Das sind doch die Kräfte, die hier wirken. Da kann man doch nicht 400 Seiten Erlebnisjournalismus schreiben aus der Berlin Blase.
Und sagen, die sollen sich jetzt mal zusammenreißen, damit wir die Demokratie retten.
Genau. Einfach kurz hinweisen in dem kürzesten möglichen Satz, es gibt da so Tech-Megadäre, sie irren. Klar irren die, aber...
Und die anderen sollen sich mal vertragen, damit das mit der Demokratie wieder besser klappt. Das ist, man hat dann auch...
Dieses Buch ist so schlecht, aber jetzt...
Dass man so tief da drin sein kann und trotzdem nichts sieht, das ist auch interessant. Wenn du zu nah dran stehst... Wenn man zu nah dran ist, dann passiert genau das. Ich will noch, bevor ich das jetzt mit den Linken bringe, noch eine Sache sagen, du hast ja alle Männer-Podcasts durchgehört. Und es ist ja gerade so, dass durch Table Media, Pioneer, Rondsheimer Podcasts, Machtwechsel-Podcasts, die sind dann immer noch alle bei Apokalypse Filter Café zu Gast, dass wir so eine große Springerwolke haben an Podcasts. Und dann sind da noch so ein paar dran angedockt, die dem irgendwie so durch Privatfernsehen so was nahe stehen, wie jetzt bei Studio Booms. Es ist dann jetzt ProSieben und so. Wir geraten ja immer tiefer in diesen Modus Robin Alexander hinein. Alle machen ja Robin Alexander. Also er ist der berühmteste von denen, oder der, der das am besten kann mit dem heißen Lervos. Aber sie erklären ja aber nichts. Sie erklären ja nur von 12 bis Mittag irgendwie eine Geschichte. Da hat er dem das gesagt, da hat die darauf so reagiert. Und dann hat der andere auch gesagt, das müssen wir so machen. In diesem Modus sind ja diese ganzen Podcasts angelegt. Und ist diese ganze Berichterstattung darauf getrimmt. Und dann wird das nochmal in den Talkshows abends wiederholt. Ist der Kanzler da zögerlich? Ja, nochmal das Ganze durch. Wir geraten ja wirklich in eine politisch hoch informierte Desinformation hinein. Also wir wissen alle Details jetzt. Ja, ich habe mittlerweile den Eindruck, ich habe mit Linnemann zusammengesessen in irgendwelchen Ausschüssen. Aber man weiß am Ende ja nichts. Es ist eine große Desinformation, weil man die größeren Linien nicht mehr erkennen kann. Und das ist jetzt das, was so symptomatisch für den Journalismus ist, was man hier gebündelt auf 380 Seiten nachlesen kann. Aber das ist gerade die journalistische Welt, die wir hier in den Händen haben mit diesem Buch. Und das ist das Traurige daran.
Wir haben ja schon das Plädoyer gemacht. Sachbücher bitte 140 Seiten. Den Rest nachlegen oder wie auch immer. Aber 140 Seiten, das muss genügen. Alles darüber hinaus ist eigentlich Harry Potter.
Ja, immer noch ein weiterer Band, immer noch ein bisschen was erzählen. Wir haben ja eine Zeit, in der alle sagen, wir beschäftigen uns mit Politik. Aber eigentlich ist das hier nur Fanfiction, immer weiter schreiben.
Und die Linken, was ist jetzt mit den Linken?
Ja, die Linken. Also wir wissen, Friedrich Merz, beim ersten Wahlgang wird nicht gewählt. Friedrich Merz zieht sich zurück. Manche denken schon, schmeißt er hin. Nee, er will einen zweiten Wahlgang. Am selben Tag. Am selben Tag gibt es eigentlich keinen zweiten Wahlgang. Da braucht man eine Zweidrittelmehrheit, um das durchzusetzen. Woher die beschaffen? Die SPD sagt natürlich also auf keinen Fall von der AfD. Und da bleiben also nur die Linken. Man weiß gar nicht, wen soll man also anrufen. Dobrindt hat aber eine Handynummer wenigstens, nämlich die von Janine Wissler. Und die kontaktiert er. Also tut man sich da mit den Linken in Räumchen zusammen und unterhält sich. Ich habe hier einen Text mal vorgestellt, von dem heute schon erwähnt Sebastian Friedrich. In dem er sagt, also das ist die Establishmentisierung der Linken. Da hast du sehr vehement widersprochen. Und einige haben das auch entsprechend kommentiert, haben auch eher widersprochen. Und ich würde sagen, Friedrich und ich werden bestätigt durch Robin Alexander, denn wir hören hier Folgendes. Die Linke will nämlich eigentlich, dass die Zustimmung daran knüpfen, dass sie bei der Reform der Schuldenbremse aktiv eingebunden werden. Dann sind sie bereit, Friedrich Merz am selben Tag noch mal einen Wahlgang zu genehmigen. Die Linke berät mit ihren eigenen Leuten, dann treffen sie sich erneut. Die Unionsleute sagen, sie könnten in Sachen Schuldenbremse nichts versprechen. Müssen sie ohnehin nicht, ohne die Linke gibt es sowieso keine Mehrheit für eine Anderung. Das haben auch deren Unterhändler mittlerweile eingesehen. Die Forderung einiger Genossen die Unione müsse ihren Unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss auf der Stelle öffentlich abschwören, übernimmt die linke Fraktionsführung nicht. Sie versteht, dass Merz nicht einfach so einen Parteitagsbeschluss widerrufen kann. Also beide Ideen werden nicht von der Union umgesetzt, nicht willig, nicht können nicht. Und dann steht hier, die Linke gibt sich mit etwas weniger zufrieden. Die Union solle einen gemeinsamen Antrag mit ihnen einbringen und sich anschließend für das Entgegenkommen der Linken öffentlich bedanken. Spahn schlägt ein und ist damit der nächste Konservative der erstaunliche Flexibilität beweist. Friedrich Merz musste für seine Kanzlerschaft bereits die Schuldenbremse schleifen. Jetzt muss Jens Spahn am ersten Tag seines Fraktionsvorsitzes auch noch mit den Linken zusammenarbeiten. So schnell wurden noch nie Grundsätze für die Macht geopfert. So kann man das sehen. Oder auch so soll eine stabile Regierung im wichtigsten europäischen Land etwa in Frage gestellt werden. Nur weil ein Christdemokrat nicht mit einer Linken gemeinsam auf einen Antrag stehen will? Wohl kaum. Der Antrag wird von Union, SPD, Grünen und Linken gemeinsam eingebracht. Und dann bedanken sich Span öffentlich und sagen ja, wir danken SPD, Grüne und Linke. Später nochmal Alexander Hofmann von der CSU. Ich möchte mich auch ausdrücklich bedanken, nicht nur bei unserem Koalitionspartner, sondern auch bei den Grünen und bei den Linken. Und dann nochmal Thorsten Frei. Mit Sicherheit sind wir in einer Situation, wo wir die eine oder andere Frage neu bewerten müssen. Was wir doch jetzt hier lesen können, ist, die Linken haben das einfach kostenlos gemacht. Also für das, die sich jetzt da bedanken. Also was soll das? Man kann ja nicht die ganze Zeit Friedrich Merz zum großen Feind erklären und dann sagen, ja, aber ich hätte schon mal gern, wenn wir das jetzt machen, so ein Dankeschön. Also ich verstehe nicht, wie man sich so billig verkaufen kann. Und Robin Alexander sagt ja auch, wenn diese Wahl erst drei Tage später stattgefunden hätte, wäre das möglicherweise von einer Katastrophe zu einem Totalschaden geworden. Also bedeutet, für Friedrich Merz hätte das jetzt hier ganz böse ausgehen können.
Ja, nicht nur für ihn. Also, dass es für ihn böse ausgeht, ist ja dann das Mindeste.
So, und dann muss man sagen, das hat die Linke, die sich als die große Opposition aufschwingt, hat das also möglich gemacht, dass das doch alles in diesem Rahmen läuft, nur dafür, dass dann am Ende Jens Spahn einem Danke sagt?
Ich wiederhole nochmal meine Kritik an dieser Sicht der Dinge. Denn wir haben jetzt dieses große Angebot zwischen, klingt ein bisschen albern, aber ich sage es trotzdem, Werte fundierter Politik oder eben transaktional. Und wohin das Transaktionale gerade führt, sehen wir. Also das ist einfach eine Spirale nach unten. Auch wenn da noch irgendwelche glauben, sie kämen als Gewinner aus so einer Win-Lose-Situation, am Ende wird es für alle schlecht. Und hier in so einer Situation, die nicht von der Linken hergestellt ist, sondern die sich einfach nur als historisches Angebot, ihr könntet das jetzt ausnutzen, weil hier geht es um extrem viel und die wären wahrscheinlich auch bereit viel zu machen. Dass man da sich selber markiert als bei der großen Unterscheidung, ob wir es jetzt transaktional ausbeuten, was uns historisch einfach zugefallen ist. Oder in diesem Moment nochmal, die Werte des Grundgesetzes sind uns schon wichtig. Es ist im Grunde nur ausversehene Tagesordnungsfrage, ob heute oder am Freitag, aber dazwischen liegt halt auch der 8. Mai, Holocaustgedenken und so weiter. Dass man da sagt, wir springen jetzt über unseren Schatten, auch wenn es am Ende den Untergang nicht aufhalten wird. Aber wir spielen das transaktionale Spiel nicht mit, sondern machen es nochmal wertefundiert. Und sagen, okay, das sind Idioten. Wir nutzen die Gelegenheit, das nochmal zu markieren. Wir stellen uns nochmal da, als diejenigen auf dies ankommt. Aber diesen Pfand lösen wir dann auch ein. Es kommt eben auch auf uns an. Es sind unsere Stimmen. Das finde ich gut. Denn außerhalb des Parlaments bin ich für jedes linke Theater zu haben.
Ja, aber da zählt es ja nicht.
Aber für die linke Disziplin...
Verstehst du, was ich sagen will, also nur da kannst du ja wirklich jetzt mal einen Unterschied machen, wie man sagen würde.
Ja, aber der Unterschied heißt keine Bundesregierung.
Eine andere.
Ja, nee, das heißt in dem Fall wirklich erstmal keine Bundesregierung. Eine AfD im Aufwind und dann...
Nein, man hätte drei Tage später ja gewählt. Vielleicht nicht Friedrich Merz.
Also es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Oder vielleicht hätte es in den Reihen der SPD eine kleine Aufräumaktion gegeben. Also irgendwas wäre passiert. Wenn ich natürlich immer sage, ich mache das aus dieser staatspolitischen Verantwortung, dann muss ich mich aber die ganze Zeit konstruktiv immer wieder verhalten.
Ich verstehe es total. Aber der Linken ist in dem Moment nicht durch Ereignis zu tun, sondern ein historisches Angebot gemacht worden, von dem man sagen könnte, okay, sie haben es abgelehnt. Hätten sie das Angebot angenommen, würden wir heute über das historische Angebot der AfD gesprochen, das ihnen ohne Zutun einfach gemacht wurde. Und es wäre ein großes Geschenk gewesen.
Möglicherweise auch nicht. Möglicherweise hätte es eine Neuwahl gegeben, und die Linke wäre noch stärker geworden.
Ich meine das mit der Neuwahl. Die Linken hätten vielleicht von ihren 12 auf 16, aber die AfD wäre voll reingegangen.
Ich will nur deutlich machen, diese minimale Konstruktivität zeigt jemand wie Friedrich Merz nicht, der ja die ausgestreckte Hand von Olaf Scholz hat liegen lassen und gesagt, ich mache hier meinen Wahlkampf, ich will, dass schnell Neuwahlen sind, am liebsten schon an Heiligabend wählen, damit ich jetzt meine Stimmen hier bekomme. Ich weiß, ich könnte mit ihnen jetzt hier zusammen wunderbar mit den Grünen die Schuldenbremsenreform anstreben, mache ich aber nicht. Also da ist ja überhaupt keine Konstruktivität gezeigt worden. Jetzt hat man so auf dem Reißbrett noch schnell so eine Notlösung auserkommen, mit dem alten Parlament irgendwas schnell beschließen. Während jetzt ja hier ein anderer Fall vorliegt, man hätte sagen können, selbst wenn ich sage, wir gehen diesen konstruktiven Schritt mit, wie du ihn siehst, weil du sagst, sonst Staatskrise oder so, da hätte man ja schon ein bisschen klüger verhandeln können, außer ein Danke zu hören.
Alles richtig.
Ich kann verstehen, dass manches nicht geht, dass vielleicht dieser Unvereinbarkeitsbeschluss nicht fallen kann aus irgendwelchen Gründen, die nicht so einfach machbar sind. Anderes wäre machbar gewesen. Und dass sie sich so billig verkauft haben, also für ein Dankeschön, würde ich jetzt nicht mit Friedrich Merz kandidieren.
Ich hole jetzt nochmal wirklich eine Atombombe raus. Dieser Frank Sauer hat in diesem Deutschlandfunkgespräch über den Neuen Westen gesagt, Achtung, jetzt wird es theoretisch, das ist ganz paradox, es ist ja nie eine Atombombe abgeworfen worden seit Hiroshima Nagasaki. Deswegen haben wir es ja mit einem Nichtereignis zu tun. Und man könnte gar nicht genau sagen, ob jetzt der Kalte Krieg, also die Drohung mit Atomwaffen, verhindert hat, oder ob trotz oder wegen Atomwaffen ist und so weiter. Und ich gehöre nicht in dieses Lager. Ich gehöre in das Lager, wo man sagt, eine nicht abgeworfen Atomwaffe ist ein Ereignis. Wir können es nicht einfach nur von der Erklärungsfolie totale Zerstörung, das sehe ich. Und alles, was dann nicht passiert ist, nicht passiert. Das Szenario ist wie folgt, in dem Moment, wo nach diesem Ampel Chaos, unaufgearbeitet, welche Verantwortung die Medien haben und dadurch zusätzliche Gefahr, dass man nicht genau weiß, wie die Medien auf ein kommende Chaos Situation einstimmen. Der CDU, die schon mit der AfD eine übergroße Mehrheit hat, rechnerisch März wegzuschlagen und den drei Tage vorher zum Fraktionschef Spahn ausgerufenen neuen obersten folgerichtigen Chef, Aya Toller, dieser Partei, die Gelegenheit zu geben. Da bin ich sehr dafür, wir werfen die Atombombe nicht und markieren das aber auch als ein echtes Ereignis und sagen nicht einfach, paradox und hier und so.
Ja, aber ich will zwei Sachen sagen. Einmal genau das haben die Linken nicht gemacht, das hat sein richtiges Ereignis zu markieren. Sie waren einfach nur froh, dass sie auch mal mit dabei sein durften.
Das Ereignis ist trotzdem, ohne diese Markierung, trotzdem ein Ereignis.
Das haben sie nicht entsprechend ausgeschlachtet, haben sie einfach nicht gemacht und es haben sie nicht für sich genutzt und es haben sie auch öffentlich nicht entsprechend genutzt. Man kann es jetzt hier bei Robin Alexander auf den zwei Seiten nochmal nachlesen. Zweitens sehe ich diese Gefahr, die du da schilderst, ja durchaus. Dann muss man aber auch jetzt fragen und das ist aber jetzt eine Frage, die muss ich ja Gott sei Dank nicht klären. Ich bin ja nicht in der Linkspartei. Bedeutet das also, man hat so eine antifaschistische Volksfront, die bedeutet, wann immer eine AfD-Koalition droht, werden wir mit allen anderen konstruktiv zusammenarbeiten. Bedeutet vielleicht dann auch im nächsten Schritt nicht nur den Wahlgang zu genehmigen, sondern bedeutet zum Beispiel auch, gemeinsam irgendwelche Grundänderungen vorzunehmen, um mehr Abschiebung zu ermöglichen, um andere Dinge zu ermöglichen, um konstruktiv das Letzte zu verhindern, nämlich eine Koalition mit der AfD. Also das ist die große, wir haben das ja auf einer Länderebene immer mal wieder erlebt, wie konstruktiv man da dann plötzlich sein will, aus einer regierungspolitischen Verantwortung oder so. Also ich glaube, dass wir da noch einige Überraschungen erleben werden und dass das erster Anfang war.
Also für mich ist schon wichtig, dass das so eine kleine historische Singularität ist, dass die einfach gar nicht wussten, wie es jetzt weitergeht. Also es war wirklich für alle so ein überraschendes Ereignis. Eine geplante Grundgesetzänderung, bei der man mit den Linken im parlamentarischen Verfahren ausverhandelt, was möchte denn die Linke haben dafür, dass man mehr Abschiebungen macht, völlig ausgeschlossen. Also wird nicht passieren, deswegen muss ich mich auch nicht dazu verhalten, wie ich das dann kritisieren würde. Das halte ich für völlig... Hier ging es wirklich um erstens, mal gucken, ob es dabei bleibt, ob es um einen formalen Akt und zweitens um eine historische schwarze Schwanland passiert einfach, die CDU nicht darauf vorbereitet oder die Bundestagsverwaltung, wie man damit umgeht. Gut, damit haben wir Robin Alexander gesprochen.
Wir kommen zu schöneren Dingen. Wir sprechen über Schauspielerei im Film. Der wunderbare Regisseur Dominik Graf hat ein Buch geschrieben, Sein oder Spielen über Filmschauspielerei bei CH Beck erschienen. Es ist ein Buch für Menschen, die sich für Schauspielerei interessieren, für Filme interessieren. Es ist ein Buch, das mich begeistert und zugleich unter Druck setzt, weil ich dann immer so merke, okay, ich habe offenbar gar keine Ahnung von Filmen. Dominik Graf kennt jeden Film, den es gibt auf der Welt und jeder Absatz kommt noch ein weiterer Film. Und ich denke, da muss ich sofort dem nachgehen. Also viele bekannte natürlich Sachen dabei, aber dann auch in den Genrefilm hinein. Viele, viele Szenenbeschreibungen, wie eine Schauspielerin dies macht, ein Schauspieler das macht, so dass man auch Lust bekommt, eigentlich nach einer Seite Lektüre mal zu sagen, okay, ich besorge mir jetzt den Film, gucke mir jetzt den Film an, schaue mir das nochmal an und dann lese ich weiter. Und man muss das, glaube ich, auch als ein Buch erfahren, dass man jetzt überall eigentlich öffnen kann und loslesen kann, weil es ein Buch ist, das ja sehr viele Beispiele wählt. Es geht also jetzt nicht darum, eine große Schauspieltheorie zu entfalten, sondern Dominik Graf berichtet von der Zusammenarbeit mit Schauspielern, z. B mit Götz George hat er ja gedreht oder wie er Martina Gedeck sieht. Er berichtet aber auch sehr ausführlich davon, wie er beim Filmpreis in München einen Preis Melanie Griffiths überreicht. Und da ist die Rede abgedruckt, in der er genau erzählt, wie sie gespielt hat. Es ist also ein Buch, das für Menschen ist, die im Film sich schon sehr gut auskennen, die da immer weiter hineingehen und die vor allem es schätzen, wenn solche Einzelbetrachtungen stattfinden, die einfach sehr gut beobachtet sind. Wenn er beispielsweise schildert, wie James Dean in Giganten agiert. Also wie man so eine alte Garde von Schauspielern hat, wie Rock Hudson dort steht und dann macht James Dean, nimmt gar nicht einen Blickkontakt auf, macht sowas ganz eigenes für sich und wie das ganz revolutionär ist, wie eine neue Art des Schauspiels dann in den Hollywood-Filmen kommt. Man hat sofort Lust, dann den Film zu sehen und sich diese Szene nochmal zu vergegenwärtigen. Also es ist interessant zu sehen, wie unterschiedlich schauspielerische Ansätze sein können. Es ist auch eine Anekdoten-Sammlung. Also man kann sehr sprunghaft da durchgehen. Man kommt auf lustige Zitate. Man hat zum Beispiel auch die Anekdote, dass Dustin Hoffman für Marathon-Man sich vier Tage nicht duscht, vier Tage nicht schläft, immer dieselben Klamotten anhat. Und sein Kollege Lawrence Olivier bekommt das dann mit und sagt, warum, probier es doch einfach mal mit Schauspielen. Es ist ganz einfach. Ja, also so unterschiedliche, ja, die einen wollen die Figur erst mal werden, um sie spielen zu können. Die anderen sagen, ja, das ist Handwerke. Ich muss mal überlegen, wie lege ich das an? Er spricht dann zum Beispiel über den Mund. Da heißt es dann, der Mund ist aber vor allem eben auch ein Verräter beim Spielen versehentlich oder bewusst eingesetzt. Die Steingesichter des Anand Delon, dem Basta-Kitten des Gangsterfilms, demonstrieren, wie genau er von dieser Gefahr wusste. Vielleicht hat es ihm auch sein großer Ziehfahrt herbeigebracht, der ikonische Regisseur Jean-Pierre Melville. Aber in seinen besten Filmen legt Delon eine maskenhafte Undurchdringlichkeit auf, die ihm mal psychische Stärke und Härte, mal eine tiefe Verletzlichkeit verleiht. Wie oft muss man im Schneideraum den Beginn eines Satzes, den Sprech- und Atemansatz eines einer Schauspielerin, wegschneiden, weil er offenbart, was kommen wird. Da gibt es vorauseilende Mimik, Seufzer, Augenrollen, Kopfbewegungen, aber vor allem ein Schürzen des Mundes, ein breit zerrende Lippen, ein nachdenkliches Verziehen usw. Alle offenbaren, nehmen etwas vorweg. Delon und die meisten großen US-Stars Spielen, spielten, zumeist trocken, ansatzlos, ob eisig oder locker, cool, immer kein Gramm zu viel. Als würden sie sozusagen das Medium, früher hätte ich gesagt, das Filmmaterial, die ganze Arbeit für sich machen lassen. Sie denken den Gegenschnitt zu ihrem Spiel bereits mit. Sie werden zur Projektion dessen, was wir in sie hinein sehen wollen. Das ist eine kluge Strategie. Und wenn man mal darauf achtet, ist das wirklich so. Und wir sehen so, wenn jemand spricht, dass wir uns schon was vorwegnehmen. Du öffnest jetzt gerade schon den Mund, dann weiß ich, okay, du willst jetzt schon. Und wenn du jetzt schon das Drehbuch hast, also du weißt, was ich sagen werde, dann machst du natürlich schon etwas, was mein Sagen schon vorwegnimmt. Und wie damit zu agieren ist, auch interessant, weil wir...
Also jetzt, wenn du es hier sagst, ich habe durch Zufall einfach nur, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es ist, aber Schauspieler, die sich für deutsche CDF-Serien oder so bewerben, laden auf YouTube manchmal so ihre Set-Videos, keine Ahnung, wie das heißt, Reels, irgendwas, so zehn Minuten und dann so in verschiedenen Situationen, wie sie so agieren. Und mein Eindruck war die ganze Zeit, du sollst in der ersten zehntel Sekunde wissen, was passiert. Da wird so Ausdrucksdruck eingeatmet. Bevor gesprochen wird, wird gleich mal der Raum so gesondiert und so. Also es wird genau das Gegenteil eigentlich von dem gemacht, was du jetzt hier als, das ist das Ziel der Profis beschrieben hast.
Er berichtet dann sehr anekdotenreich. Wenn er etwas nicht so gut ist, dann zählt meistens nennt er dann die Namen auch nicht. Also ist da diskret. Es geht ja auch mehr um die Sache an sich. Da sagt er, eine Hauptdarstellerin kam am ersten Drehtag eines großen Kinofilms, unabgesprochen, mit jedem Dialogsatz gecoacht von einem Rollentrainer. Die es ja in den USA schon lange zuvor gab, bei uns war es damals neu. In ihrem Fall legte sie konstant Atemluftsäulen unter ihre Sprache, unter fast jeden Satz, was wohl auch erotisch gemeint war. Das eigentliche Problem an dieser für die Rolle etwas nahe liegenden Spieleidee war jedoch, dass die eingeübte Sprechweise für die gesamte Dauer des Films bei ihr nicht mehr richtig rauszukriegen war. Kaum ein Satz in den wesentlichen Szenen kam er so, wie ich ihn mir vorgestellt hatte. Trocken, offen, spontan. Irreparables Luftkissen, Gesäuse. Ich habe es jedenfalls nicht reparieren können. Seitdem, und das ist jetzt interessant, mache ich immer und mit jeder auch noch so kleinen Rolle vor, dem Drehen möglichst ausführliche Sprechproben, die auch den Rhythmus, die Tonalität betreffen. Und nicht nur die Frage, was fühlt deine Figur? Ja, es sind viele Details, viele Dinge, bei denen man auch sagt, okay, da bin ich jetzt gerade nicht so drin, in welchem Film hatte wer wie mit dem Mund gezuckt oder die Augen aufgeschlagen. Man muss dann damit leben, dass man das nicht alles wissen kann. Man hat nicht alles gesehen, was Dominik Graf gesehen hat. Man hat doch nicht alles beobachtet.
Ist das ein Lehrbuch?
Nein, es ist kein Lehrbuch. Ich würde sagen, es ist ein Erinnerungsbuch. Es ist ein Kompendium von gewissen Auffassungen zum Schauspiel. Es ist ein Lexikon auch. So geht er hin und wieder. Also er geht zum Beispiel Stars durch oder Starlets. Also solche Sternchen, die mal kurz funkeln und die so zwei, drei interessante Rollen spielen und dann wieder weg sind. Er verfolgt deren Schicksal dann auf ein paar Zeilen, geht dann wieder zum nächsten über. Also es ist eine sehr sprunghafte Anlage dieses Buches. Es ist dann aber auch immer mal wieder so eine Betrachtung, die grundsätzlicher wird. Es geht beispielsweise um Barbara Valentin, die man früher dann so das Busenwunder nannte. Eine Schauspielerin, die später auch mit Freddie Mercury zusammen gelebt hat in München und die dann irgendwann natürlich nicht mehr an diese Erfolge anknüpfen konnte, bei Fassbinder eine Zeit lang was anderes noch sein durfte, aber ja, auch eben ein Starlet war, die dann auch vor allem an der Theke anzutreffen war. Und jetzt beschreibt er viele dieser Starlets, die dann auch Probleme hatten, irgendwie seelische Probleme hatten, mit all dem so fertig zu werden, auch mit dem Alter klarzukommen. Und da könnte man ja heute sagen, ja, Therapie wäre doch was. Und dann sagt er, na ja, also mit diesem Psychotherapie-Form, das ist so eine Sache. Da kann man sich natürlich jetzt mit stark machen, aber oftmals sorgt das dann auch dafür, dass gewisse Freundschaften nicht mehr möglich sind, Familien auch daran zu Grunde gehen können, an so einer Art von modernen Psychotherapie. Und noch etwas schreibt er. Resilienz ist eine Rüstung. Der Drang zur permanenten Selbstbestimmtheit verschließt auch wiederum kreative Poren. Verletzlichkeit und emotionale Instabilität sind schwer auszubalancieren, zweifellos. Aber sie schaffen allen großen und kleinen Künstlerinnen auf der Welt auch eine Transparenz. Sehnsucht nach Liebe, die man Schauspielerinnen im Kino ansieht, kann nicht ersetzt werden durch ausgestelltes Ich-Bewusstsein, durch Ich weiß wer ich bin und was ich will und festgeklopfte Ich-AG-Karriere-Strategien. Die Gewagtheiten, die Abstürze, die unerfüllten Sehnsüchte, die Tränen, die muss man im Film sehen, glauben können. Einiges kann man nun mal nicht spielen. Und die permanente Offenheit, die der Beruf fordert, ist unersetzlich. Lars Reichardt, der Sohn von Barbara Valentin, fragt sich in seinem Buch an, was seine Mutter dachte, wenn sie beim Spielen wie auf Knopfdruck weinen konnte. Wie weinst du denn im Film, Mama, wollte ich wissen. Ich brauche bloß an etwas bestimmtes zu denken, schon schießen mir die Tränen in die Augen, sagte sie. Um Himmels willen, woran denkst du denn bloß? Verrate ich dir ein anderes Mal, sagte meine Mutter an unserem letzten gemeinsamen Abend vor ihrem Schlaganfall, dem Weihnachtsabend des Jahres 2000. Jetzt wieder Dominik Graf, die Filmkunst, wenn man sie in allen Erscheinungsformen ernst nimmt, frisst auch ihre Kinder. Und wenn es dabei keine Verletzungen mehr geben darf, sondern sich alle mit schimmernden Egorüstungen begegnen und ständig einander Rücksichtsnahme und Wertschätzung beteuern, dann wird das Kino vielleicht auch zu Recht nicht überleben. Also eine interessante Idee, der ich glaube ich sehr zustimme. Also diese Fragilität, die sicherlich für das Leben ein großes Problem ist. Und da geht ja einige Biografien dann mal so durch in einem Kapitel. Ist natürlich auch wieder eine Stärke für das, was man im Film dann benötigt. Und ja, wer also in die Schauspielerei da tiefer einsteigen will, oder auch sich fragt, ja wie spielen die eigentlich, wie machen die das eigentlich, dann findet man hier viele verschiedene Antworten. Also es ist nicht ein Buch, das sagt, hier ist meine Methode. Du musst an was Schreckliches denken, dann kannst du gut spielen. Oder du musst nur Handwerk machen oder so. Es werden verschiedene Wege natürlich da aufgezeigt. Aber es ist vor allem auch, deswegen sagte ich das Anfangs, ein Erinnerungsbuch, also Dominik Graf resümiert hier auch, das was er gesehen hat, was ihn beeindruckt hat. Das ist also ein ganz persönliches Lexikon und Kompendium.
Kommen denn seine eigenen Filme auch noch mal so drin vor? Ja, auch da geht er natürlich darauf ein, was sind denn so seine, wer wird gelegt dabei?
Na zum Beispiel Hotte im Paradies, das ist ein ganz großartiger Film über das Rotlichtmilieu, Die Katze mit Götz G. Orge musst du dir unbedingt ansehen. Ein unglaublich toller Thriller mit Gudrun Landgräbe auch noch. Und Im Angesicht des Verbrechens ist eine wirklich fantastische Serie. Die wurde damals von der FAZ auch sehr gelobt. Und die ist dann aber nicht so erfolgreich geworden, weil man in Deutschland dann sagte, gut, das zeigen wir dann und dann in der ARD und wie das dann so ist. Also eigentlich kam die ein bisschen zu früh. Das wäre wahrscheinlich jetzt das Netflix-Ding schlechthin vielleicht sogar geworden. Na ja, weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht auch zu anspruchsvoll für die heutigen Sehgewohner. Also eine ganz großartige Serie. Ja, dann die Kessner-Verfilmung, Fabian. Also es gibt einiges zu entdecken. Okay.
Wir gehen auf dem Spektrum auf die ganz andere Seite. Sam Altman guckt nicht zurück, was er erlebt hat, sondern was der Welt zukünftig droht. Und er spricht von der Gentle Singularity. Und ich will es ganz klar markieren. Ich halte Sam Altman für einen ganz gefährlichen Idioten. Ja. Wir wissen, wie im Silicon Valley gesprochen wird. Das gingen bisher nicht gut aus, die Fantasien, die man da so hatte. Und von daher geht es mir ja auch darum, die Drohung festzuhalten. Also wir haben den Ereignishorizont überschritten, sagt er. Der Start hat begonnen, mit der meint, die Superintelligenz ist da. Und mit Ereignishorizont wissen wir jetzt seit Nolan, damit ist das schwarze Loch gemeint. Es gibt keinen Entrinnen mehr. Wir sind in der Gravitation gefangen. Also es wird passieren. Und es wird aber viel weniger merkwürdig, als es eigentlich sein sollte. Deswegen ja, Gentle. Verspricht er uns. Heute schon haben wir diese Systeme, die uns in vielerlei Hinsicht intelligent, also einfach überragen. Ich sage ja, das haben wir so ein bisschen mit Taschenrechner. Wobei jetzt dieser so ein bisschen breiter geworden ist. Das Angebot an Überragungen, die wir da erleben. Der unwahrscheinlichste Teil der Arbeit liegt hinter uns, sagte. Bin ich einen sehr interessanten Satz. Denn wir kennen ja diese Idee des KI-Winters. Also man macht einen Durchbruch und dann merkt man, okay, der ist ausgereizt, nichts passiert. Jetzt hat man einen Durchbruch, bei dem man merkt, man hat ihn noch nicht ausgereizt. Man wird vielleicht nicht einzelne KI-Strategien noch hochtreiben können, aber dann miteinander verschachteln oder was auch immer, sich noch mehr am menschlichen Gehirn und dem Apparat orientieren, wie immer. ChatGPT ist in einem großen Sinne bereits mächtiger als jeder Mensch, der je gelebt hat. Da dachte ich so an Ray Kurzweil, der ja auch immer ganz wichtig betont, nein, nein, die KI ist nicht einfach nur klug. Sie ist klüger als jeder Mensch, der je gelebt hat und leben wird. So und dann kommt immer dieser blödsinn da mit, warum so. Naja, gegenwärtige Realität. Also noch laufen Roboter nicht auf der Straße, noch fliegen wir nicht ins All. Man sieht hier schon, das ist ganz schön materiell gedacht, dafür, dass wir alle noch im Chatbot-Zeit alle sind. Aber es wird kommen. Eine kleine Neufähigkeit kann eine enorme positive Wirkung erzeugen, freut er sich und warnt aber auch. Eine kleine Fehlausrichtung multipliziert mit hunderten von Millionen Menschen, kann sehr viel negative Auswirkungen verursachen. Wir werden ja nachher noch hören, wie wenig jetzt so mitgedacht wird bei diesem Schritt für Schritt. Und das sieht man ja auch bei, also man kann ja fast weniger mitdenken als März jetzt so im politischen Alltag. Also da geht vielleicht gar nicht so viel politische Steuerung verloren, weil eh schon nichts da ist. Naja, Szenarien. 2025 ist schon das Jahr, in dem Agenten für uns kognitive Arbeit leisten. Was konkret hier bedeutet. Die Literaturliste heute schreiben wir, aber die KI bereitet sie auf, indem sie am richtigen Punkt einen Doppelpunkt und dann die URL und von der URL nur die Top-Level-Domain und der ganze Kram. Kapitelmarken, Texte. Also ich wähle die Kapitelmarken aus, aber die kleinen Zusammenfassungen, da lasse ich einfach Gemini, kurz die wichtigsten Substantive und so, mal ein Wort, so einen Text bringen. Also da sind wir, also auch wir jetzt einfach schon. An 2026 sagt er neuartige wissenschaftliche Erkenntnisse. Da bin ich sehr skeptisch, denn wir werden nachher bei Apple hören, ne, die Begrenzung im Sinne von KI-Illusion durch Rekombination, zehn Gedichte und dann noch ein elftes, das sich auch reimt, das ist aber noch kein Fortschritt, sondern es ist einfach nur ein elftes Gedicht. Also wir sind noch sehr in dieser Manufaktur und Produktion, aber noch nicht so richtig bei Research and Development angekommen. Er sagt 2026, können wir dann gucken. 2027 sagt, da kommt die KI in die reale Welt, also Roboter, ich denke da vor allem auch an Autos, das ist ja, daran denke ich ja so, ne, dass ich einfach, ich habe keinen Führerschein, aber ein Mobilitätsbedürfnis, wann, wann trete ich ein in die über 25 kmh-Beförderung ohne fremde Hilfe. Bislang brauche ich immer einen Fahrer, Busfahrer, Zugfahrer, Taxifahrer. 2030, die Fähigkeit einer Person, 2030 viel mehr zu erreichen als 2020 wird eine auffällige Veränderung sein. Das ist natürlich jetzt so eine KI-Übersetzung von dem Standardenglischen Klampelsatz so. Aber das finde ich eigentlich interessant, denn wir haben jetzt, unabhängig von KI, allein durch technischen Fortschritt auch einen sehr großen Sprung von 1920 zu 1930 ist ja unser Thema so. Also das ist ja, wenn du jetzt vergleichst 60er, 70er, wo dann schon so die, wo ist eigentlich der Fortschritt und so, das ist da klar auch durch Militärtechnik, Vorbereitung und so weiter oder echte Kriege, die nachwirken. Also dieses ruhige Jahrhundert, dass es jetzt so hier nochmal markiert wird, okay. Intelligenz und Energie werden wir im Überfluss, im wilden Überfluss, widely abundant werden beide Ressourcen sein. Er rechnet dann kurz durch, was es heute kostet, ChatGPT eine Frage zu stellen, also wie viel Strom und wie viel Wasser das ist. Das sind natürlich so 0,000, also irgendwie und so. Und er meint, irgendwann wird es nicht mehr auffallen. Energie durch Erneuerbare, die zu Intelligenz einfach umkodiert wird, ohne dass wir noch einen Ressourcenverbrauch feststellen, dass sich dann so niederschlägt, dass wir ganz normal mit der KI dann leben. Also mal sehen.
Aber wie kommt diese Erneuerbare Energie zustande? Wer baut die?
Ja, das ist eben...
Das macht auch die AGI dann oder was?
Genau.
Ach so.
Naja, also das sagt er ganz konkret. Also für ihn sind es Roboter, die andere Roboter bauen. Wenn sie die gesamte Lieferkette betreiben können, Mineralien abbauen und veredeln, Lastwagen fahren, Fabriken betreiben und so weiter. Rechenzentren werden Rechenzentren bauen. Die wirtschaftliche Wertschöpfung hat einen Schwungsschaden.
Das ist aber eine schöne Idee. Perpetuum mobili.
Wir wissen alle genau, dass umso mehr Monopolisierung und Zentralisierung im Markt geschehen ist, umso mehr wird Partikularistisch oben rausgegriffen, um eine Party in Venedig zu feiern. Also, hier wird ja sozusagen abgezogen. Von der würde ich auch sagen, er sagt das so. Aber er ist überschöpft, er ist überzeugt, die wirtschaftliche Wertschöpfung hat ein Schwungrad, des sich aufbauenden Infrastrukturausbaus in Gang gesetzt. Also in der Zukunft. Es wird ein selbstlaufendes System sein. Naja, so wird die Singularität dann ablaufen. Wunder werden zur Routine, stell dich drauf ein. Und damit zur Selbstverständlichkeit. Wir werden staunen und dann wird es eine Selbstverständlichkeit, was so alles passiert. Und perfiderweise hat er folgendes Beispiel hier. Sehr schnell gehen wir vom Staunen darüber, dass KI einen schön geschriebenen Absatz generieren kann, zur Frage über, wann sie einen schön geschriebenen Roman generieren kann. Und wir wissen, die Schauspielerei ist insbesondere davon abhängig, dass dort Menschen zu sehen sind. Wir haben nur noch nicht diese Segewohnheit. Jetzt kommen natürlich so Menschen, die wirklich unverwechselbar sind. Nur auch beim Panda im Podcast wahnsinnig interessant. Wir hatten schon mal eine Zeit, in der man über Politiker alles behaupten konnte, weil Text gegen Text argumentiert hat. Und dann war irgendwann klar, wir brauchen Autoritäten, bei denen klar ist, die New York Times hat es geschrieben. Also scheint es wahr zu sein. Und jetzt kommen wir in diese Zeit, wo dasselbe noch mal mit dem Bild passiert. Und wir denken aber, wow, das ist ja völlig neu. Wir haben Bilder, die wir noch nie zuvor gesehen haben. Ja, ja, wir haben auch jahrhundertelang Texte gehabt, bei denen wir das Problem lösen mussten. Und das fand ich auch sehr instruktiv, das wäre eigentlich jetzt wieder in so einem Zeitalter, der ja, ja, wir brauchen jetzt eine Autorität. Einfach nur ein Bild zu sehen reicht halt nicht. Also in der Ansicht, Sam Altman denkt das hier auch nicht ganz zu Ende. Naja, geht das dann so durch? Wirtschaft und Wohlstand, wissenschaftlicher Fortschritt, ein neuer Gesellschaftsvertrag muss natürlich geschrieben werden, der ganze Kram. Arbeitsmarkt. Es wird sehr schwierige Teile geben, wie ganze Berufsklassen, die wegfallen. Noch haben wir ja immer diese Empfehlung, wer doch Fliesenleger, das ist safe und so. Für das einzelne Fliesenlegen würde ich sagen, ja stimmt irgendwie, aber für das ganze Haus konzipieren, in dem dann auch Fliesen legen, würde ich auch wieder sagen, ja, da muss man dann wirklich mal gucken, inwieweit diese körperlichen Restarbeiten, die noch übrig geblieben sind, in so einem Gesamtkonzept neuer Produktionswege dann vielleicht doch aussortiert wird.
Wie meinst du das?
Naja, bislang haben wir ja so einen Drang zu, okay, wer der Handwerker? Die werden immer gebraucht, wird von der KI nicht ersetzt.
Ja.
Und für das einzelne Gewerk stimmt das. Aber typischerweise findet ja ein Gewerk immer Raum in einem größeren Konstrukt, wie ein Hausbau oder so. Und wenn man sich da Gedanken darüber macht, wie man das eigentlich mit KI-Unterstützung, wenn die Hopper dann einmal soweit sind, macht, fällt das einzelne Gewerk dann doch wieder raus. Oder allenfalls in den Reparaturbetrieb. Aber nicht in den Hausbau.
Aber das würde ja dann bedeuten, dass die Roboter zum Beispiel Küchen herstellen, Fliesen legen, streichen. Also was soll das? Ich stelle mir mal vor, wie die Roboter aussehen sollen und wie teuer sie sind, um das zu machen. Also das ist ja, wenn man jetzt sich heute ansieht, was Gerätschaften auf dem Bau kosten, mit denen man irgendwas macht, dann ist man direkt in den Tausenden drin und denkt, ja, aber das ist doch eigentlich nur ein Heizlüfter oder was weiß ich, ja. Da sind wir also schon bei oberenten Summen. Was sollen das für Roboter sein, die solche Allrounder sind, bei denen man sagen kann, ich hätte gern ein neues Bad, ChatGPT, mach mir mal ein Bad, das die und die Ansprüche hat. Und dann wird das umgesetzt von Robotern. Also was soll das für eine Roboterwelt sein?
Also bei der Renovation eines Bades würde ich das auch so sehen. Wobei man nie weiß, ob jetzt doch jemand auf so eine humanoide Idee kommt und dann wird der Mensch einfach ausgetauscht. Aber das glaube ich weniger. Ich glaube auch, es werden mehr so ganze Prozesse, ganze Abläufe einfach umgemodelt. Also dass man wirklich auch einen Hausbau in einer Fabrik. Und dann wird es halt geliefert.
Also was es jetzt zum Beispiel schon gibt, sind ja Dachkonstruktionen. Also das Dächer ist so ziemlich fertig. Oder dass es zwei, drei einzelne Teile sind, die müssen dann mit einem Schwertransporter gebracht werden. Und dann wird das aufgesetzt. Und dann ist das ist das in dem Sinne fertig.
Da fallen aber fünf Gewerke wirklich raus.
Ja, aber das wird dann vorher gedeckt und gemacht und getan. Und da.
Aber in einer anderen Umgebung, also da, wo du tatsächlich in Fabriken, an Kränen und so weiter an Ort und Stelle. Also wenn du immer am selben Ort baust, würde ein Haus anders gebaut werden.
Dann musst du natürlich so ein Plattformhaus haben, mit dem du das so machen kannst.
Und dann mal gucken, wie weit man es modular treiben kann. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt gesehen, das iPhone wurde extrem effektiv und immer besser und leistungsstärker, aber modular wurde es nie. Also in deren Sicht, hier hat man immer noch Chinesen, die das so zusammenschrauben.
Das Botea Gaibits modulares Bauen, das hatte sie ja beobachtet.
Das gibt es auch in vielen Orten und das ist ja vielversprechend. Muss man halt ein bisschen abweichen von seinen eigenen Wünschen, sondern da ist dann halt so ein bisschen Katalog angesagt.
Menschlicher, aber ist ja sowieso auf fast allen Ebenen. Also wenn du jetzt nicht deine Traumvilla für ein paar Millionen baust, würde ich sagen, sind es Häuser, Häuser.
Wir kommen ja auch in die finanziellen Regionen, wo es einfach nur noch heißt, egal wie, Hauptsache, ich lebe noch, während ich mal irgendwo einziehe. Die Rolle des Menschen. Also ganze Berufsklassen stehen zur Disposition, aber die Ideengeber stehen kurz davor, ihre große Zeit zu haben. Und das stelle ich bei mir auch schon fest, ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich so eine Idee habe für meine Webseite, wie was dargestellt werden kann. Weiß ich ja, ich brauchte nur die entsprechenden Zeilen Code dafür. So und die kriege ich mittlerweile rausgepromptet. Ich leide dann zwar sehr unter Effektivitätsverlusten beim Betreiben dieser Webseite, weil ich da so viel Kram reinbaue, dass es dann eine Minute braucht zum Laden. Aber das sind ja alles Filet-Fans-Geschichten. Aber das finde ich eigentlich interessant. Umso mehr KI wir haben, umso mehr kommt auch so ein nächster Jahrgang in so ein, ja, mach's doch einfach so. Und da sich eben eher hauptsächlich auf dem Smartphone abspielt und man hat so eine App-Idee oder braucht hier irgendeine Verfeinerung oder so, mach's doch einfach. Also dass Apple da noch nicht so hinterherkommt, die Kurzbefehle, die ja schon da sind, also das Handy wirklich so auf Schnittstellen der Programmeebene zu bedienen, dass man das mal mit KI unterstützt, einfach aufbaut und mir Handy einfach nur noch sagt, brauche morgen die und die App, mach denen den Ablauf und dann macht es das einfach. Also da würde ich auch sagen, dafür ist alles da. Da muss nur noch so ein paar Produktentscheidungen getroffen werden.
Die Frage ist dann, glaubst du, dass sich das durchsetzen wird in der Masse? Also dass du das dann angehst, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, aber wir werden das andere angehen. Wir hatten ja jetzt bei der regulären Folge mal kurz darüber gesprochen. Ich habe gesagt, geh mal raus, frag mal jemanden, ob der ChatGPT Perplexity oder Claude benutzt, und du wirst keine Antwort erhalten. Und ich habe es dann doch auch wieder so mitbekommen im näheren Umfeld bei Leuten, die nicht alt sind, also bei Leuten, die Mitte 20 sind und die zum Beispiel immer noch googeln und Perplexity noch nicht kannten.
Ja, also das kommt vor für die Leute, für sehr viele Leute, ein Grundbegriff, eine Alternative für Routine ist. Das ist ja ein Wunder, das mich einfach immer beeindruckt. Während ich einfach denke, nee, die Vereinfachung, die Rationalisierung, die Beschleunigung, aber nein, Leute fühlen sich in ihrer Komfortzone mit einfach Routine. Und selbst wenn du es ihnen zeigst, wie einfach es ist und sei es nur bei einem Spieleabend, wir müssen nicht in die Anleitung gucken, wir fragen einfach GPT. Nein, auch nach der Präsentation, wie gut die Frage beantwortet wird und zwar genau die, die man gestellt hat, schaut man danach, blättert weiter durch die Anleitung.
Also mich fragt zum Beispiel ein 24-Jähriger, wie man eine Rechnung schreibt und ich denke mir, so was. Brauchst du eine Rechnung, dann sagt das ChatGPT.
Gib ihm alle kurzen Hinweise.
So, ja. Das fand ich interessant, dass mir die Frage gestellt wird.
Ja, es kommt halt auch wirklich drauf an, wie oft man so Rechnung schreibt, wenn es nur mal eine ist, klar, denkt man nicht.
Ja, also ich kann die Frage vor zwei Jahren auch nachvollziehen, dass mir die gestellt wird, aber jetzt dachte ich, dass man einfach routinemäßig, das bei ChatGPT macht.
Ja, wer weiß, wer weiß. Sein Fokus hier ist auch, Menschen haben einen langfristig wichtigen und merkwürdigen Vorteil gegenüber KI. Wir sind fest verdrahtet, uns um andere Menschen zu kümmern. Steckt in unserem Gen, offenbar. Und wir kümmern uns nicht sehr um Maschinen. Also es könnte, bin ich ja eh, also das glaube ich auch so ein bisschen, es wird sich so humane Nischen finden, die persönliche Fotografie, der Film, wie auch immer. So ein Podcast wird immer ein persönliches Medium bleiben. Das erleben wir auch schon beim Zugfahren oder Busfahren. Der Busfahrer ist offenbar nicht nur fürs Auto, also fürs Fahren zuständig, sondern auch für alle Anwesenden als Signal, da ist ein Mensch und so weiter und so fort. Also da werden sich wohl Nischen aufbilden. Mal sehen, wir werden sehr viel wunderbare Dinge füreinander bauen, sagt er. Alles sehr unkonkret. Ich habe keinen Zweifel daran, dass zukünftige Jobs sich für die Menschen, die sie ausüben, unglaublich wichtig und befriedigend anfühlen werden. Und daran wage ich kaum zu glauben. Das gab es bisher noch nie. Und wir haben ja schon einen technischen Fortschritt, der uns erlaubt hat. Die Mama kann jetzt auch mal raus aus der Küche, der Geschirrspieler macht die Arbeit. Nein, die Mama steht weiterhin in der Küche und alles ist wie bisher. Also da auch große Skepsis angefragt. Die Gesellschaft ist widerstandsfähig und kreativ. Menschen können sich nämlich an alles anpassen. Diesen Satz würde ich sehr negativ auslegen. Er sagt hier, finde ich sehr interessant, ausdrücklich, wir hatten ja schon bisher technische Innovationen, Social Media Feeds sind ein Beispiel für fehl ausgerichtete KI. Also das eine Silicon Valley haut jetzt das andere Silicon Valley in die Tonne. Wahrscheinlich, Meta versucht ja jetzt beides, so vom Social ins KI-Ding überzugehen wird wahrscheinlich. Also funktioniert ja schon relativ schlecht, muss man sagen. Naja, Lösungsstrategien, das Alignment-Problem technisch und gesellschaftlich lösen. Also da sind wir so weit entfernt von irgendwelchen politischen Diskussionen. Wir sehen ja, mit was Robin Alexander sich da umschlägt. Also dass da mal irgendwer eine KI und Alignment und überhaupt Diskussionen führt oder eine Arbeitsmarkt-Politische oder was auch immer so Bildung. Also das ist ja wirklich ausgeschlossen. Aber die Superintelligenz wird billig sein, sehr breit verfügbar. Und wir werden uns daran gewöhnen, so wie wir uns daran gewöhnt haben, dass auf der Straße Leute telefonieren und keine Selbstgespräche führen. Dass sie einfach mit KI reden die ganze Zeit. Und wer das dann auch erredet kann mit seiner KI. Lass mich mal machen so. Wir dürfen die gerade nicht stören. Also in deren Sicht ist er hier sehr froh, gemüt. Und ich denke mir fast nichts davon wird ausgehen. Ich kann mir das einfach nicht vorstellen.
Das ist gut, dass du das jetzt noch mal deutlichst hast, weil wir manchmal E-Mails bekommen, die dich offenbar nicht so ganz richtig verstehen dann. Also manchmal, wenn du was, also nicht jede Position, die du hier wiedergibst, ist exakt deine Position. Also du bist manchmal sehr optimistisch, würde ich auch sagen. Ich bin da eher skeptisch unterwegs, was KI Innovation anbelangt. Aber du stellst ja oft auch einfach Positionen vor wie jetzt zum Beispiel diese. Das bedeutet aber nicht, dass du sagst, ja Sam Altman ist mein neuer Gott und der sagt mir, was jetzt bald kommt.
Der Abschlusssatz hier ist einfach, mögen wir reibungslos, exponentiell und ereignislos durch die Superintelligenz skalieren. Ist natürlich so ein Silicon Valley Satz. Nur er hat ja selber gerade markiert, wir Menschen sind nicht gut im Umgang mit Maschinen, sondern wir möchten uns um uns kümmern. Und wir sehen ja gerade, wie sich Menschen um Menschen kümmern. Also, der eine räumt für den anderen die Ausländer aus dem Land raus, der eine organisiert die Flüge für seine Partygäste nach Venedig. Menschen werden sich immer um Menschen kümmern. Und diese KI Sachen, die er hier, also wenn er einfach sagt, er werbt jetzt hier so und die Maschinen machen das dann alles selbst, da fallen ja offensichtlich produktive Gewinne ab, die dazu führen, dass einige Menschen sich noch mehr um ihre Menschen kümmern können und andere ja aussortiert werden. Also jetzt werden gerade Mitarbeiter aus Ländern aussortiert, aufgrund ideologischer Verbrellung. Als nächstes in fünf Jahren haben wir einen demokratischen Präsidenten, der sagt, it's economy stupid. Und dann werden halt wieder Menschen aussortiert, aus dem Arbeitsmarkt. Ja, wohin denn eigentlich? Gehen die dann auch alle nach Alcatraz Alligator oder so? Also in der Hinsicht, wir haben jetzt schon mit sehr vielen Texten zu tun, in denen sehr viel versucht wird, so chronologisch einfach, ich denke mir mal was aus. Aber das Nachdenken findet hier nicht so richtig statt. Und da ist Sam Altman, und da kann man auch nicht wieder das Wort Perfidie einbringen. Er hat ja was davon, uns das so zu verherrlichen. Ja. Nicht gut.
Kommen wir zu jemanden, der mehr nachdenken möchte. Juan S. Guse ist Schriftsteller und legt mit seinem Buch 1000 Mal so viel Geld wie jetzt erschienen bei S. Fischer ein Buch vor, das ja es so noch nicht gegeben hat. Wir kennen ja viele Bücher, die uns erklären, wie man in Kryptowährungen investiert. Wir haben hier im Salon sehr ausführlich über das Buch von Ijoma Mangold gesprochen. Dieses Buch verherrlichte den Bitcoin und die anderen Kryptowährungen. Sprach die ganze Zeit von einer Jugendbewegung. Und wir dachten die ganze Zeit, wo ist da die Bewegung in dem Ganzen? Wo tun sich da Menschen wirklich zusammen? Ist es nicht eher eine Art der Vereinzelung? Und ja, eine Vereinzelung können wir auf jeden Fall hier beobachten, in dem was Juan S. Guse uns zeigt. Er hat sich mit Krypto-Millionären getroffen, mit Menschen, die aber gar nicht so sehr nur in den Bitcoin investiert sind oder kaum in den Bitcoin investiert sind, sondern in Tokens, in andere Blockchain-Modelle. Wir bekommen so ein paar Dinge erklärt oder in Ansätzen erklärt, was es da noch so alles gibt und wie die irgendwie reich geworden sind. Aber dieses Buch hat einen Reportagesstil mitunter, wird dann aber auch wiederum sehr literarisch, geht mitunter ins Surreale über. Es ist ein Buch, das danach sucht, was bedeuten eigentlich diese Krypto-Karrieren für uns heute? Was können wir darüber hinaus ableiten? Das Buch beginnt mit Basti, der auf einem Friedhof eine Schubkarre schiebt. Er arbeitet dort, er jobbt dort. Er müsste dort nicht sein, aber wenigstens ist dort einmal kurz Ruhe. Wenn er zurückkehrt in seine Zwei-Zimmer-Wohnung, geht es nur weiter. Geht es darum, 30.000 Euro am Tag zu verdienen. Denn im Hintergrund rattern die Maschinen. Er ist überall investiert. Seine Karriere ist eine, die damit beginnt, dass er Hanf überall anbaut, dann Marihuana vertickt, das auf eine Weise tut, die wirklich sehr kreativ ist. Er geht nämlich irgendwo in öffentliche Räume und baut überall was an, muss dann aber auch in Trockenzeiten sehen, dass er mit der Gießkanne dann noch hinkommt und macht dann so einen ersten Reibach. Irgendwann wird ihm das aber auch alles so prensig, dass er sagt, gut, ich nehme jetzt das Geld und investiere.
Der baut in der Ecke so ein kleines Pflänzchen an und…
Ja, ja, wohl auch größer. Also das wurde hier so… also der ist natürlich alles anonymen gehalten, wird dann geschildert, dass er den ausfindig macht und der also so ein Startkapital hat und dann in dieses Krypto-Geschehen reinkommt. Ja, und dann irgendwann 1.000 Mal so viel Geld wie jetzt hat und dann sich auch fragt, wie ist denn das jetzt eigentlich? Also darum geht es immer wieder in diesem Buch. Wie geht man eigentlich damit um, wenn man einen solchen Klassensprung auf einmal hinlegt mit diesen Krypto-Investments und dass das ja auch eine neue Form der Karriere ist. Also ohne Kontakte, ohne Insiderwissen, ohne ein MBA zu haben, ist man plötzlich da für jemanden etwas. Man kann sich alles Mögliche kaufen. Man kann sagen, ich hätte gerne mal 10 Airpods, iPods oder was auch immer. Es ist alles dann nicht mehr relevant. Zugleich aber geht es jetzt Juan Guse nicht darum, zu zeigen, das sind hier Self-Made-Millionäre wie Toll, so Hoss und Hopf mäßig. Sondern er zeigt Leute, die eigentlich sehr verunsichert sind, was sie mit ihrem Geld tun sollen, die nicht so richtig wissen, was damit eigentlich zu machen ist, die auch in diesem Rabbit Hole drin waren, Krypto oder immer noch sind. Aber was bedeutet das eigentlich für sie? Es ist eine große Perspektivlosigkeit, bei ihnen zu sehen, so eine Ahnungslosigkeit. Einen trifft der, der auch so merkwürdige Männlichkeitsfantasien und sowas haben. Also das sind nicht alle. Also die Sebastian ist so politisch nicht verdächtig, sondern eigentlich ein ordentlicher Kerl. Der andere dann schon merkwürdiger. Mit dem geht er auch klettern. Da muss ich sagen, das ist die einzige Passage, die ich nicht besonders raffiniert finde, auch wenn sie raffiniert sein will. Er geht also klettern mit dem, Mann, ich zeige dir das mal hier. Und dann sind so etwa 40 Seiten fast ganz leer. Und da stehen dann immer nur so einzelne Sätze oder Worte drauf, die sie sich beim Klettern zurufen. Fuck, ist das heiß hier oben. Mach mal zu, ich kann nicht mehr. Sorry, okay, ich mach weiter. Seil.
Aber das ist doch ansonsten jetzt kein kreativ gestaltetes Buch?
Doch, es ist ein Buch, das nämlich auch reflektiert, dass der Autor 2.000 Euro in OHM investiert. Das ist auch so ein Token-Blockchain-Ding, sehr zu kompliziert zu erklären, aber da steht es auch ehrlich gesagt nicht richtig. Und dieser aber verliert und sich die ganze Zeit denkt, okay, ich habe jetzt so einen Vorschuss vom Verlag bekommen, um das Buch zu schreiben. Aber die verdienen ja so unendlich viel Geld. Und natürlich ist das hier so ein Spiel damit, ich mache jetzt mal fast leere Seiten, dann habe ich schon wieder 40 Seiten geschafft. Aber ehrlich gesagt, ist das so eine Poate, die ich jetzt nicht so besonders raffiniert finde. Interessanter ist dann wirklich, wenn er überlegt, was bedeutet das eigentlich, dieser ganze Krypto-Hype? Wenn er sagt, solche Enttäuschungen können als fast generalisierte Erfahrung jener Kohorte in Industrie- und Schwellenländern gelten, die üblicherweise als Millennials verklappt werden. Obwohl sie und auch die Menschen nach ihnen im Schnitt besser ausgebildet sind als ihre Eltern, obwohl die Wirtschaft, in der sie arbeiten, mutmaßlich produktiver geworden ist, stehen sie finanziell in allen Metriken schlechter da, ziehen später zu Hause aus, haben weniger Geld bei gestiegenen Kosten für alles, müssen sich mehr verschulden, um Wohneigentum zu erwerben und so weiter. Insert my parents at 30 vs. me at 30 meme. Das ist nicht unwichtig, wenn man verstehen will, warum primär U40 Menschen sich für Krypto und andere alternative Methoden der Vermögensbildung interessieren, die Online-Coaches und Krifter bewerben, weil die Pfade der Eltern nicht mehr zu funktionieren scheint. Dazu gibt es eine Geschichte. Also es geht jetzt darum, was die sich dann immer so dagegen erzählen. Zwei Männer laufen durch den Wald. Dann taucht ein Bär auf. Der Bär ist der Kollaps der Wirtschaft. Einer der beiden Männer beugt sich runter, um sich die Schnürsenkel zu binden. Der andere sagt, warum bindest du dir die Schuhe? Du wirst niemals schneller als der Bär sein. Woraufhin der andere immer antwortet, ich muss nicht schneller als der Bär sein, ich muss nur schneller sein als du. Und dann, schreibt jetzt Guse, man wundert einen dieser finanziellen Nihilismus nicht. Es wundert einen nicht, wenn Leute wie Arne sagen, man komme zu nichts, wenn man nur mitschwimme. Es reicht heute einfach nicht mehr, sein Geld mittelfristig zu verdreifachen, zu vervierfachen. So könne man nicht Schritt halten mit der Teuerung aller Dinge und der sich beschleunigen Konzentrierung vom Kapital. Dann wundert es einen nicht, dass Menschen unter 40 bei Krypto-Sportwetten und Meme-Stalks hellhörig werden, weil sie darin etwas wittern, nämlich die ersehnte, notwendig erscheinende Verhundertfachung ihres Vermögens, die große 100x-Wette als Last-Ditch-Effort, um auszusorgen, um sorgenfrei zu leben, bis sie unter die Erde kommen. Das Problem ist, dass es nicht nur ein Bär ist, sondern Hunderte. Also eine Diagnose, die wir, glaube ich, so teilen würden. Er versucht, sich eigentlich so erzählerisch denen anzunähern. Und vielleicht sind diese einzelnen Kapitel auch so mehr als literarische Erzählungen wieder zu verstehen, dann nur als Reportagen. Er wird aber dann sehr reportagehaft, und das finde ich eigentlich ist auch so das Stärkste in diesem Buch, wenn er nach Barcelona fliegt, um dort so eine Kryptokonferenz zu besuchen. Und er betritt dann das dort und sagt, es wirkt nicht wie der erste Tag von etwas, sondern schien, als wären diese Menschen schon immer hier gewesen und ich nur der letzte Besucher, ein geduldeter Gast in hellblauem C&A-Hemd. Den größten Stand betrieb Chainlink, der Veranstalter mit einem alles überragenden Turm, an dessen Spitze eine Banderole aus Bildschirmen hing, durch die aktuelle Marktdatenrauschen. Dem morgendlichen Menschenstrom folgend, ging ich als erstes zur Hauptbühne, einem Auditorium mit 2000 Sitzplätzen, kolossaler LED-Wall und einer Lichttechnik, die Träume bei vollem Bewusstsein erzeugen konnte. Auf der weitläufigen Bühne lagen weiße geometrische Formen verteilt, als wären sie aus dem Himmel gefallen. Sie verliehen der Bühne etwas Landschaftliches. Wenn Vortragende sie betraten und sich zwischen den Formen bewegten, sahen sie aus wie Reisende in einem Theaterstück. Das Sprechen dieser Reisenden richtete sich aber nicht an mich. Es waren Worte der Eingeweihten. Enable stylus for orbit chain. Deploy nitro technology. Customize your L3 roll-up. Any trust. Display your orbit chain. Arp Gurley. Arp Sepoli. Man sprach zu den Devs, die angeblich im Publikum saßen. Kleinanlegern wie mir. Ich hatte mich nach Dänemark dazu überredet, Link im Wert von 1000 Euro zu kaufen, in heimlicher Erwartung, dass der Preis des Tokens nach der Messe steigen würde. Wurde hier allenfalls eine Botschaft gesendet. Wir sind immer noch da. Wir arbeiten unermüdlich. In diesem Vibe der Vorbereitung auf eine erwartete Zukunft war einmal ein Wort zentral. Onramping. Gemeint war das Bereitstellen einer technosozialen Rampe zwischen zwei Welten, zwischen drinnen und draußen, zwischen uns und den anderen. Eine Rampe, über die man Boomer, Normies und die von ihnen besetzten Institutionen führen wollte, um sie davon zu überzeugen, die kryptographischen Buchhaltungstechnologie, Blockchain in ihrer Alltagsrealität zu implementieren. Das war und ist der finale Baustein im großen Plan dieser Industrie. Das Vertrauen unserer Eltern. Er beschreibt dann das immer weiter, wie man versucht, mit irgendwelchen Technologien, also vor allem dann durch Chainlink, die analoge mit der digitalen Welt zusammenzuwinden. Denn die Blockchain muss ja auch wissen von dieser analogen Welt. Und was er hier immer so aufruft, ist, dieser unglaubliche Fortschrittsgeist, der da drin steckt. Dieser Wunsch, okay, hier kann wirklich nochmal das große Rad getreten werden. Wir alle merken ja jetzt so, das große Rad dreht sich ja sonst so eher nicht. Das ist ja unsere Diagnose heute mehrmals schon gewesen.
Ein bisschen Mysterium einfach.
Ja und hier gibt es noch einmal so die Hoffnung darauf, weshalb das auch alles so verlockend ist, wenn wirklich Leute auf der Bühne stehen und dem Publikum zurufen, we need guys like you. Er erzählt dann von Sebastian, dem Sohn eines Supermarktbesitzers in Rosario im Norden Argentiniens geboren. Der hat mal für 10 US-Dollar das Stück 250 Bitcoins gekauft und dann findet er sie nicht mehr. Viele Jahre seines Lebens habe er mit sich gerungen wegen dieses fahrlässigen Fehlers, der ihm mit jenem Monat unverzeihlich erschien. Einen solchen Hass habe er auf sich selbst entwickelt, so selbstzerstörerisch und dunkel, dass er in Therapie gegangen sei. Daraufhin habe er Rosario verlassen und sei nach Buenos Aires gezogen, um erst Lehramt und dann Dingoistik an der UBA zu studieren, an der er später eine Promotionsstelle bekam. Für eine Dissertation über State-of-the-Art-theoretische Fragen der Konstruktionsgrammatik. Bis er eines Winters mal wieder im Haus seiner Eltern zu Gast war und die Heizung kaputt ging. Und als er und sein Vater den undichten Heizkörper ausbauen wollten, da sei er auf einmal rausgefallen. Der USB-Stick. Er habe ihn sofort wiedererkannt und geschrien wie ein Verfolgter. Er habe nicht auf die Worte seines Vaters reagiert, der es mit der Angst zu tun bekam. So weit weg schien ihm sein Sohn auf einmal. Das sei vor drei Jahren gewesen. Der Kurs bei 50.000. Seitdem sei Sebastian unterwegs, fast das ganze Jahr über reise er von einem internationalen Krypto-Event zum nächsten. Also das sind diese Geschichten. Ich finde, dass das Buch eine gute Annäherung an diese Welt bringt, weil es immer auch darüber hinausweist, auch das Schreiben so mitreflektiert. Es geht um die Frage, wenn jetzt alles verifiziert werden soll, braucht man dann kein Vertrauen mehr? Na ja, man braucht ja dann wieder ein Vertrauen in diese Verifizierungstools. Und dann schreibt er, wie sie mir auch vertrauen müssen, dass sie mir jetzt gerade glauben, dass ich den wirklich getroffen habe, mit dem gesprochen habe. Also es wird auch das Literarische dann manchmal so eng gekoppelt. Es wird auch gezeigt, wie ideologisch heterogen das alles ist. Es geht dann um Meleigh, der ist ja gegen Schwangerschaftsabbrüche. Und dann fragt er auch einen, ja, weil das passt doch alles nicht zusammen. Der ist doch sonst für totale Freiheit und sowas. Ja, und dann heißt es einfach, das fände er auch unlogisch. Aber wegen solchen Fragen würde man Meleigh nicht wählen, sondern wegen der Geldpolitik, wegen der Wirtschaft, wegen der gottverdammten Inflation. Das waren seine Worte. Und ich konnte sie nur nehmen, als das, was sie waren. Und du kannst sie nur lesen, als das, was ich schreibe. Die Ratlosigkeit bei dem Ganzen bleibt. Es ist eine Annäherung an die Krypto-Szene. Eine literarische, die aber auch das analytische immer wieder herausplitzen lässt. Aber es ist jetzt nicht eine soziologische Studie oder sonst etwas. Wer also da sich mit diesen Sleepern, wie sie genannt werden, also mit denen, die im Stillen sehr reich geworden sind, beschäftigen will, kann hier diese Charaktere wiederfinden. Ich finde dieses erste Kapitel mit Bastian sehr gut. Ich finde den Beitrag mit der Kryptokonferenz auch sehr lesenswert und sehr schön, weil es, wie schon gesagt, in Surreale kippt. Ich halte diese große Kletter-Episode da, wo uns, ich glaube, Arne Heister vorgestellt wird, für ein bisschen sehr gespreizt und dann auch nicht besonders ergiebig. Eher habe ich wieder den Eindruck, dass hier das so ein bisschen ein Trick und ein Scam zu machen, also in Form eines Buchs. Ich habe jetzt hier ein Buch, das sind 180 Seiten, aber 35 Seiten sind fast leer. Fand ich jetzt als Proante nicht so ganz weit tragend.
Ja, ein bisschen komisch. Hier in Frankfurt ist am Wochenende auch so eine Konferenz. Philipp Hopf und so sind anwesend. Auf dem Werbebild sind irgendwie so 30 Köpfe, die Hälfte davon kennt man so ein bisschen aus dem Internet. Es wird über Cash, also die Konferenz heißt Cash Flow, weil wir wissen, da wird es wahrscheinlich auch viel über Krypto gehen.
Ja, Stefan, das ist deine Gelegenheit und du?
Genau, ich kann nicht.
Und verpasst sie jetzt wieder.
Wir weisen immer wieder drauf.
Normie.
Genau, ich Normie. Wir haben diesen Sachstand jetzt nur bei Bitcoin, aber das wird ja für viele andere auch gelten. 90 Prozent des ganzen Wertes steckt bei drei Prozent der Leuten und der Rest ist einfach nur, hoffentlich bringen genug Leute ihre Euros und Dollars mit, um eben für den einen oder die andere, aber sind schon auf dem Buchrücken, habe ich gerade gesehen, steht ja nur von Männern, ist nur von Männern.
Ja, ja, nur Männer, nur Männer und auch genau das als Thema immer wieder, dass dann, also er trifft dann den einen, der sagt ihm dann, also das, das ist auf jeden Fall. Dann erzählt er dem nächsten davon, nee, also kannst du völlig vergessen, hier das. Und dann kommt einer und sagt, nee, eigentlich kann man nur in den Bitcoin investieren.
Das ist, es hat sowas Religiöses.
Und ja, und es ist aber viel Gürterei. Also die Krypto-Szene trifft sich da und das sind so Messen, die dann da gefeiert werden. Aber jeder selbst hat noch mal so eine Privatreligion gesagt, nee, also ich mache nur noch die Tokets. Ich mache nur noch Ethereum.
Nur noch Solanus.
Und ich sage, ich muss ganz in die Infrastruktur investieren. Die Coins an sich sind egal.
Genau. Ja, der einzige Gewinner aus der ganzen Szene ist Donald Trump. Aber der hat halt auch was zu verkaufen. Apropos, Donald Trump. Trump can't escape political gravity. Also die Schwerkraft wirkt, sagen drei Autoren der New York Times, wobei Frank Bruni wohl ein bisschen fester dort ist. Und Kristin, Soltis Anderson und Nate Silver zum Gespräch eingeladen wurden. Nate Silver macht gar nicht mehr dieses 538 oder so, sondern der hat jetzt ein Buch geschrieben on the edge und hat ein Newsletter, Silver Bulletin Newsletter. Und die reden über die Umfragewerte, die sind ja sozusagen drei Experten in Sachen Umfrage. Wie steht es jetzt um Trump? Und da können wir im Anschluss an Robin Alexander Mertz auch einiges für uns draus lernen, denn die Themen sind ja so ungefähr dieselben. Also Trump kam ins Amt und dann kam es beim Rückgang der Zustimmungswerte, weil man hat so wieder gesehen, okay, dieses Chaos und so weiter, fand es nicht gut. Und jetzt ist es aber zwischenzeitlich wieder ein bisschen gestiegen. Er hat sich jetzt irgendwie so normalisiert auf so einen 45% Zustimmung, 51% Ablehnung. Die sagen schon, naja, in so einer komischen Lage ist das 40% das neue 50. Also steht irgendwie solide da. Aber Nate Silver sagt auch, besorgt sollte er sein. Er glaubt aber noch nicht, dass er schon in einer Todesspirale ist. Da fragen wir uns, warte mal, hieß es nicht gerade noch, safe und jetzt plötzlich Todesspirale. Also das hat dann mit thematischer Spreizung zu tun. Trump ist beim Thema Wirtschaft. Das ist ja nun, das ist ja bei März betont, da ist nichts außer ein Nimbus. Und so ist das hier so ein bisschen auch. Also er kam mit diesem Nimbus, ein Mann aus der Wirtschaft, auch beim zweiten Mal. Aber beim Thema Wirtschaft allgemein 13% Unterwasser, Handel 15%, Inflation sogar 27%. Und wenn man gemerkt, wie viel Inflation bedeutet, ist ja ein unmittelbares Erleben im Supermarkt. Wo dann auch, wenn Politiker zu sehr dagegen anargumentieren, aber die Wirtschaft allgemein oder irgendwas und so, dann ist das nur ein Einfallstor für, seht ihr die Lügen und so. Also das droht hier Trump auch. Kaufkraft der Amerikaner ist großes Problem, kriegt man nicht schön geredet. Und er hat sich da wohl auch ein strategisches Eigentor geschossen. Denn die haben ja selber Inflation zu einem ganz wichtigen Einzelthema im Wahlkampf gemacht. Und dann direkt zum Amtseintritt dieses Zolltheater einfach aufgeführt. Also in der Sicht muss man sich da wenig wundern, wenn man da Wahlkampfleiter ist. Einwanderung ist ein überraschend gutes Thema für Trump, denn die Leute wollen jetzt einen handelnden Staat sehen. Und wenn sie so Lager sehen, wie dieses Alligator Alcatraz, dann denken sie wohl, also das ziehen sie da so qualitativ in diesem Gespräch hier raus. Ja, wir sind ja bislang zu gut mit den Migranten umgegangen. Jetzt dürfen wir auch mal ein bisschen über die Stränge schlagen. So, man redet sich das so schön. Aber es gibt halt so eine Entkopplung aus Preisgestaltung im Supermarkt. Und wie läuft es eigentlich bei der Ernte, wenn da keiner mehr ist? Also das wird noch nicht so zusammengebunden. Man will da erst mal nur einen handelnden Staat sehen. Das ist sowieso ein großes Thema, dadurch dass es auf beiden folgte, dass man das Chaos selbst als Indikator für den starken, stabilitätssuchenden Staat sieht. Hauptsache, es wird was gemacht, egal was. Nicht noch mal ein Wahlkampf aus der Corona-Kältekammer im Keller mit einem Präsidenten, den man gar nicht einschätzen kann und danach einfach nur Expertokratie von irgendwelchen Leuten, die zur Pressekonferenzen geben, was sie wieder gemacht haben und so. Es wird hier von dem Bruni so ein bisschen beschrieben, wie dass die für die einen, die sagen halt, ich habe ihn jetzt erstmal gewählt, ich bin kein Migrant, also ist mir das egal, die sehen einen in den Staat. Die anderen befinden sich aber schon in einer übelkeiterregenden Achterbahnfahrt. Also da fallen die Lage auseinander. Was könnten die Demokraten jetzt irgendwie machen? Sie gehen da so ein bisschen durch. Die Peak Vogue-Ära von 2015 bis 2023 muss auch von den Demokraten nochmal hart beendet werden. Es reicht nicht, dass die Republikaner einfach sagen, seht ihr, ihr wart immer scheiße und so, sondern die Demokraten brauchen eine strategische Antwort darauf. Das wird ihnen natürlich schwer fallen, ist ja klar. Man muss unbedingt davon weg, dass man wie zuletzt dreimal in Folge einfach nur Kandidaten fürs Präsidentenamt nominierte, bei denen jeder wusste, das sind die Meister des Insiderspiels. Also das, was wir da in New York jetzt sehen, dass jemand kommt und sagt, ich will etwas ganz anders machen und sei es Supermärkte staatlich zu betreiben, plus ich bin U40, scheinen die Trümpfe zu sein. Ein handelnder Staat, der ein Angebot macht von jemandem, den man noch nicht kennt, hinter dem man sich aber so versammeln kann. Finde ich übrigens auch interessant, immer so als ich es gestern gelesen habe. Es gibt jetzt die große Diskussion, ist das nicht totaler Kommunismus, wenn ein Bürgermeister sagt, mein Wahlversprechen ist Supermärkte, die ich betreibe, weil ich dann Preiskontrolle habe. Im Vergleich dazu, real, jetzt schon, überweist, hat New York jetzt gerade wieder 925 Millionen Dollar an die Hotelbranche in New York City überwiesen, weil die Obdachlose unterbringen. Für 325 Dollar pro Nacht. Also während wir jetzt gerade so Nachrichtenmeldungen haben, wie keiner fährt mehr nach Amerika, Touristen, Flaute, nichts los und auch die Business-Leute sagen so langsam, ich habe keinen Bock mehr da einzureißen, wird die Hotelbranche einfach durchgepäppelt mit solchen Deals.
Unglaublich.
Das ist wirklich krass. Also da ist ein Supermarkt, wo man seine Milch für einen Dollar kauft, wirklich vergleichsweise fällt überhaupt nicht ins Gewicht. Na ja. Was könnte man noch vortragen? Ach ja, wer sind die größten Kontrahenten eines möglichen Herausforderers? JD Vance. Also wenn JD Vance das Amt verteidigt, dann nach Trumps Tod, wenn der Wahlkampf kommt. Alexandra Ocasio-Cortez. Wird hier von allen ganz hochgerankt. Sie scheint das Ding anzuführen. Platz zwei ist allerdings schon Bernie Sanders. Sie sagen aber ausdrücklich dazu, er müsste wirklich zehn Jahre jünger sein.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, wie kann denn das sein, dass sie überhaupt noch genannt wird?
Wenn du nur demoskopisch jetzt, also nicht strategisch, sondern nur demoskopisch zugehst, wäre es immer noch Bernie Sanders. Was ja bedeutet, die Radikalität von Bernie Sanders ist vorbildhaft. Für alle, die jetzt Wahlkampf machen. Also einfach nur aus dem Gouverneursitz mal kurz rüberfahren und eine Rallye oder so ist nicht, sondern da kann man schon richtig zulangen. Ja, fand ich ganz interessant. Ja, also die, ich würde sagen, ist es sehr augenscheinlich. Diese Kombi aus Wirtschaft und Migration ist das Thema, das auch journalistisch aufzuarbeiten ist, weil das Verhältnis dieser beiden Felder ungeklärt ist. Demoskopisch haben wir es hier wirklich mit zwei Lagern zu tun. Leute sind betrübt, wenn die Eierpreise so ein ganz klein bisschen spiken, aber wenn jemand Konzentrationslager oder sowas baut und sei es nur so Lagerbestände, wo wirklich nur Gitter statt Wände und so weiter alle dreifach gestapelt darum liegen, es kümmert sie demoskopisch kaum. Also das ist kein Game-Changer für irgendeine. Aber ich finde Trump jetzt doch nicht so gut. Mal gucken, wie das dann ist, wenn die Menschen da ankommen und diese Lager journalistisch begleitet werden. Aber dass Trump da extra hinfährt, Pressekonferenzen macht, das zeigt, und dann noch Witze darüber, wie man vor dem Krokodil flüchtet und so, finde ich, die scheinen die demoskopische Aufklärung auch bekommen zu haben. Dass sie das machen können und dass da Punktgewinne sind. Was mir für Hardliner im deutschen Innenministerium wie Dobrindt nichts Gutes sagt, weil der wird sich auch demoskopische Zahlen geben lassen.
Die in Belgrad geborene Barbi Marković und seit 2005 in Wien lebende Schriftstellerin hat ihre Poetikvorlesungen vorgelegt. Poetikvorlesungen sind in der Regel so, dass Schriftsteller eingeladen werden, offen zu legen in einer oder mehreren Vorlesungen, wie sie schreiben, was ihre Angehensweise ist, wie ihre Werke entstanden sind. Und erst einmal ist Barbi Marković auch guter Dinge. Wir haben es mit einem Buch zu tun, das als Countdown angelegt ist. Es beginnt damit, dass sie noch zwei Jahre Zeit hat, nämlich ruft sie da jemand an und fragt, möchtest du in zwei Jahren eine Poetik-Vorlesung halten? Und sie sagt, ja klar, zwei Jahre sind eine Ewigkeit. Das ist keine Frist, sondern ein Versprechen für die Zukunft. Schön zu wissen, dass ich nicht tot sein werde. Im Gegenteil, ich werde eine Poetik-Vorlesung halten. Bis dahin ist bestimmt alles besser. In zwei Jahren habe ich das kleine Horrorbuch auf jeden Fall fertig. Bis dahin bin ich gut organisiert und habe im Kopf viel Raum für neue Erkenntnisse. In zwei Jahren bin ich klüger und gebildeter. So denkt sie, ich werde auch einen Sixpack haben und ein Haus. Eigentlich wird alles ganz gut sein. Dann kann ich es schreiben. Ich sage auf jeden Fall zu. Nun gibt es dann gleich nach diesen euphorischen drei Seiten einen Bruch. Dann steht da nicht mehr noch zwei Jahre, sondern steht da noch 13 Tage. Sie hat gewartet bis auf den letzten Drücker und denkt, ach du Scheiße, ich muss ja noch diese Poetik-Vorlesung schreiben. Denn die Leute erwarten ja viel von mir. So habe ich es mir doch immer gedacht, dass das die Lesung sein wird. Und genau in diesem Countdown spielt sie auch mit diesem Spannungsbogen. Sie wird es schaffen, eine Poetik-Vorlesung zu halten. Und natürlich ist ein jedes Kapitel Teil der Poetik-Vorlesung. Also schreibt sie dann darüber, wie sie darüber nachdenkt, wie eine Poetik-Vorlesung aussehen könnte, wen sie damit enttäuschen würde, wenn sie das oder das sagt. Sie beginnt mit, ich sitze an meinem Schreibtisch und weiß nicht, was ich schreiben soll. Ich sitze in meinem Zimmer, sehe aus dem Fenster und warte auf die Inspiration. Ich schreibe den ersten Satz und lösche ihn wieder. Ich starre das Leereblatt Papier an. Wie soll ich beginnen? Und so geht sie dann erst einmal zurück in ihre Schulzeit, springt wieder nach vorne. Ich muss sagen, mir war der Name schon lange ein Begriff, Barbi Marković, aber bis heute, ich gestehe, habe ich noch nie einen Roman von ihr gelesen, habe das aber jetzt unbedingt vor. Denn es ist ein großartiges Buch hier, diese Poetik-Vorlesung. Also ihr viertes Buch ist das eben erwähnte Mini-Horror. Mit dem hat sie auch auf der Leipziger Buchmesse gewonnen. Da hat sie den Preis im März 2024 bekommen.
Sie hat 2009 mit Ausgehen ein Buch geschrieben, das ein Remix ist eines Textes von Thomas Bernhardt. Der Text von Thomas Bernhardt heißt Gehen. Sie schreibt über das Ausgehen, also in der Nacht, in Clubs usw. Da erklärt sich dann auch vielleicht der Titel dieser Poetikvorlesung, nämlich der Titel lautet Stehlen, Schimpfen, Spielen. Sie stiehlt Texte, nimmt also Thomas Bernhardt Remix das Ganze. Sie schimpft über die Zustände in Belgrad, die Zustände aber auch im Literaturbetrieb. Wenn sie nach so vielen Jahren, in denen sie auf Deutsch schreibt, immer noch gefragt wird, ist das eigentlich nicht ein großes Problem, wenn sie nicht in ihrer eigenen Sprache schreibt und sie sagt, nee, ich kann auch auf Deutsch schreiben. Sehen Sie doch. Und Spielen meint, dass sie auch schon einen Roman geschrieben hat, der sich an einem Spiel orientiert und diese Dramaturgie verfolgt. Und auch hier, ich zeige dir das kurz, wird sie einmal ein Spiel spielen, das ist wie so ein Super Mario Spiel. Und sie schreibt ab dann, was diese Figur jeweils macht. Sie springt irgendwo rauf, muss irgendwo rüber, muss einen Angreifer abwehren und das Besondere...
Hast du dich gefühlt, als würdest du selbst zum Handy greifen, während du eigentlich noch das Buch in der Hand hattest?
Ein bisschen. Aber es ist natürlich so eine Verschiebung, die da mit einhergeht, wenn sie plötzlich... Also man muss ja dann so... Also man bringt ja plötzlich Narration in was rein, was jetzt einfach nur so kompetitiv als Spiel ist. Und dadurch entsteht natürlich durch die Literatur was anderes. Ich will mal Beispiele lesen, wie sie so schreibt, denn es ist auch sehr amüsant. Sie ist in Wien natürlich am richtigen Ort, nämlich da kann man nicht nur Deutsch lernen, sondern die Wiener oder die Österreicher an sich haben natürlich noch mal ein ganz anderes Sprachbewusstsein. Und das Spielen mit der Sprache ist natürlich in der österreichischen Literatur viel stärker ausgeprägt als hier in Deutschland. Sie schreibt dann von ihrer Zeit in Belgrad noch, auch meine zu dem Zeitpunkt schon ehemaligen Kollegen aus dem Rendeverlag fanden, dass es Zeit war, so ein nicht geniales Werk in die Welt zu setzen. Also sie nimmt sich Thomas Bernhards Gehen und remixed die Sätze neu und fügt da die Club-Szene mit ein. Da ich die einzige Person im Verlag war, die ein wenig Deutsch konnte, warten sie mich, die rechte Lage zu klären. Wie im Comic Peanuts mit der Zunge im linken Mundwinkel schrieb ich die E-Mail auf dem Verlagscomputer. Ich versuchte einer gewissen Frau Hart, die für die Rechte an Thomas Bernhards Werk zuständig war, zu erklären, was ich gemacht hatte. Und zwar in meinem noch sehr schlechten Deutsch. Vermutlich war die Mail schrecklich zu lesen. Die Lizenz-Abteilung hat sofort zurückgeschrieben. Wir wissen nicht, was sie da getextet haben. Es ist auf jeden Fall verboten. Ich antworte, aber ich bin nur 25 und wir sind in Serbien. Niemand wird jemals von diesem Buch erfahren. Und dann habe ich peinlicherweise von Kleist gestohlen. Der Goethe bittet, den zerbrochenen Krug irgendwo spielen zu lassen. Auf den Knien meines Herzens bitte ich sie. Ja, ich fürchte, dass ich meiner ohnehin katastrophalen, unlektorierten E-Mail auf B2-Niveau Deutsch genau diese Worte hinzugefügt habe. Es hat aber funktioniert. Sie meinten, gut 500 Exemplare, keine weiteren Auflagen, keine Übersetzungen. Und die Autorin soll sich in Zukunft von solchen Projekten fernhalten. Die Autorin soll sich in Zukunft von solchen Projekten fernhalten. Das war eine unvergessliche Empfehlung, die mich sehr geprägt hat. Ich wusste dadurch, dass ich etwas richtig mache. Und die Geschichte ist natürlich dann, jetzt hält sie weiter, dass das Buch doch irgendwann ins Deutsche übersetzt wird. Und wo erscheint es? Natürlich im Thomas Bernhardt Verlag bei Suhrkamp. Das ist dann das Thema. In diesem Ton ist sehr viel geschrieben. Sie spricht über Prust, ihre andere große Inspirationsquelle. Und sie sagt dann auch selbstbewusst, ich bin wie Prust. Damit meine ich nicht reich und krank. Ich meine, dass auch ich wie Prust nichts erfinden kann. Ich habe lediglich eine kurze Sequenz aus dem Film von Percy Atlon aus dem Jahr 1981 beschrieben. Ich habe jahrelang allen Menschen, die mich zum Schreiben ausfragten, erzählt, dass auch ich nichts erfinden kann, als wäre das etwas, worauf man stolz sein sollte. Eine sichere Anekdote, die ich bei fast jedem Interview ausgepackt habe. Aber eines Tages fragte mich eine Slavistikprofessorin, wie ich das meinte, dass ich nichts erfände. Denn ich hätte immerhin ein Buch über drei Freundinnen mit magischen Superkräften und eines mit einer Zeitreise geschrieben. Sie sagte, dass sie hofft und glaubt, dass einiges davon erfunden sei. Da merkte ich erst, dass die Anekdote nur für Ausgehen gegolten hat und ich seitdem erfunden habe. Trotzdem ist es keine Lüge, wenn ich sage, dass jene Szene aus dem Film Celeste im Kern meines Schaffens liegt, zusammen mit einem weiteren Prostzitat, das mich lange verfolgt hat. Ich habe es eben schon mal zitiert. Unsere Wahrheit verändert sich für uns so sehr, dass andere sich in ihr schwer zurechtfinden können. Die Realität ist kompliziert. Die Realität muss man im Text hin und wieder bändigen, da sie wie das Aller Erfundenste wirkt. Nur weil etwas passiert ist, bedeutet das nicht automatisch, dass es der Wahrheit des Textes entspricht. Und sie beschreibt zum Beispiel eine Szene mit einem Betrunkenen. Dann kommt es zu einem dramatischen Unfall. Und sie erklärt, wie diese Szene sich vollzogen hat. Und wie diese dann zu Literatur wird. Und wie sie ein Detail aus der Szene rausnimmt, weil sie es zu übertrieben hält für die Literatur. Damit es der Realität besser angeglichen ist. Obwohl die Realität eigentlich das Übertriebene war. Sie beschreibt immer wieder, wie das ist eigentlich zu schreiben. Sie versucht, alles aufzuschreiben, was sie umgibt. Sie sagt, jetzt ist es mir egal, was die Poetikvorlesung von mir denkt. Also sie gibt der Poetikvorlesung selbst immer wieder Subjektstatus. Sie beschreibt so eine Ökonomie des Erzählens. Also wie sie jetzt einfach sagt, gut, ich schreibe jetzt einfach alles auf, dann ist die Poetikvorlesung fertig. Sie sagt dann, der Seufzer des Geschäftsmanns neben mir auf dem Bahnhof bleibt in der Poetikvorlesung. Also schreibt sie auf. In Belgrad, bevor ich von der sogenannten Demosine abgeholt werde, die mir das österreichische Kulturforum als Flughafentransfer organisiert hat, sitze ich bei einem Freund zu Hause. Er fragt mich, wissen die Leute in Salzburg, dass du einen Stand-up-Act schreibst? Das musste in die Poetikvorlesung. In Belgrad war ich eine ganze Woche, weil ich eine Lesung im Goethe-Institut und einen Auftritt an meiner alten Uni hatte. Dort habe ich die meisten Bilder gesammelt. Ein alter Straßenhund scheint seine Verkehrstauglichkeit verloren zu haben und geht ständig bei Rot auf die Straße. Der arme Hund bleibt in der Poetikvorlesung, obwohl er inzwischen wahrscheinlich tot ist.
Und sie ist wirklich jetzt erst 27 oder was?
Nein, nein, sie ist ja schon 2005 nach Wien gekommen und ist 1980 in Belgrad geboren. Hat also schon einige Werke vorgelegt. Und beschreibt hier natürlich ihr Werk, auf das man sehr große Lust bekommt. Aber ich finde, dass man hier nochmal so eine herausragende Behandlung von Sprach-ID. Wir haben diese ganzen LLMs und die können alles Mögliche generieren. Aber wirklich nochmal die Frage selbst aufzustellen, was ist denn eigentlich die Sprache für mich? Wie kann ich mir die Sprache aneignen? Wo bleibt sie mir fremd? Wo bleibe ich mir durch die Sprache fremd? All diese ganz, ganz wichtigen Dinge, die die Literatur nur auftun kann, die werden hier in der Poetik-Vorlesung, ich will nicht sagen verhandelt ist auch so ein hässliches Wort, die werden hier zum Thema. Und es ist immer so, dass sie nicht nur über etwas spricht, also indem man jetzt so literaturwissenschaftlich erklärt, Autoren macht dies und das, sondern sie macht es dann auch in diesem Moment. Also sie redet über Humor und macht dann etwas Humorvolles. Also der Text ist selbst auch immer gleich der Akt, der vollzogen wird. Und damit zu arbeiten ist wirklich ganz großartig, vor allem auch, weil man so erkennt, wie kann man überhaupt die Welt einfangen. So ein letztes Beispiel, dieses berühmte Buch, das den Preis gewonnen hat, Mini-Horror, da ist es so, als ich 2023 anfing, einen kleinen Band mit Horrorgeschichten zusammenzustellen, wollte ich hauptsächlich vom Alltag in Wien erzählen. Das Genre war eine logische Wahl in einer Zeit, in der Pandemie und Klimakrise die Hauptthemen waren, in der sich die Gesellschaft in unversöhnliche Gruppen gespalten hatte, je nach Art oder Umgang mit ihren Ängsten. Der Gegenstand erschien mir, jedenfalls aktuell und universell, und um nicht als Fremd abgestempelt und in eine Ecke geschoben zu werden, suchte ich nach Protagonistinnen, die möglichst vielen Menschen als Identifikationsfiguren dienen könnten. Mickey Mouse fiel mir ein, eine Figur, die auf der ganzen Welt beliebt ist und allen gehört. Mickey sei der bekannteste unbezahlte Schauspieler der Welt, soll Walt Disney über ihn gesagt haben. Ein kleiner Kerl, der immer sein Bestes versucht. Ich dachte, was für eine weirde Idee, Disney-Charaktere anzustellen im Buch. Aber ich will es ausprobieren. Und Minnie und Mickey haben sich in meinen einfachen Sätzen sofort zurechtgefunden. Sie haben sich dort eingenistet und bald das Geschäft übernommen. Dort, wo in meinem Text bisher ich war, frohlockten jetzt Mickey und Minnie. Und die Leserinnen entdeckten in ihnen sich selbst. Jetzt konnte ich über alles schreiben.
Ja, da hört man ja wieder raus, dass wir es mit einer Art Horen zu tun haben, die einfach, wie Thomas Mann sagt, der Text selbst ist das Substrat. Und die Welt drum rum ist halt so Ideengeber. Wo hat sie denn jetzt ihre Vorlesung, da ihre Podcastvorlesung gehalten?
Das war in Salzburg.
Ah ja. Okay, sehr gut. Nicht schlecht, sehr gut. Fast würde ich dich bitten, das Buch hier zu lassen, damit ich es dann lesen kann. Aber ich weiß schon wieder, dass ich es eh digital brauche.
Hier ist es tatsächlich ein bisschen schade, dass es das Hörbuch nicht gibt. Weil ich es auch gerne noch mal so gehört hätte, wie sie das in ihrem Duktus auch vorträgt. Denn sie hatten eine ganz tolle Rhythmik in der Sprache. Man hat sofort auch Lust, es laut zu lesen. Aber ja gut, man kann es sich laut vorlesen.
Bleiben wir bei meinem Metier und geben der Autorin recht. Denn man hat ja MIT Media Lab da jetzt diese Forschung gemacht, also mal richtig Köpfe verkabelt. Sich das angeschaut, Your Brain on ChatGPT. Es geht tatsächlich was verloren. Und die Aufgabenstellung ist ganz konkret auf Sätze schreiben. Also man hat 54 Studierende von vor Ort im Alter 18 bis 39, ist ja klar, die man einfach konkret die Aufgabe gegeben hat. Schreibe, du hast 20 Minuten Zeit. Und dieser ganze Text leitet ein mit Frank Herbert, Frank Herbert, also dem Dune Autor, denn einst überließen die Menschen das Denken der Maschinen in der Hoffnung, dies würde sie befreien. Aber das erlaubte nur anderen Menschen mit Maschinen, sie zu versklaven. Also wir sind hier ganz literarisch und auch gegen Sam Altman gleich beim Thema. Die Kernfrage hier ist, welchen Preis zahlt man für die neue Bequemlichkeit? Und zwar nicht in Bezug auf eine Aufgabe, die man ChatGPT gibt, sondern eine Aufgabe, die sich selbst im Leben stellt, die man dann assistiert mit ChatGPT. Denn es könnte ja sein, dass man zwar am Anfang sozusagen einen Bequemlichkeitspuffer plötzlich vorfindet und dann stellt man fest, zahlt sich am Ende gar nicht so aus. Ihr werdet also kognitive Prozesse im Kopf gegen kognitive Prozesse, sagen wir mal in der KI, gegenübergestellt. Und wenn wir jetzt immer sagen, die KI ist ja nur so ein Assistent, sie macht noch nicht so ganz eigenständig, autonom, sondern so als Assistent. Wie ist da eigentlich so die Aufgabenteilung und die Anstrengungsverteilung gegeben? Und vor allem auch im Zeitverlauf. Also hat man vielleicht am Anfang so ein kleines Hochgefühl, dass sich am Ende gar nicht so auszahlt. Die Aufgabe bestand darin, man hat sich so an den SAT-Standardtests orientiert. Es ging um Schreiben zum Thema Loyalität, Glück, Kunst und so. Und man hatte dann drei Gruppen. Eine LLM-Gruppe, die durfte also feuerfrei, wie im Mathe, du darfst die Taschenrechner benutzen, durften einfach grundsätzlich tpt benutzen. Dann gab es eine Suchmaschinengruppe, die durfte also Google-Suche benutzen, um sich inspirieren zu lassen. Und dann gab es eine Brain-Only-Gruppe, die keinerlei externe Hilfsmittel hatte beim Schreiben. Ich hätte mir gewünscht, dass man hier nochmal eine, wir legen dir ein paar Bücher hin, Lexikon, wie auch immer. Also so eine analoges Lesengruppe gibt. In dem Fall gab es sie nicht. Und dann hat man sich die Gehirnprozesse beim Schreiben angeschaut und später die Ergebnisse, also den Text, ausgewertet. Und auch die Protagonisten hier nochmal ins Interview verwickelt, wie sie selbst eigentlich zufrieden sind mit ihrer Arbeit. Und da stellte sich zum Beispiel heraus, dass die Zufriedenheitswerte sehr groß steigen, wenn man eine Beziehung hat zum eigenen Text. Wenn er aber nicht das Resultat des eigenen Vorgangs ist. Oder man sogar denkt, eigentlich habe ich mir was hinlegen lassen, das ging recht schnell und dann habe ich dagegen angearbeitet, um es mir zu eigen zu machen. Das ist schlecht. Also jeder, der glaubt, die Hausaufgabenleistung wäre damit zu erbringen, sich einfach das Ding zu... und dann redigiert man es noch schnell. Nein, man muss es anders konzipieren, ein bisschen verwobener. Ansonsten hat man es nämlich wirklich nur mit Redigat von fremden Texten zu tun. Und wenn Leute schon die wenig Erfahrung mit viel schreiben haben, sagen ich mag nicht so gerne schreiben, weiß man schon, also was die gar nicht mögen werden, ist fremde Texte zu bearbeiten. Und das ist aber die Herausforderung, die jetzt plötzlich kommt. Und das kann ganz schön frustrieren, wie hier in diesem Text drin steht. Also man hat eine Entfremdung, sie rennt von Essay Ownership, war bisher eine Selbstverständlichkeit eigentlich. Dass man, wenn man als Autor seinen Text schreibt, den dann auch mag, weil man ihn ja gestaltet hat und so, das muss hier erstmal wieder erarbeitet werden, dass man in einer Beziehung zusammen eignen. Ich würde jetzt sagen, Text ist jetzt auf diese Fragestellung bezogen. Menschen sitzen im Büro und machen Arbeit, von der sie eh schon entfremdet sind. Und jetzt holen sie sich noch LGBT rein. Und es ist ja nicht alles nur Rechnung schreiben, sondern manchmal muss man ja auch mal eine Konferenz vorbereiten oder was auch immer. Da würde ich dann auch sagen, diese alte Idee des Hausarztes, den Befund nochmal handschriftlich festzuhalten, ist vielleicht doch nicht so die allerschlechteste Idee, nur weil man es auch diktieren könnte oder so. Naja, die Brain-Only-Gruppe wies jedenfalls die robustesten und weitreichendsten neuralen Aktivitäten auf während des Schreibens. Da ist man nämlich nicht, wie bei der LLM-Gruppe, am Anfang in so ein Komfortding rein. Und dann wurde es plötzlich stressig am Ende. Also da hat man, am Anfang fühlt man sich gut, und am Ende, oh man, war das eine scheiße Arbeit, so ungefähr. Also das muss man sich dann im Zeitverlauf genau angucken, und was man sich da einlässt, wenn man sich zu früh irgendwas präsentieren lässt. Es gab menschliche Gutachter, zwei Englischlehrer, die sich die Texte angeschaut haben. Außerdem hat man noch eine KI-Auswertung gemacht und hat dann auch festgestellt, wenn die Texte schon mit Suchmaschine geschrieben werden, hat man eine hohe Konformität. Wenn man selbst schreibt, ist einfach jeder Text überraschend. Was eben, finde ich auch immer wieder, wir hatten ja bisher immer so Running Gags, Benotung in Deutsch. Vielleicht ist es schwierig, also in anderen Fächern ist es völlig normal, dass man so einen Maßstab hat für alle. Vielleicht sollte man auch im deutschen Unterricht sich noch mal so Varianzbereiche einfach anschauen, wie ist die Klasse so insgesamt drauf. Und umso größer die Abweichungen sind, umso erfolgreicher ist der Unterricht. Aber man muss halt die ganze Klasse begutachten dafür. Und nicht nur den Einzelnen und die Schreibleistung. Also irgendwie solche Sachen müsste man mal überlegen.
Also das meint jetzt, dass wenn die Varianz höher ist, dass das eigentlich ein Zeichen dafür ist, dass es gut klappt.
Genau, im Matheunterricht würde ich glauben, wenn alle dasselbe schreiben, super, waren alle richtig gut in Mathe.
Ja.
Und wenn jetzt in Deutsch plötzlich Hausarbeiten abgegeben werden und alle schreiben gleich gut so, dann scheint es da so ein, keiner hat mehr mitgedacht, Hintergrundphänomen zu geben.
Ja, ganz richtig.
Und deswegen lieber auf Spielraum und Varianz achten und so, als auf die einzige Benotung.
Das ist auch das Interessante an der Literatur, also dass die Literatur ja nicht einfach sagt, wir versuchen jetzt nochmal genau gleich zu machen. Also jetzt könnte ja Barbi Marković sagen können, wir haben eine Poetik-Vorlesung, wie hat die zu sein? Und dann guckt man einfach, wie die schon immer war. Dann schreibt sie aber jetzt eine besonders originelle Poetik-Vorlesung, denn so eine hat es da noch nicht gegeben. Und dass sie das so reflexiv einbauen kann zum Beispiel, dass sie darüber sprechen kann, dass die Poetik-Vorlesung selbst Subjektstatus hat und immer wieder mit dem Kopf schüttelt über die Autoren. Oder dass sie dann auch sagt, so was, wenn ich das noch gerade zitieren darf, wenn sie dann am Ende sagt, ich wollte eine Poetik-Vorlesung schreiben, die so gut ausgeführt ist, dass man sich denkt, das ist keine Poetik-Vorlesung. Genau diese Punkte bekommst du nicht hin mit einem LLM.
Ja. Also Originalität wird ein neues Desiderat sein, aber auch ein großes Einfallstor für Menschen, die es ernst meinen. Und zwar in ganz vielen Bereichen. Künstlerisch sowieso, aber auch so im Alltag einfach. Und sei es wirrigig in irgendwelchen Dating-Chats oder so. Weil das Angebot jetzt konform zu antworten, erwartbar zu antworten, zufriedenstellend zu antworten, das ist alles gegeben. Also das kann jeder jetzt einpreisen, aber originell zu antworten. Den Zwischenton nicht nur in Kauf zu nehmen, sondern zu forcieren und so. Da wird dir die KI ganz wenig helfen. Sie kann ja halt Beispiele und so, aber für das Konkrete brauchst du einfach diese Originalität. Weshalb ich ja auch sowieso immer darauf hinweise, wenn es jetzt heißt, GBT kann voll geil schreiben und so. Also es stimmt ja nicht. Es kann ja nicht so gut schreiben. Und man muss halt grundsätzlich sagen, fast niemand kann gut schreiben. Also wenn man jetzt anfängt mit 8 Milliarden Menschen, also wenn das der Maßstab ist, kann die KI schon richtig geil schreiben, weil 7,9 Millionen Menschen können echt total beschissen nur schreiben. Und das ist nicht der Maßstab, menschlich zu sein. Ja. Sondern da kommt es schon sehr drauf an, wer da schreibt.
Ich rette mich ja in die Sprachnachricht, wenn ich eine größere persönliche Nähe aufbauen will.
Stimme und Stimmung, genau. Und da kann jetzt jeder schon.
Ich schreibe auch ehrlich gesagt nicht gern, also ich texte nicht gern. Ich bin eher so funktional, schreibe morgen neun Uhr.
Ja, das ist jetzt interessant, denn die Bandbreite eines Textes ist nun mal gering. Man hat nur Buchstaben.
Du bist ja jemand, der gerne auch, also jetzt nicht mit allen Leuten, aber du bist ja schon jemand, hast du immer mal wieder hier deutlich gemacht, dass du zum Beispiel in einem Dating Zusammenhang auch bereit bist, viele Worte zu schreiben und in so einen richtigen Austausch hineinzugehen, während ich immer dann das direkte Gespräch vorziehen würde.
Ich würde so sagen, um die Poante daraus zu stricken, vielleicht, wenn jemand von mir eine Chatnachricht bekommt, die länger als fünf Sätze, kann er davon ausgehen. Ich bin gerade, ich blöde gerade. Das ist der einzige Grund, viel zu schreiben. Der Rest ist sehr runtergedampft auf Hallo, ciao, gut, okay, Daumen hoch. Ich will eine Anmerkung zu diesem Text hier noch machen. Ich habe die natürlich auch mit Gemini ausgewertet, denn es ist ein wissenschaftlicher Text, der ist sehr lang und da ist auch sehr viel Forschungsstand und so weiter. Aber mir ist während des Lesens so eine Fragestellung gekommen, die uns ja immer wieder unterkommt, wie zum Beispiel, mein Kind spielt zu viel, kann jetzt nicht mal Arte schauen. Man denkt sich so, also du wünschst dir jetzt, dass dein Kind Fernsehen schaut? War nicht vor zehn Jahren Fernsehen das böse Medium und du hättest dir gewünscht, dass es ein Buch liest. Und als es ein Buch gelesen hat, hättest du dir nicht gewünscht, dass es draußen spielt. Also das ist da so eine Verschleppung, der immer gleich eine Argumentation gibt. Und das ist, ich habe den Gemini gefragt, wie siehst du das bei diesem Text? Und Gemini so, und das finde ich witzig, weil Gemini ist ja von Google, dass Gemini sagt, ja, das ist schon interessant, wie hier die Suchgruppe verherrlicht wird. Also der Text ist darauf abgestimmt, die LLM-Gruppe entsprechend zu kritisieren und eine Operationalisierung darum zu bauen. Und nicht nur eine Brain-Only-Gruppe, sondern die MITler haben eben auch eine Google-Suchgruppe ein bisschen verherrlicht da drin. Und da habe ich dann Google gefragt, ob hier nicht Google zu viel verherrlicht wird und Google so, ja, wenn du also bei der Fragestellung, die du so gestellt hast, stimmt. Also vor zehn Jahren hätte man wahrscheinlich genau dasselbe so operationalisiert und hätte gesagt, also die Leute, die mal googeln, das ist ja total konform, was dann geschrieben wird und so. Das fand ich schon interessant, dass jetzt einfach nur, weil es eine neue Technik gibt, plötzlich das Googeln so in die Höhe gehoben wurde in diesem Text. Und dass mich Google dann darüber aufklärte und bestärkte, dass mein Eindruck da richtig ist.
Naja, ich will kurz auf einen Text hinweisen, der lang ist, sieben Seiten lang in der Tat zu erschienen. Also sieben Seiten, wenn man ihn ausdruckt. Von Nina Scholz, junge Inder in Deutschland, das Geschäft mit den Studis. Und zwar wird es vielen, die in Berlin sind, schon aufgefallen sein. Es gibt sehr viele Inder, die dort auf Fahrrädern unterwegs sind, um etwas auszuliefern. Und man fragt sich so, wie geht es denen eigentlich? In der Bildzeitung war da mal so ein Bericht darüber und da wurde das so dargestellt. Ja, das sind alles eigentlich Leute aus gutem Hause und die machen das da so, um ein bisschen Geld dazu zu verdienen. Nein, die Lage ist natürlich wahnsinnig prekär. Nina Scholz trifft Ritik Yadav. Er hat im Sommer 2022 vor dem Fernseh sitzend mit seiner Mutter beschlossen, ich muss für eine Universität ins Ausland. Ritik Yadav ist 22 Jahre zu diesem Zeitpunkt alt, hat schon einen Bachelorabschluss in Business Administration. Aber so richtig weiß er nicht, wie es weitergeht. Er hat auch schon eine kleine Firma aufgebaut. Aber die wirtschaftliche Situation in Kanpur, das ist im Nordosten von Indien, ist schwierig. Da ist es die Stadt, die einst ein Zentrum für Textilverarbeitung war, sei mittlerweile deindustrialisiert worden. Viele gut bezahlte Jobs gäbe es nicht mehr. Vor diesem Fernseher sitzen, sagen sie, Ausland wäre doch was. Deutschland, das sieht doch eigentlich gut aus. Denn es gibt da eine Werbung. Der Werbespot zeigt UpGrad. Das ist ein Berufsberater und in einem indischen Start-up für Online- und Auslandstudienvermittlung. Wenn man da vielleicht doch was möglich machen kann. Yadav sagt, er hat mir vorgeschlagen, also dieser Berufsberater, dass ich ein Master in Internationalen Management in Berlin mache. Mittlerweile leben in Deutschland 43.000 indische Studierende. Damit sind die Inder die größte Gruppe internationaler Studenten in Deutschland. Auch interessant an deutschen Universitäten.
Mit 43.000, bei zweieinhalb Millionen Studierenden, das sind zwei Prozent oder so.
Ja, größte Gruppe aus dem Ausland. Schon. Nancy Felser, wir wissen ja, man will ja sowieso mit Indien gut zusammenarbeiten, hat begonnen, damit da zarte Bande zu knüpfen. Sie sagt damals, wir stellen die Walchen dafür, dass qualifizierte junge Inderinnen und Inder in Deutschland studieren können. Nina Scholz fragt sich aber, stimmt das wirklich? Dieser Retik Yadav wird von Wohnung zu Wohnung ziehen. Weiter heißt es, Geldprobleme bekommen. Und er wird einer von den vielen indischen Kurierfahrern werden, die mittlerweile in Berlin das Stadtbild bestimmen. Sein Kommilitone Shivam Kumar hat ähnliche Erfahrungen gemacht. Doch bevor es für Retik Yadav nach Berlin geht, wird es noch ein ganzes Jahr dauern. Die ersten beiden Semester seines Masterstudiums bestehen nur aus Online-Seminer an, die er von der Wohnung seiner Eltern aus besucht. So sieht das Studienmodell der International University mit Standort in Berlin vor. Das Studium ist eine große Investition für Yadav und seine Familie. Er hat Indien noch nicht verlassen. Da hat er bereits über 22.000 Euro dafür ausgegeben. Im Oktober 2023 sei es für ihn dann endlich nach Berlin gegangen. Doch seine Studienzeit in der Hauptstadt verläuft anders, als er sich erhofft hat. Yadav ist enttäuscht, als er das Gebäude seiner Hochschule zum ersten Mal betritt. Das ist doch keine richtige Uni, habe er gedacht. Die Internationale Hochschule ist mit 130.000 Studierenden die größte Hochschule Deutschlands und sie ist privat. Hierzulande hat sie neben Berlin noch 38 weitere Standorte und bietet darüber hinaus auch ein Fernstudium an. Gründet wurde sie 1998 in Bad Honnef. Man hat sich, so steht jetzt hier im Text, offenbar ein Geschäftsfeld erschlossen mit diesen indischen Studierenden. Die Zahl ist stark in Berlin gestiegen. In Berlin studierten da 2020 noch 234 Inder. Heute sind es knapp 5000. Man verdient also viel Geld da. Aber auch wenn man in Berlin dann studiert, muss man plötzlich Online-Kurse besuchen. Ritig Yadav sagt, von den 18 Fächern, die ich belegt habe, fanden nur zwei auf dem Campus statt. Alle anderen waren online. Seine Dozenten würden oft gar nicht in Berlin leben, sagt er. Kurse würden manchmal ausfallen, weil die Internetverbindung schlecht sei. Für einen Kurs habe es nicht einmal einen Dozenten gegeben, nur Online-Videos. Da wird dann die Uni immer mal wieder befragt. Die sagt, nee, das läuft alles irgendwie doch besser. So sei das doch gar nicht. Wohnen, großes Problem. Er wohnt zunächst in einem Hostel. Dann ist er in so einer Chatgruppe. Da können die Inder sich untereinander sagen, ja, geh mal dahin, vielleicht hilft dir das. Dann trifft er jemanden, der will erstmal eine Vermittlungsgebühr von 1000 Euro, dann 1200 Euro Kaution, dann 1800 Euro Miete. Die Wohnung von Bilal, einem Mann, von dem Reti Yadav bis heute nur den Vornamen weiß, liegt in Moabit. Laut Yadav bietet Bilal in seinem WhatsApp-Status täglich mehrere solche möblierte Apartments überall in Berlin an. Yadavs erste Wohnung ist klein, 40 Quadratmeter. Gemeinsam mit drei anderen indischen Studierenden mietet er sie an. Sie teilen sich die Kosten. Zwei seiner Mitbewohner schlafen in der Wohnküche. Yadav und ein weiterer Mitbewohner teilen sich ein kleines Zimmer. Es gab keinen Platz zum Aufhängen der Kleidung. Ich musste den Koffer öffnen, um meine Sachen herauszunehmen und wieder hineinzulegen. Niemand von uns hatte einen Schreibtisch zum Lernen. Also zieht Yadav damals mit seinem Laptop von Kaffee zu Kaffee, von öffentlicher Bibliothek zu öffentlicher Bibliothek, um seine Online-Kurse zu machen. Denn es gibt auch keine richtige Bibliothek da auf diesem Campus. Es werden in dieser Gruppe irgendwelche Zimmer vermietet, die man sich zu viert teilen muss. Und trotzdem muss man 600 Euro Miete zahlen. Das möblierte Wohnen, wusste ich auch nicht, wächst allgemein in Berlin.
Ja, das ist eine ganz neue Masche.
In Berlin sei im Schnitt inzwischen bereits jedes dritte Mietangebot eine möblierte Wohnung, heißt es beim Vermittlungsportal Immobiliere Scout 24. Und für die gelten Regularien wie die Mietpreisbremse nicht.
Genau.
Im Durchschnitt werden möblierte Wohnungen in Berlin für über 25 Euro pro Quadratmeter angeboten. Unmöblierte nur 15 Euro.
Ja.
Man versucht natürlich dann auch mal hier die von der Tatsaus, also Nina Scholz versucht, die zu kontaktieren. Wie sieht dann eigentlich so Berlin und die Regierung und so was das Ganze? Ja, also da sei man ja jetzt nicht für zuständig. Mittlerweile, schreibt sie, warnen sich Inderinnen und Inder auch auf Social-Media-Plattformen davor, ein Studium an der Berliner IU zu beginnen. Avoid this university in Germany, rät der Account Mylingual Visa seinen Followern. Sollte mit dem Anwerben der indischen Studierenden nicht auch eine Verantwortung des Bundesinnenministeriums einhergehen? Ein Sprecher des Ministeriums antwortet auf Anfrage der TATS jedoch, dass das Migrationsabkommen zwischen Indien und Deutschland die Bundesregierung nicht dazu verpflichtet, Schritte zu unternehmen, um indischen Studierenden dabei zu helfen, die Voraussetzung für eine Aufenthaltserlaubnis zur Erwerbstätigkeit zu schaffen. Denn manche müssen, wenn sie sich um irgendwas nicht gekümmert haben, plötzlich wieder das Problem haben, dass sie nicht mehr bleiben dürfen und wieder gehen müssen. Visa werden einfach nicht verlängert. Und auch da die Frage, müsste sich da nicht das BMI darum kümmern? Nee, hat man nichts mit zu tun. Also man lockt Leute an und lässt sie allein und beutet sie noch mal maximal aus. Es ist wieder eine unglaubliche Geschichte.
Ja, vor allem eine, die halt so unter der Hand einfach passiert. Ich glaube, die Politiker wissen wirklich einfach gar nicht, was da passiert. Die lesen das in der Zeitung, wenn überhaupt.
Ja, und dann sagen sie, oh nee, da haben wir gar nichts zu tun.
So, allerdings brauchen wir noch menschliche Intelligenz, denn Apple klärt uns auf. The Illusion of Thinking. Sie machen sich auf den Weg, die Stärken und Limitationen dieser Reasoning-Modelle zu verstehen. Und damit ist ja gemeint, also Reasoning ist ja dieses neue Konzept, das Deep Seek mitgebracht hat. Nachdem man einfach einen Input in das Modell gibt und dann kommt ein Export und den liest man dann als Antwort, haben die ja gesagt, ne, wir können es ja miteinander verschachteln. Und dann ist die Maschine erstmal so im Selbstgespräch mit sich selbst, dokumentiert das so ein bisschen. Und ich lachte auch bislang, ah ja, das kann man mitlesen, also wird das wohl was sein, aber anscheinend sind die Maschinen da völlig, also das war bisher so gar kein Interessier, das wurde so mitdokumentiert, was die Maschine gerade so im Selbstgespräch klärt. Und dann kam das Ergebnis und dann hat man gesagt, okay, gut. Und Apple hat sich jetzt gesagt, okay, wir müssen uns das mal anschauen, was passiert denn da eigentlich? Ist das wirklich ein Gewinn, die so miteinander zu verschachteln oder wie auch immer? Und sie kommen drauf, nö. Und sie stoßen auch relativ früh, es schreiben sie schon zu Beginn, auf fundamentale Grenzen. Und das finde ich jetzt sehr interessant, denn mein Professor Stefan Kühl hat ja auch immer wieder darauf hingewiesen, ja, zeigt mir doch mal den Anwendungsfall. Und dann habe ich immer sehr vorsichtig darauf reagiert mit, naja, der Anwendungsfall sind erstmal so Alltagstätigkeiten. Ich will nicht, dass die KI für mich irgendwelche Proteine faltet, sondern ich will nur, dass die Literaturliste, die ich für ein Podcast schreibe, gut aussieht. Das ist also ein Anwendungsfall, der braucht eigentlich gar nicht so viel. Aber das Versprechen, und das hat ja Sam Altman für 2026 schon markiert, ist ja, dass man aus dieser, könnte auch ein Mensch machen, macht es aber nicht, weil Faul tatsächlich ein Mehrwert kommt, wo man nicht einfach sagt, könnte auch ein Mensch machen, weil, nee, es ist ein wissenschaftlicher Durchbruch. Und da sagt Apple hier einfach, nee, das sehen wir so gar nicht. Also erstens sehen wir diese wissenschaftlichen Fortschritte so nicht. Wir sehen sehr viel Alltagserleichterung, aber nicht bei irgendwelchen Forschungsabteilungen, die KI-unterstützt sind. Und wir glauben auch nicht, dass das geht, aus prinzipiellen Gründen. Also das ist sozusagen, deswegen haben sie es hier veröffentlicht. Die machen wahrscheinlich sehr viel mehr Forschung und haben sich dann hier gedacht, wir schreiben das mal zusammen. Dieser Status quo, den sie da heute aufgreifen, ist, dass es eigentlich gar keine richtigen Evaluierungsmethoden und Kriterien gibt, sondern man hat halt Benchmarks. Und Apple sagt dann hier ganz dort klar, also wenn die Benchmarks selbst bekannt sind, stecken sie auch in den Trainingsdaten dran oder zumindest in dem durch Search erreichbaren Daten, dann können wir mit den Ergebnissen nicht so richtig arbeiten, weil das ist ja so, als würde man die Betriebsanleitung mit zum Abitur geben. Schreib mal ab, so ungefähr. Da kommt man wenig weiter und sie sagen grundsätzlich, es gibt da auch gar keine Forschung dazu, erstens so eine Datenkontamination mal aufzubereiten oder sich überhaupt mal die Reasoning-Schritte Schritt für Schritt einzeln würdigend anzuschauen, sondern man hat das erst mal nur so miteinander verschachtelt, wie man grundsätzlich erst mal die Modelle intern miteinander verschachtelt und dann hat man halt Ergebnisse gehabt, die irgendwie präsentabel sind. Also war es sofort ein Produkt. Ich habe zum Beispiel auch gelesen, der Ilja Sutzkever, den wir damals beim Alignment und so behandelt haben, der hat ja dann in diesem Streit mit Sam Altman Open AI verlassen und ist jetzt selber seit dieser Woche Chef von seiner High Security Firma, die solche Modelle baut. Die haben gerade eine Marktbewertung von irgendwie 40 Milliarden Dollar einfach durch Geldzufluss und haben aber gar kein Produkt. Und dann war die Frage, wie geht denn das und so? Und er sagt, naja, wir machen hier Forschung. Klar, könnten wir jetzt ein Modell veröffentlichen und das macht dann irgendwas, aber wir wollen ja erst verstehen, was es tut. Also ist deren Konsequenz, einfach gar kein Produkt zu haben. Das finde ich auch interessant. Ja, das wäre wirklich so. Man muss immer einen GPT sagen. Sorry, aber nehmt das nochmal alles zurück. Schaut euch das nochmal an. Also so ungefähr. Also Apple ist hier wirklich sehr streng. Ich habe dann auch, ist ja auch ein sehr langer Text, ich habe ihn mir angehört.
Na ja, im Prinzip ist es doch dann wie bei Pfizer. Wir haben das Versprechen auf eine Impfung oder vielleicht ein Medikament gegen Krebs und man investiert da hinein, aber noch war ja auch kein Produkt da, bis dann mit der Impfung was geschah.
Genau, also bei Pfizer wurde auch einfach re-kombiniert. Wir haben ein Versprechen. Wir kennen ja den genetischen Code, gegen den wir anarbeiten und wir haben Methoden, die vielversprechend sind. Sie hatten dann relativ zügig die Impfung, war ja nach drei Tagen oder so, und dann musste man das aber testen. Weil auf den Menschen zulassen kann man einfach so, wir haben ein Produkt ja nicht, sondern das muss den ersten.
Ich meine jetzt nur den Schritt davor, weil du jetzt sagst, da sind 40 Milliarden Wert. Ist da gemessen und erst mal ist Pfizer irgendwas wert. Aber man hat auch noch nicht das Produkt gehabt. Das kam dann natürlich später. Genau.
Sie machen Studien, intern. Also es gibt ein funktionierendes Modell, das ist ja klar, dass sie ein Modell haben, ist ja klar, es ist ja offenbar doch nicht so schwer, wie behauptet wurde. Aber sie lassen das, sie impfen noch nicht die allgemeine Bevölkerung damit. Also es scheint da Firmen zu geben, die einfach anders damit umgehen, je nachdem wie sich Apple dann irgendwann mal platziert. Wir wissen ja auch, dass Apple immer sehr viel Forschung macht, die nicht veröffentlicht wird. Die haben ja jetzt auch bei den letzten Presse-Terminen wieder auch so Interviews mit normalen Podcastern und so gegeben, wo sie ganz offen darüber reden, dass sie Qualitätsvorstellungen haben und Testabläufe. Und es hat einfach nicht gematcht. Während wir von GPT wissen, die haben keine Testabläufe. Also die veröffentlichen einfach auf der Webseite ihr Modell und dann kann man es benutzen. Also Apple hier sehr streng. Ich habe dann Gemini auch nochmal gefragt, Apple, da läuft es ja gerade nicht so erfolgreich mit der KI-Forschung und so, jedenfalls nicht mit der Produktentwicklung. Schlägt sich das im Text irgendwie nieder? Nö. Also hat Gemini da keinen Ansatz irgendwo gefunden. Das mal so kritisch zu betrachten, fand ich auch interessant. Ich hätte gedacht, Apple macht nochmal so den ein oder anderen politischen Kommentar. Da wir ja auch auf politische Kommentare warten, ehrlich gesagt. Und wenn jemand mit so einem, da gibt es fundamentale Grenzen. Und das sollte man sich vielleicht doch nochmal auch in der Forensik anschauen, wie evaluieren wir das eigentlich? Kann man das einfach so veröffentlichen? Aber da haben sie sich zumindest zurückgehalten. Es ist also einfach nur beschrieben, was sie hier sehen. Und die Erkenntnisse sind, das Denken dieser Maschine, wenn es so verschachtelt wird, kann einfach komplett kollabieren. Alle getesteten Modelle, auch die fortschrittlichsten, versagen. Und es gibt Grenzen, ab denen fällt die Genauigkeit einfach auf Null. Also man hat Aufgaben. Und sie überdenken sich dann so Puzzle-Aufgaben aus, ganz bewusst, damit es die überhaupt gar nicht gibt. Und selbst wenn sie das Ergebnis nicht verraten, aber die Schritt-für-Schritt-Anleitung, sodass also das Modell, das ja selbst das Reasoning durchläuft, also Schritt für Schritt im Selbstgespräch, ein Zwischenergebnis weiter ausarbeitet, selbst wenn es eine Anleitung für den Rechenweg der Zwischenschritte bekommt, führt es trotzdem nicht zu dem Ergebnis. Also relativ zügig hat man es mit Fragestellungen zu tun, die einfach nicht erledigt werden können von diesen Maschinen. Und sie gehen natürlich einfach die Bandbreite durch. Aber ich würde sagen, ja, also da kann man schon mal Schluss folgern, dass das einfach fundamentale Hürden sind, an denen man da irgendwie steht. Da braucht jemand noch mal eine andere Idee. Na ja, also in deren Sicht Apple hier sehr deutlich, sehr objektiv nach der Einschätzung der KI. Und mir ist jetzt auch nichts aufgefallen. Und selbst exakte Lösungsalgorithmen im Prompt selbst verbessern die Leistung nicht. Was man sieht, ist Overthinking. Das Ergebnis ist eigentlich schon gefunden, aber die Maschine rechnet einfach weiter, übersieht also, worum es eigentlich ging und verschwendet dann auch noch Energie. Oder sie postulieren dann hier auch so eine Art Faulheit. Die Maschine weiß irgendwie so nicht weiter und dann läuft das so leer. Und dann hat man eigentlich hier noch genug Tokens übrig gelassen, so, aber wird gar nicht mehr verwendet. Also es ist sehr interessant. Vielleicht ist es gar nicht so schlecht, dass wir ein Unternehmen auf dieser Augenhöhe haben, das einfach sagt, ne, Hype ist gut und schön und wir versprechen uns da auch viel. Aber stopp mal Leute. Vor allem weil die halt wirklich, also ich verstehe das ja auch bei Apple. Wir haben ja ein echtes iPhone in der Hand und wollen hier das konkret, was auf dem Display erscheint. Wir können uns das ja nicht erlauben, dass einfach, so wie GTPT jetzt einfach sagt, guckt mal, wie überraschend unser Ergebnis ist. Also ja, die Überraschung ist da. Wir lassen uns gerne Überraschungen. Farbenfroh, Bilder, was auch immer. Nur häufig im Leben wollen wir halt gerade nicht überrascht werden, sondern wir wollen gegen die Überraschungen anarbeiten mit Hilfe von Werkzeugen. Und wenn diese Werkzeuge das nicht können, sondern einfach nur, ah ja, du hast schon drei Überraschungen, hier, ich habe noch eine für dich, ja, dann führt das natürlich zu nichts. Also Apple scheint hier auf dem richtigen Weg zu sein für die eigene Fragestellung, die man da hat, nämlich ernsthafte, produktive Lösungen zu haben, statt einfach nur so Gimmicks. Und ich nehme nichts zurück von dem, wie ich es benutze und wo es mir weiterhilft und so, ja. Aber das sind wirklich überschaubare Aufgaben. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich das nicht an, was weiß ich, ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, einen Hospitanten zu haben, der mir ein paar Sachen erledigt. Aber also in der Produktion, ja, Manufaktur auch, Research and Development. Da scheint KI irgendwie nicht sehr viel weiter zu helfen. Fundamentale Barrieren für generalisierbares Denken sind hier markiert.
Da bleibt uns nur die Musik. Ich empfehle...
Bevor du die Musik, würde ich gerne einen Eintext einfach nur nennen. Muss nicht groß ausgebreitet werden. Aber zu diesem alles, was über Trump wissenswert ist, steht in der Zeitung und was da nicht steht, weiß auch Trump noch nicht. Also ich werde euch diesen Text auch mal verlinken. Den kann man ruhig mal so als Standardargumentation, dass es die Poente mitlaufen lassen. Denn wir können uns nicht erlauben, uns die Zeit noch mehr zu vertreiben mit irgendwelchen Erklärungsbüchern, die uns irgendwas darstellen, was nicht ist. Ja, so, Musik.
Ich empfehle das Simply Quartet. Ich habe dieses wunderbare Streichquartett auch schon mal live gehört und kann das auch nur jedem empfehlen, das mal zu tun. Aber man kann sich auch sehr erfreuen an der Einspielung. Sie haben nämlich sowohl das Streichquartett in G-Dur, Op. 106 von Antonin Dvořák eingespielt, als auch von Felix Mendelssohn das Streichquartett in F-Moll, Op. 80. Und auf das würde ich ein bisschen mehr eingehen. Dvořák ist auch ein wunderschönes Werk, ein Resümee seines Schaffens. Es ist ein spätes Streichquartett. Ich glaube, sein letztes Streichquartett und er zeigt noch mal alles, was er kann. Er nimmt auch vieles, auch sein Werk noch mal auf. Aber ich würde gerne über Mendelssohn sprechen, weil es für mich ein Werk ist, das mich besonders berührt hat. Gerade auch in dieser Einspielung, die so sehr transparent und dabei zugleich leidenschaftlich ist, die ja ein ganz dramatisches Werk uns vergegenwärtigt. Denn Mendelssohn richt in einem Schmerzenschrei aus, als seine Schwester Fanny ganz plötzlich stirbt. Sie ist vollkommen überraschend an einem Gehirnschlag erlegen. Und es wird nicht lange dauern, bis auch Felix Mendelssohn-Bartoldi an einem Schlaganfall sterben wird. Er hat eine ganz besondere Beziehung zu seiner Schwester, auch weil sie ja beide komponiert haben. Und er ist erst mal gar nicht in der Lage zu komponieren. Aber dann doch irgendwann kommt dann dieses Streichquartett aus ihm heraus. Man muss das nicht jetzt nur vor dieser biografischen Kulisse lesen. Man kann das natürlich auch machen. Es ist jedenfalls ein äußerer Anlass, der dann dazu führt, dass Felix Mendelssohn, dessen Musik man oft auch als Heiter beschrieben hat, wenngleich das vielleicht immer ein bisschen zu flach ist, ihn als Heiter zu bezeichnen, ist das jedenfalls etwas, wo er sehr da ausbricht. Denn dieses Allegro vivace assai, also der erste Satz, beginnt damit, dass wirklich die Geigen zittern und beben. Dass fast nichts mehr zusammengehalten wird, so hat man den Eindruck. Ruckartig brechen sie auf. Immer wieder entstehen Klangflächen, die dann unterbrochen werden von Schreien und Weglagen. Also beim Streichquartett haben wir die erste Geige, zweite Geige. Wir haben eine Pratsche und ein Cello. Und das Cello ist immer wieder so, dass es auch Dinge zerreißt. Dass man glaubt, jetzt entsteht wieder was Ganzes und trotzdem wird es unterbrochen. Der zweite Satz ist dann so angelegt, dass da mit sehr vielen Synkropen gearbeitet wird. Es entstehen so Verzögerungen, ein noch nicht ganz. Und immer wieder auch diese unglaubliche Geschwindigkeit, diese Dynamik, die überraschend ist. Im dritten Teil dann, im dritten Satz, dem Adagio wird es alles ruhiger. Und wir erleben dann, wie ja so die Instrumente so ja kurz Melodien produzieren, sie überlagern das. Das sind so überlagerte Gesänge, die aber doch immer wieder abbrechen müssen. Man könnte jetzt biografisch lesen, der Schmerz ist zu groß. Und dann im vierten Akt gibt es nochmal eine furiose Einlage. Es gibt ja dieser dieser Versuch nochmal, die ganze Dramatik des Ereignisses deutlich zu machen. Aber es ist dann auch der Punkt, in dem sich diese Komposition eben von ja dem so immer wie dem löst, was man jetzt irgendwie typisch für Mendelssohn bezeichnen würde. Ja, das kommt aus der Romantik, aber Mendelssohn führt das dann doch zu irgendwelchen Teilen hin, zu Tonarten, die schon auf irgendwas anderes noch hinweisen. Das ist so ein Werk, das aus dem Mendelssohn schaffen ausbricht, aber auch so aus der Zeit schon sehr ausbricht und viel auch im 20. Jahrhundert hineinweist mit dem Disharmonischen, was wir da so vernehmen können. Und es ist einfach ein Werk, das sagt, ich kann nicht mehr jetzt in so einer großen, übergeordneten Struktur arbeiten, sondern das Fragmentierte, das ist eigentlich das, was auch das Prinzip der Komposition sein muss. Und ich bin wirklich begeistert davon, mit welcher Dynamik das gespielt wird. Denn da sind nicht nur große Intervallsprünge, da sind auch erstaunliche Tempiewechsel drin. Es ist sehr, sehr leidenschaftlich umgesetzt, aber wie schon gesagt, mit einer höchsten Präzision. Also hier wird nicht einfach so auf den Effekt herausgespielt, sondern es wird auch alles dann wieder zurückgenommen, um auch so präzise zu zeigen, wie ein Rhythmus funktioniert. Also es gibt immer, da muss man immer darauf achten, so Rhythmen, die sich wiederholen. Ich hab's jetzt im Kopf nicht so gut parat, aber es geht dann... Und plötzlich taucht das im Cello auf oder ist dann in den Geigen und dann bricht es wieder ab und dann geht es nochmal woanders hin und dann taucht es doch wieder auf und es hat fast so etwas Schicksalhaftes, dass es doch nicht aufzuhalten ist. Da ist etwas, was nicht mehr einzufangen ist, was auch der Mensch in gewisser Weise nicht mehr in der Hand hat. Also ich empfehle dieses Streichquartett und auch das von Dvořák sehr, empfehle diese Einspielung sehr, das Simply Quartet mit dieser wunderbaren CD bzw. man kann es natürlich auch überall streamen.
Sehr gut. Also nochmal mein Night, weil du ja heute Abend wieder...
Heute geht's zu Alcina.
Live-Musik bekommst, in der am Ende auch Spezialapplaus für die erste Geige-Solo und das Cello gespendet wird.
Und was man hier auch sehen kann ist, vier Instrumente reichen aus. Also das klingt so symphonisch an manchen Stellen, dass man gar nichts fassen kann, dass es nur vier Instrumente sind, die das jetzt gerade erzeugen.
Mhm. Sehr gut.
Wir sehen uns dann am Ende des Monats wieder.
So ist es. Mal sehen, was bis dann passiert. Bis dann.